Facebook Twitter Instagram YouTube and
Linkedin are the top us social media
platforms as per the reports on the web
YouTube mobile has
868 million users this shows that social
media platforms can be easy Marketplace
to highlight products and services with
great marketing strategies one can get
immense growth in the business today
with this social media marketing crash
course we will take a deep dive into
marketing strategies for various social
media platforms like Facebook YouTube
Pinterest and Instagram on that note if
you are looking to learn social media
marketing and become a digital marketing
expert then look no further than the
simply learns post-graduate program in
digital marketing gain in-depth
knowledge of search engine optimization
also with this course you will learn
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
optimization and more unlock the whole
toolbox of skills including SE ranking
hoot suit Facebook Instagram LinkedIn
YouTube Twitter Google ads and Keyword
Planner don't miss out on this
opportunity Find The Cost Link in the
description box for more information so
before we begin consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us so let's
get started by knowing what is social
media marketing over to our tutors and
in today's video we're going to talk
about social media marketing for those
people that are not really familiar with
what social media can do for you and for
your business this is the course that
you want to uh want to watch so we're
going to talk about what it is what you
need to know where is social media going
how do you f how do you develop your own
social media strategy and we will also
do a quick rundown of the most important
social media channels but before we
start let me introduce myself I am Mark
kman I am your digital navigator for
this video and if you like today's video
why don't you like the video by clicking
below and also if you want to subscribe
to our Channel click on the Subscribe
button below we would love you to be
part of our community so let's get
started are you ready for this let's
check out the topics that we will be
discussing in a bit more
detail yep we're going to be starting
with discussing the trends in social
media what is happening where is it
going what are the most social media
networking platforms and what do we see
happening in the future we will also
look at the definition of social media
marketing it is important that you
understand what social media marketing
is and what it can do for you yeah and
we look at what it the importance for
your business business um and you will
also learn why you basically can't go
without social media marketing these
days yep so that's what we will be
looking at and next we will be looking
at how to develop your social media
marketing strategy yeah we're going to
look at a very simple five-step process
that you can follow to develop your
social media marketing strategy for your
business or for your personal brand next
we will be looking at the different
social media marketing platforms we will
be looking at Facebook at Twitter at
Instagram LinkedIn Pinterest Etc and
we're going to look at where are they
where are they what people are using the
platforms and I'll maybe cover some of
the cool features of the various social
media platforms that you can use as a
business we will close this with looking
at the pros and the cons of social media
marketing there's lots of benefits you
can get from it but hey of course there
are some negatives to it as well and
then I will close with giving you some
answers to questions that I get asked a
lot when I run this social media
marketing introduction so that will give
you a full overview of what social media
marketing is and how you can benefit
from it for your own business or when
you are a um uh freelancer for your
client's business or for yourself as a
social media expert or any expert that
you um that you are positioning yourself
as so that's the introduction let's get
going into the action so let me start
with a simple
question out of these four social
networking apps which one do you think
is the old one out yeah when you look at
Facebook Instagram YouTube and WhatsApp
which one is the odd one out from a
social media networking app
perspective yep and the right answer of
course is WhatsApp because WhatsApp is a
messaging platform yeah and what does a
messaging platform do in between social
media platforms like Facebook Instagram
and YouTube well very simple the answer
is is that WhatsApp and messenger
Facebook Messenger for instance nowadays
are considered social media apps as well
yeah so in WhatsApp you can communicate
and engage with your friends and with
groups um you can promote your business
in there so they are fully blown social
media networks yeah just a little trivia
to get the the jues going so there we
have it so what I always do when I talk
about social media marketing yeah I've
um I'm talking about Trends from a from
a quite a generic
perspective I've been in digital
marketing social media from the very
early days yeah I was one of the first
to demo the internet when I worked in
Silicon Valley in
1995 yeah we call when the web was
launched in
1995 we talked about the presentation
web yeah you created a website for your
business to present your business and
that was what the web was it was very
much like one way you could go on the
web and you could find any information
that you like yep and that you need it
now in the early 2000s we saw Web 2.0
emerging which is the conversational web
yeah and in the conversational web we
saw social media coming yep so was
Facebook was Twitter there were some um
some other social media networks that no
longer exist but it was all about
getting into
conversations with your clients or with
um with other people that share similar
interest so that was the conversational
web and that led to the growth the
phenomenal growth of social media and
then nowadays today we're talking about
web
3.0 yep and web 3.0 is what we call the
virtual reality web Facebook bets
heavily on the virtual reality web
through the
metaverse it's that important for
Facebook that they even changed their
name as a company they are now called
meta as a company so the meta first is
Mark Zuckerberg's Vision to actually
meet people in a virtual world and you
can see each other in this virtual world
currently probably still with virtual
reality glasses or a virtual reality
headset but where will the future go yes
so instead of typing text or sharing
photos in your news feed you're stepping
into a virtual world where you can meet
your friends anytime
anywhere so really exciting still a long
way to go but consider that web 3 3.0
and social being interaction engagement
is a core part for that yeah social
media although social media websites
social media platforms may come and go
the basic concepts of social media they
are here to stay yeah social media has
led to a fundamental change in the Way
businesses engage with their clients
yeah and how they interact with their
clients and we'll get deeper into that
when we go into the definition of social
media marketing for now let's look at
where we are today with the social media
networks and I always use this slide for
that it is the most popular social media
networks worldwide by monthly active
users and I want to emphasize the
monthly active users because that is
what is of interest I'm not interested
in how many people have subscribed to a
network there may be robots that have
subscribed to it yeah what I am
interested in is that how many people
are actually using it on a monthly
basis and you can very clearly see yeah
Facebook of course is the biggest social
media Network platform but if I look at
this slide I see three major
Trends the first trend I see is the
sheer size of
Facebook yeah because Facebook is not
just number one when it comes to social
media networks worldwide but there is
also WhatsApp on number three there is
Instagram on number four and there is
Messenger um as well yes so you see the
share size of Facebook is enormous and
they are driving the changes in social
media lens although some of the
Innovation may come from other social
media
networks yeah the um the big Drive is
from
Facebook the second Trend that I see
here is if I look at number two which is
YouTube yeah to me that says video is
one of the most important types of
content being used used in social media
these days if I combine that with the
importance that Facebook gives to video
yeah there's no doubt that video is the
preferred type of
communication on social media networks
and let's look at ourselves yeah we
prefer to watch a video than read a
lengthy article yep with um about a
particular topic so if you are not on uh
video in your social media marketing
strategy you're really missing out on a
tremendous
opportunity yep so that's Trend number
two the importance of video and the
third Trend I see is the importance of
messaging there you see number three is
Messenger you see number five is um
there is Facebook Messenger there's also
WeChat from China yeah so it is very
important these days to understand that
messenger is considered a key key social
media platform and that businesses use
messenger in their communication and the
power of using messaging in your
marketing Outreach is that it allows you
to have oneon-one
conversations with your customers you
can reach an
audience yeah you can reach a big
audience through Messenger but once they
respond you get into personalized
conversations and that is how Faceook is
seeing messenger yeah as where in
messenger you have your onetoone
communication with your best sort of
friends where on Facebook platform
itself you more have like Community T
style
conversations okay so another few things
that you see in this slide is the of
course the emergence of the Tik Tok yeah
you see the presence of um Snapchat of
Twitter of Pinterest but the main thing
that I miss here actually is where is
LinkedIn on this
chart and if I look at the original
graphic of this chart you see that
LinkedIn is in there and remember
LinkedIn May probably have more than 300
million subscribers but not all
subscribers are actively engaging and
using the platform on a monthly basis so
from a monthly active user perspective
LinkedIn does not feature on this chart
and that is one of the biggest
challenges that LinkedIn has yeah to get
people to engage with the
platform we'll come back to all these
social media networks later where I'm
going to give you a quick overview of
what it what it is and what it
does okay so let's have a look look at
what social media marketing actually
means what is it yeah and we got to put
this in the context of the definition of
marketing yeah I studied Marketing in
the very early days in the 80s and um my
main sort of uh Guru in marketing was
Philip Cotler and over the years
marketing has sort of developed from
traditional marketing to online
marketing but the basic concept has not
changed if you look at the definition of
marketing it's the activity of creating
communicating delivering and exchanging
offerings that have value for
customers yeah so you supply you deliver
you exchange products or services that
have a value for your customers
so two very important aspects here there
is value and there is customer and that
is what we capture in the marketing
concept you put the customer at the core
of what you do yeah because when you do
that you automatically will look at what
value are we giving to the
customer yep so take social media
marketing in that context then the
second part of the social media
marketing sort of term is the word
social media what is social media when I
explain social media I'm using the three
C's the three C's of social media
marketing and they are content they're
community and
campaigns content is the fuel of your
social media content is the um the
currency of social media if you have
really good content that you can share
on the
internet yeah using various multip
multiple social media channels like
Facebook like YouTube or like video or
like Instagram or blogging you name it
yeah people will engage with your
content
and then when people start engaging with
your content they may come back for more
content that you supply and they will
then become part of your community so
Community is a very important aspect of
your social media definition with really
good content you can create
communities and then you can push that
process by running
campaigns yeah and a campaign makes it
relevant for
businesses because when you run a
campaign you have a goal for your
campaign you have an objective you have
a start date you have an end
date yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting
content and then you put it into the
marketing context you do that it with a
customer at in the core of what you
do yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media
marketing is very basic it says the use
of social media to develop a company's
brand increase website traffic and boost
sales that is what we call social media
marketing yeah the most important
important aspect here is that you need
to have an outcome you need to have a
result which is customer
related and that is where the sales
element comes in you do this to get the
customer to do something and in the end
that is buying your product or your
service yeah so social media marketing
is not the Tactical
combination of your social media
networks yeah to um to reach as many
people there needs to be a goal to it
and when we talk about marketing it
comes down to selling your product or
service with a
value yeah so that is the um kind of the
call to action as it were that comes out
of your social media marketing so keep
that in mind everything you do with your
social Media Marketing in the end comes
down to reaching your goals or achieving
your objectives of developing your
company's brand increasing website
traffic or growing your
sales now a big benefit that you're
getting these days in digital marketing
and social media marketing is data is
intelligence is
knowledge in the early days of marketing
the biggest problem has always been how
to measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and they write about me
in the newspaper how do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I Ran So in the early pre-
interet days yeah we the only way to
measure customer engagement as it were
were through Loyalty cards or credit
cards yeah with a loyalty card you had
some basic customer data through credit
cards you could track transactions but
it's very difficult to relate it to
marketing then the internet emerged and
all of a sudden I could track traffic to
my
website yeah I could see how many people
visit my website are these people that
visit my website for the first time are
they returning visitors what are the
most popular pages that they see how
long do they stay on my website and are
they actually buying my
product yeah so that was a major
advancement of marketing
in the early 2000s and then when social
media emerged it all of a sudden became
possible to measure
engagement how many people are having
conversations with us I could even
measure sentiments are people positive
about my brand are they negative about
my Brands I could track the
effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns I could measure the
effectiveness of my advertising
campaigns that I ran online so today's
reality is that we can measure
everything we can measure clicks we can
measure transactions we can measure
engagements we can measure return on
investments yeah and we can now even
take that a step further through
artificial intelligence that we can
actually start making predictions how
people may respond to campaigns that
we're going to be running so it's a very
important aspect of your digital uh your
social media
marketing so as I mentioned earlier
social media is a completely new way for
businesses to engage with their
customers yeah you can no longer go
without it it's a new channel to Market
it is a new channel for engagement with
your customers it is a new channel to
learn it's a new channel to listen to
find out what's happening in the market
so it's now it's it's it's there in
every aspect of your business and not
only for the marketing department it's
there for the sales department it's
there for Logistics it's there for the
customer service department is there for
the HR department using social media for
your recruitment is a very important
element of social media marketing yes so
keep that in mind that social media
marketing is no not a fat it is there
and it's there to stay and it touches
every aspect of your
business now to summarize this there are
three areas where social media has
changed the way businesses operate first
of all there is the connection social
media is a new way to connect with your
stakeholders yeah and stakeholders in
this case can be customers they can be
prospects influencers your own employees
using social media for
internal and not only on a local scale
this happens nowadays on a global scale
the internet allows you to sell locally
to a global audience if you want to yeah
so it can you
can cover the world you can Target
specific audiences wherever they are so
the connection aspect the targeting
aspect yeah the the market where you
want to sell your product is opened up
through social media and that is a big
benefit for
business the second area where social
media has changed businesses
fundamentally is in the interaction site
it's not just about connecting with your
stakeholders you can also interact with
them and they can interact with you on
their terms on their preferred platform
and remember in social media land the
customer is in the driving seat if
you're not interacting with them on
their terms you're going to miss the
train it's not about you don't liking
Facebook or
LinkedIn yeah as long as your customers
are on Facebook you better be on
Facebook otherwise you're going to miss
the
boat yeah because if you don't interact
with them they will move on to your
competitors who are very likely engaging
with
them yep so it's the connection aspect
it's the interaction aspect and then the
third part is the customer data aspect
all of this we what we talked about can
be done and you can track every aspect
of your social media marketing at a
customer level and it gives you the key
performance indicators like conversion
ratios sales ratios customer
satisfaction ratios and ultimately
return on
investment and there are tools nowaday
that let you manage and track all these
areas in one conglomerated system yeah
HubSpot is for instance a tool that you
can use for that and they integrate all
your marketing and customer data data
and campaigns in one system that um you
can use for
that so now Having learned about these
sort of fundamentals of social media
marketing let's now have a look at how
do you put together your social media
marketing strategy how do you set it up
how do you develop it now with my over
40 years of experience in marketing
digital marketing and social media I
developed a simple fstep methodology to
set your business or to set up yourself
for social media and it's called
flirt yeah and flirt is an acronym flirt
the first letter the f is for
Focus yeah and in the focus
face what you do you look at various
things the first thing you do in
developing your social media marketing
strategy is look at what is your
Niche what Market are you
targeting and the more you focus in your
Market your targeting your Niche the
easier it will be to reach
them yes so it's very important that you
focus on a very particular
Niche once you've identified that Niche
you look at your
positioning why should they buy from you
what is your unique value proposition
remember the definition of marketing
yeah the value for your customer is key
in this and you put it in what we call a
positioning St
statement you also look at your
customers you create customer
personas where you look at your
customers and you kind of map their
interests their uh pain points the
typical questions that they would ask so
you get a good understanding of your um
your
customers yes so you look at your Niche
you look at your positioning you look at
your focus or sorry you look at your
customers yep and then you're going to
ask yourself why am I going to use
social
media yeah am I going to use it to build
awareness am I going to use it to drive
traffic to my website am I going to use
it to generate
sales am I going to use it to improve
customer service am I going to use it to
recruit new staff am I going to use it
to communicate with my um my
employees yeah so lots of reasons why
you could use social media and it's your
challenge to identify one or two
objectives for your social
media and then a very important aspect
of your social media marketing strategy
even your overall digital marketing
strategy what are the key keywords that
you will be focusing on in other words
what are the keywords that you want to
be recogn recognized for Google wants to
know Facebook wants to know LinkedIn
wants to know and it's all about
repetition the more often you use those
keywords the more those social media
platforms and Google will associate you
with those keywords when people search
for them they will then show you higher
up in the search results we call this
search engine optimization or search
engine
marketing yeah so keywords is like a
whole course in itself but it's very
important part of your social media
marketing strategy in the focus phase so
that is the F for Focus think about your
Niche your positioning who is your
customers why are you on social media
and what are your main
keywords the next is the L for
listen listen is so
important yeah we tend to talk too
much yeah where social
media can give you fantastic listening
opportunities and when I say listen I
mean read articles
online listen on Facebook and on Twitter
on LinkedIn listen on
Google yeah watch videos listen to
podcasts there's dozens of ways that you
can listen online because when you
listen you learn and when you learn you
get better and you develop so what does
that mean from you some practical tips
when it comes to listening first you
need to listen to where your customers
hang out are your customers on Facebook
are they on Twitter are they on LinkedIn
and later in this session when we go
through the various social media
platforms I'll give you an overview of
what type of people are on the various
social media
platforms the next thing that you want
to know when you listen is who are your
top 10 bloggers or influencers in your
Niche do you know your top 10 bloggers
do you know your top Instagram
influences because you want to learn
from them but you may also want to build
relation with them to use them in your
marketing
Outreach you also want to look at the
trends in your Niche Google Trends is a
really useful tool that you can check to
to find out what are the trends in your
Niche and you're looking at your
competitors and your customers what are
they doing what are they talking
about yes so a very important stage and
if you're doing it properly you would
actually set up a social media listening
dashboard where you bring all your
listening channels together in one
dashboard and then instead of having to
go to all those social media networks or
websites you let them come to you Ino
reader is a very good dashboard online
dashboard a free dashboard that you can
use for
this we're then looking at the I for
integration yeah so you know your
strategy you know where your customers
are you know which social media Networks
you're going to focus on then you're
going to integrate them you're going to
set up your social media Networks you're
going to make sure the branding and the
profiles are consistent you're using
your keywords you're going to create
your content calendar and you're going
to set up your blog blogging is very
important in social media marketing
because it is the easiest way to start
creating content on your website and to
start sharing that content through your
social media channels that will then
drive people back to your your
website yes so that is part of the
integration stage and then once you've
got that all set up you're then going to
reach out it's very important that you
reach out because if you're not reaching
out then people won't find you people
won't see you yeah the whole essence of
social media marketing is that you
create as many touch points as possible
on the internet for people to find you
yeah where they start engag in with your
content going back to your website want
to know more about you want to know more
about your content and you start
building a relationship that may then
turn into a
sale so reaching out you're going to
start sharing your content you're going
to repurpose your content so turn your
blog post into a video or into a
carousel or turn your video into a
podcast or what have you yeah you're
going to share other people's content
there's nothing wrong with sharing
content from other people and you're
going to run
campaigns campaigns to push your content
in the
channels yeah and campaigns nowadays are
no longer sort of just posts on social
media it is a combination of
organic posts yeah where you just share
your post on social media could be paid
like payperclick advertising or it could
be influencer marketing style um
reaching out yeah so very important is
the reaching out stage and then of
course tracking is the icing on the cake
as it were when you track you measure
your online reputation you measure your
conversions you measure your social
media activity and engagement you're
meshing your Roi and you plan for your
next
quarter okay time to talk about the
social media marketing platforms let's
have a look at some of the most relevant
ones out there now but before that let's
make sure that you understand the
essence of the social media marketing
platforms how do they work very simple
they all work according the same concept
what you do you create create an account
on the social platform like Facebook for
instance you fill in your profile on
Facebook you put in a lot of data about
yourself on Twitter a little yeah so you
fill in your profile and once your
profile is ready you're going to connect
with friends or follow and be followed
there are some platforms when you send
somebody a connection request or a
friend request request when they accept
you're mutually connected like Facebook
and like LinkedIn other platforms like
Twitter and like Instagram when you
follow somebody doesn't mean that that
person follows you yeah so we're talking
about followers and following as it were
yep and then when you've got that you're
going to start sharing updates and
you're going to check your news feed
where you will see the updat dates from
your
friends now as a business every platform
enables you to create a Facebook page or
to create a page yeah and what you want
to do you create your page you put in
your company information you brand it to
your company branding guidelines and
then you get people to follow or like
your Facebook page or your LinkedIn page
yep and then you start sharing updates
and people people that liked your page
they may see your company updates in
their
feeds and this is what we call organic
reach so you do a post as a business and
then the people that follow you will see
your posts on their personal news
feed now in the early days of social
media this organic reach could be 40 to
50% which means that if you have have
10,000 followers on Facebook so 10,000
people liked your Facebook page 5,000 of
those people would see your update on
their personal news feed which is
fantastic and that was in the early days
for social media many Brands they spent
lots of marketing building huge
communities because it was a fantastic
free way of reaching out to your market
now nowadays things have
changed Facebook has been driving this
yeah Facebook wants you to advertise on
Facebook all these social media
platforms they have to make money so
they have advertising sort of on their
platform and they want you to use
advertising so over the years Facebook
has lowered organic reach to less than
3% so again if you have 10,000 people
people that like your Facebook page
fewer than 300 people may see your
updates in their
feet and Facebook says hey that's the
way it is we offer you a fantastic
marketing environment and we need to
make money as well so hey yeah start
advertise on Facebook to reach your
entire audience and businesses Now
understand that they now know that
social media is pay to playay to reach
your audience it's no longer relying on
organic reach you have to pay to use
payperclick advertising or PPC but we're
going to talk about that in the next
videos all right so it's very important
that you understand this concept of how
social media marketing platforms work so
let's start with the first one the
biggest one Facebook with 1.9 billion
active us users
worldwide fact is that over the years
the younger generation has left
Facebook yeah why have they left
Facebook because it's not cool anymore
yeah and their parents are on it yeah so
if you want to reach the young teens ear
late teens early 20s don't go to
Facebook you want to be on social
networks like Snapchat or or Tik Tok if
that's available in your market now
there's still markets where Facebook is
enormous yeah so they are the leading
social media Network in your Market if
that is the case then of course you have
to be on Facebook but in general we can
say that the audience for Facebook is
now a slightly older audience Generation
X or Millennials it's still a really
good Network to reach these people
particularly when you talk about
consumer type products now what does
Facebook offer you as a business to use
Facebook has the Facebook page that you
can create to reach your audience
nowadays Facebook really would like you
to use Facebook
groups Facebook groups is a fantastic
area in Facebook where you can get
really good engag engagement and as a
business you can offer a group to your
customers as a VIP area or a product
knowledge area or a pre-launch area or
just for your customers yeah lots of
Reason lots of areas where you can use a
group to reach your
customers then there's Facebook
Messenger of course that you can use for
your business where you can set a Bots
yeah so you can have sort of automated
conversations with your customers on
Facebook messenger and there is Facebook
live don't ignore Facebook live Facebook
loves you to use Facebook live the
beauty about using the Facebook live it
gives you sort of Buzz and engagement
before the event during the event and
after the
event yeah we call this tent pole
marketing you can build up excitement
leading up to the event and after the
event as
well and then finally of course Facebook
is betting heavily on the metaphors yes
so it's Mark Zuckerberg's Vision that
instead of engaging with your friends in
the news feed you engage with them in a
virtual world now the verdict is out if
this is going to work but fact is that
although we've been talking about
virtual and augmented reality for years
it is here here now yeah there's more
and more apps becoming available on your
mobile on your desktop that use
augmented
reality and virtual reality I can now
download Ikea place I think it's called
where you just open up the app you pick
a product from the catalog like a table
and then you can just position that
table in your living
room yeah and then you can move it
change the color of it or whatever yeah
using augmented reality through your um
your
camera okay so that is Facebook let's
look at the next one Instagram I love
Instagram yeah a lot of users from
Facebook have gone to
Instagram why because it is a visual
social media platform and it has
inherently higher engagement than
Facebook it's easier to reach the
audience
not just your
friends yeah so lots of cool features in
Instagram one of the coolest features is
the Instagram
stories yep and people now spend more
time on the stories than on the uh the
timeline where they see the posts so
Instagram started as a photo sharing app
very simple yeah you made a photo you
put a filter on top of it which almost
almost felt like you're a photographer
and then you share it with hashtags and
you saw immediately the likes coming in
and people loved it for its Simplicity
and now it has grown to a fully featured
social media Network that businesses can
use to make their brand come to life via
photos and Via
Stories the audience is slightly younger
than the Facebook um audience but a more
and more mature audience is coming on
there as well and it's it initially it
has very much a business to Consumer
Focus but nowadays it's not just photos
that you can share you can share visuals
I can turn a blog post into a carousel
of five
visuals yep and um in that way share
really good
content so very powerful and very useful
for businesses to reach the audience
that hangs out on on
Instagram all right so that is Instagram
let's look at the next one and that is
YouTube now YouTube of course is not
just for watching video YouTube is a
fantastic social media platform to build
an audience of
followers yeah it's a great platform to
monetize your video as well by enabling
advertising to be shown before or during
your videos a lot of video creators they
do that yeah and YouTube has a program
for that if you qualify by um number of
views that you have on your video and
number of uh and and the size of your
audience you can participate in this
program and it is a really good way to
make money on you for many content
creators now check out our earlier check
out our earlier video on how to create a
YouTube channel to find out how you can
set up a YouTube channel and how you can
use YouTube as a social media
platform YouTube is great for brand
awareness and since it's owned by Google
it's also really helpful for your search
rankings both on YouTube YouTu and on
Google Google and there's lots of
different videos of course that you can
make yeah videos that do well are
typical videos like howto videos
unpacking videos Vlogs video blogs we
call them review videos live videos lots
and lots of ways to reach the video your
audience yeah on um with video on
YouTube so the typical audience that
uses YouTube are basically everybody
from young to old but very important to
understand with YouTube that people are
there for a reason they search for
something they may search for
entertainment they may also search for
answers to their questions which is
different than the videos you would have
on uh Facebook for instance yeah so
Facebook is very good for brand
awareness where YouTube videos are very
good for um for lead generation for
instance and for building relationship
with your your
audience good and very interesting
social media platform that emerged
around 10 years ago is
Snapchat they have around 300 plus
million daily active users
and let me tell you a bit about the
history of Snapchat Snapchat was a
response to Facebook's problems about 10
years ago in
privacy and um not being cool anymore
and particularly the Privacy issue where
in those days a lot of people said who
is owning my photos on uh on Facebook
yeah um is it Facebook or is it myself
so a lot of people and that has always
been a gray area yeah combined with
Facebook not being cool anymore and you
know how important being cool is for the
younger generation yep so fa so two guys
who came up with the idea of doing
something radically different and they
came up with a social media platform
Snapchat where posts would delete
themselves Within 24
hours they built a a user interface
around this which was fairly difficult
to
use yeah but that was for a
reason kids they love to explain to each
other how it works and if it's
complicated enough then their parents
won't be able to get on it yeah so kids
love that idea it's too complicated to
use for my parents so I really really
have my own social media world yeah in
Snapchat that nobody else has access to
so particularly the teens the Generation
Z yeah was very uh keen and they were
very hot on the uh on Snapchat so it was
the new place for Facebook users to go
to and they grew ever since steadily not
huge but they are there and they are a a
very powerful social network
particularly when you want to Target the
younger generation now there are two
major features that they sort of drove
into social media land which was the
stories and second the vertical videos
so you all know the concept of the story
itself s the leads in 24 hours but it
turned um social media instead of sort
of scrolling through your news feed you
swipe from story to story much more
visual much more fun much more
engaging yep and you would swipe those
stories vertically and that
automatically led to using vertical
video and vertical video is a major
Trend in social media content yeah which
is picked up by um by Tik Tok as the
main format for uh for videos on Tik Tok
YouTube have shorts so all social media
now networks they now have stories and
they have vertical video as a key
element yeah so vertical video
particularly for short 10 12 second
videos which we call snackable content
is very important why would you tilt
your phone to watch a video why not just
use it vertical which is also a quite an
interesting um sort of form factor to
get a good engagement on your
videos finally Snapchat has very
Innovative advertising
features yeah they have lenses they have
stories they have filters you can put a
filter over your face BMW had a really
good campaign to launch a new car where
you could place the car through a lens
anywhere that you liked in augmented
reality and you could actually put a
filter where you gave yourself a golden
face yeah so very powerful advertising I
think the the WhatsApp advertising
platforms is one of the best advertising
platforms out there it's also probably
one of the most expensive um advertising
platforms of all social media
networks right so let's look at Twitter
I call Twitter SMS on steroids
yeah it was one of the first besides
Facebook one of the first social media
platforms that came out and it was a
very exciting platform when it launched
and Twitter relied heavily on C
celebrities using it to drive acceptance
on a global scale yeah and many music
stars rock stars actors they started
using Twitter and that drove the global
adoption of the uh the platform now what
makes Twitter so powerful there are
three aspects on Twitter first of all
you can retweet a
tweet yes so when you send a tweet and I
follow you I receive your Tweet if I
just click on retweet it'll go to all my
followers yeah if somebody in my
follower base retweets that tweet your
Tweet can go viral without uh in in in
in minutes Y and there's various examp
examples of tweets that went viral um
within minutes yeah like the um which
was it a selfie tweet during the Oscar
ceremony a few years
ago yes so it is um so the retweeting is
very
powerful it also makes it instant yeah
because of this retweeting aspect news
goes on in on Twitter instantly and it
shares to a global audience instantly so
that makes it very very powerful for
news agencies as well and for businesses
a very powerful feature of Twitter is
the Twitter search each tweet is indexed
and you can
search in all the tweets you can search
for the very first tweet that was ever
sent yeah so that makes it very powerful
for Brands to find content so Twitter is
really good for finding jobs for
instance because lots of businesses they
tweet about I'm looking for a marketing
manager or a web developer so if I
search for web developer # jobs that
tweet will show up in my search
results one problem that Twitter had is
that they did not keep up with the
developments in social media platform
functionality yeah so most celebrities
went to Instagram because Instagram was
much more visual much better place for
celebrities to engage with their their
fans so Twitter lagged behind and in the
last few years it clearly repositioned
itself so it now is seen as a great way
for businesses to use as a communication
and service Channel with their customers
and for media companies to sh share the
latest news so if you want to find out
what is happening in the world now or
what businesses are doing now or if you
have a problem with a product from a
business Twitter is the best place to be
and for you individual as I always say
you don't need to be on Twitter to tweet
but you must be on Twitter to find great
content to
search where whether you want to search
for jobs or whether you searching for
opportunities if you're a photographer
yeah and you in London for instance and
you go to Twitter and you search for
looking for wedding photographer London
you get a list of tweets of people who
are tweeting I'm looking for a wedding
photographer does anybody know
anybody yeah so extremely powerful to uh
to use for lead
generation right so what about Pinterest
Pinterest is a visual bookmarking
platform it's very cool the concept is
simple you see a photo on the website
that you like yeah what you can then do
you can pin that photo on Pinterest in a
board yeah and you're not copying the
photo you're just copying the link in
your board so by doing that you can
build fantastic collection of visuals
that you like and want to
organize so I bought a house in mares a
number of years ago in Morocco and we
needed to design the interior so we had
a board with Morocco design we had a
board with Morocco riads we had a board
with um tiling and what have you and we
just build up a whole collection of
ideas that we liked and then we got the
people that helped us in making the
things that we wanted and we could just
share them the links on Pinterest of the
ideas that we had worked really
well now because you can save those
Boards of course you can then share them
as well yeah so everybody can access
your boards which means that it becomes
a great tool for getting ideas and
Inspirations from boards from other
people so if you want ideas for home
design or your wedding or fashion
Pinterest is a fantastic place to get
inspiration another major benefit for
businesses is that you can put your
product catalog on Pinterest as visuals
organized in boards yep and then when
people find those products on in on
Pinterest and they click on them it will
take them to the catalog of your website
where they can buy your product so it's
a great way to drive additional traffic
to your website if you want to see a
good example for that go to the IKEA UK
um Pinterest page and look at their
boards you see boards for small living
room ideas back to school Christmas
holiday celebrations and then you get
lots of ideas with um for instance for
small living rooms and then you click on
some of the products that you see and
that takes you to the page on the Ikea
catalog website where you can buy the
product now Pinterest is very popular
amongst women amongst Millennials and it
also has very powerful advertising
features and then LinkedIn LinkedIn is
serious yeah I call LinkedIn Facebook
with a Time
where Facebook is fun LinkedIn is
serious in Facebook you can get away
with a funny profile photo in LinkedIn
your photo needs to be
professional now if you go to
linkedin.com for SL sales SL
SSI you get your Social selling index
and that is a score between one and 100
of how good you are on LinkedIn
and you will see in the score in the
summary that are four components that
contribute to your SSI score or four
components that contribute to how well
you do on LinkedIn so those four are
your
profile yeah your activity level in
connecting with
people how much content you share and
your activity level in building
relationships with people
yeah so the better you do in those four
areas the higher your score your profile
of course is very important make sure
that your LinkedIn profile is as
complete as possible now linkedin's
biggest challenge as I mentioned earlier
is to get people to engage and share
content so how does LinkedIn make money
very simple there are four areas where
they make money first of all they allow
people to upgrade their LinkedIn account
to a premium account where they get more
features there is a whole section in
LinkedIn specifically for
recruiters yeah so a recruiting version
of LinkedIn there is a whole area for
sales we call this sales
Navigator yeah if you run a sales team
that use LinkedIn of course you want to
keep the customer data so you're getting
a sort of customer relationship
management system within LinkedIn when
you sign up for sales Navigator and then
there is LinkedIn
advertising LinkedIn of course is best
for business to business and it's really
good for developing your personal online
profile as long as you share content
through publishing articles and sharing
uh sharing posts
so I've been operational on LinkedIn
from the very beginning and I shared
lots and lots of content and articles on
LinkedIn and I got lots of business
coming in through Linkedin yeah we're
talking about serious amounts of
business that I did by being on LinkedIn
so you got to be on LinkedIn if you are
in
business right
now one thing that I will not talk about
here is uh is Tik Tok yeah we haven't
got a slide for that but bear in mind
Tik Tok although it's not available in
India um Tik Tok is a very important
social media Network these days which
drives a whole new format of uh of of
engaging and communication but more
about that that
later right so let's look at the pros
and cons of social media what is good
and what is bad about it the biggest the
biggest advantage of social media
marketing is that it can lead you to new
audiences yeah wherever they are in the
world whatever type of business you are
you can reach them through organic paid
or influencer
Outreach yeah influencer Outreach has
become a very powerful element of your
social media marketing Strat stry it is
about collaborating with for instance
Instagram users with many followers to
Market your products or
services so there's the pros are there
and they are far better than the than
the cons but there are cons it's not all
positive you need to be aware that when
you are on social media you are opening
yourself up as a business people can see
what you do they can see how you do it
and they can also see when you're doing
things wrongly yeah when you're doing
things not the way it should be done
it's okay when things go well but it can
be disastrous when things go bad as we
say it takes years to build a brand but
on social media you can ruin it
overnight yeah there's lots of examples
of that um a really um big example was
the remember the Chinese passenger that
was dragged off a of a United Airlines
plane YouTube and Twitter were bombarded
with negative and cynical posts towards
United Airlines how they dealt with that
situation but hey those are the cons and
there's in any marketing channel that
you use there are cons but the pros far
outweigh the cons that are there it is
there it is a fantastic channel to reach
new audiences yeah and it is only going
to get get
bigger right so to close here are a few
answers to questions that I get often
asked in my social media
classes so let me start with giving you
a list of the questions and then we'll
do um the answer so what is viral
marketing All About Now marketing is
considered viral when it reaches the
point where it's being shared by the
public at large rather than just its
target
audience yeah so when the um you reach
more people than you intended to
reach yeah that could be through word of
mouth or through social sharing it means
your content has gone
viral yeah and particularly on YouTube
you see when you are running a campaign
for uh um a particular Market but then
the video is so good that it goes well
beyond your target audience yeah that is
what we call viral marketing what is
earned media earned media refers to
positive reviews or mentions in Industry
Media or user generated content and
guest posts on thirdparty
websites so it is basically when other
people talk about you other people
people share your
content that is what we call earned
media what are some examples of social
media marketing strategies there is one
famous one uh which I can highly
recommend you have a look at it is from
a company called blendtech yeah Blend
Tech sells professional blenders if you
go to Starbucks and you order a
frappuccino they blend the ice cubes
with Blend Tech blenders they are in
industrial grade blenders they need to
be very powerful now nobody talks about
blenders online so they came up with a
um an Innovative campaign called will it
blend yep so where they created a series
of videos where they blend everything
you want them to blend like an iPhone
comparing that with a Samsung which one
Blends the fastest they had a Facebook
page with it a website with it campaigns
with it through that campaign they
managed to grow their revenue with over
500% very powerful campaign the Dollar
Shave Club is another good example how a
small company an online company started
to challenge the big shaving companies
yeah who charge lots and lots of money
for shaving blades they challenged it
hey come to us and you'll um buy shaving
blades for $1 so really Innovative
campaign how they did that so how do you
get started in social media
marketing remember my flirt
methodology yeah Focus that is where you
start think about your Niche what makes
you unique think about your customers
think about your
targeting yeah so focus focus focus that
is the most important part when you get
started on your social
media then what is sticky marketing
sticky marketing is a term for
attractive content that engages
customers and then influences them not
only to purchase the product but also to
share the
content yeah so is people they like the
content so much that they it helps them
going through the buying cycle but also
they start sharing it with their friends
yeah which gives you additional traffic
to your website which may lead to
additional leads to your website on that
note if you are looking to learn social
media marketing and become a digital
marketing expert then look no further
than the simply learns post-graduate
program in digital marketing don't miss
out on this opportunity Find The Cost
Link in the description box for more
information too many Brands tend to be
so busy putting content out on different
channels that they miss the need and the
value of having a centralized Hub and
what I mean by that is having one place
where all of the collateral that they're
creating for their social campaigns is
actually housed and accessible in one
centralized Hub and in general they do a
pretty good job with social media
they're active on Twitter they have a
YouTube channel they're on Facebook and
Pinterest and all sorts of different
places
so what happens is your target audience
can miss a lot because social media
efforts are scattered you know people
who find one type of content they don't
always know hey you also have a YouTube
channel hey you also have an Instagram
channel so they're not necessarily aware
of all the possibilities now if I
actually go into the Annie's website now
I'm going to find out about their grants
for Gardens program and I've been a fan
of Annie's for years but I had no idea
this program existed until I used them
as an example to go and pull screen
shots for this so it's important to keep
in mind that if you are utilizing your
social channels as a way to draw people
into deeper content on a site that you
own you have much more flexibility and
ability to pass them through different
types of content now the other thing
about having a home base a place where
your content on third party channels
points back to is that then your social
media efforts help boost your overall
marketing effort
simply because of the way they impact
everything online so for example if
you're using your third party channels
is a way to attract people into deeper
content on your site you're pulling in
traffic Focus traffic potentially high
volume traffic and traffic that's
emotionally invested because if they've
seen your content somewhere and chosen
to click into your site they clearly
have an interest it also delivers links
volume of links topical links and
credible links the idea of social
proofing so that has a big potential
benefit for you it can deliver
conversions it can be much easier to get
a conversion once you have someone in an
environment that you have more control
over than to get it out on a thirdparty
channel even as third party channels are
improving their ability to get those
instant conversions you know when we
look at things like Twitter cards even
while those exist you still have more
control over the overall process and
your ability to test and refine it when
it's happening on your site and then
finally this just a way to deliver
credibility because it lets you get out
on some of these channels and
demonstrate that knowledge and offer
that teaser content that says you're
here you're present and you have
something to
offer now one of social media's biggest
Powers is the concept of touch Point
okay it's important to understand that
being able to go and meet customers
where they already are and lead them
back to you that's where social channels
truly have their power yes it's also in
the connecting it's also in the ability
to drive engagement and get exposure but
those are your starting points to get
those conversions there's a lot of value
in inviting them back into a place where
they can engage with you on a deeper
level the other thing to understand
about touch points is that the more
times a consumer sees your brand or
campaign mentioned the more likely they
are to engage with it and again that's
one of those areas of true power in
getting that exposure through social
media so if you look at each of our
little person icons here and you look at
the sort of ripple effect circles that
are spreading out around them view each
of those circles is a post to a social
media channel and maybe the bigger
circles are posted by an influencer in a
specific area and the smaller circles
are posted by you know a friend or maybe
a lesser known blogger oh years ago with
Candy Crush Saga which was a huge huge
mobile phenomenon here in the United
States most people didn't know know
about it until a friend invited them to
play and most people probably got half a
dozen dozen maybe two or three dozen
invites before they took the time to
check it out it takes a lot of exposure
a lot of your friends sharing the same
video or linking to the same news story
before you finally cave and go okay well
if that many people think it's
worthwhile maybe I should take a look at
it so if you look at those places where
we have one person being impacted by
multiple Ripple effects that's where we
see the the highest likelihood of
Engagement and that's where're having a
good presence across social media
channels and good social sharing across
social media channels gives you those
touch points and those ability to draw
people into an experience with your
company now most social media channels
have slightly different reasons for
existing again we we mentioned earlier
and we're going to talk a little bit
later about the fact that it's important
to customize the way you put your
content out there so that it has the
highest like hood of catching the
attention and being engaged with by
consumers so if we look at things like
micr Medias um Twitter and Tumblr it's a
great place to sort of connect and
listen same thing with forums but as we
move down from say forums to social
networks now we're also looking at
building relationships and it requires
sort of a frequency of contact and you
can see that each of the different forms
of social channels has a value to it and
a specific thing that it has the ability
to accomplish
now if each of your social media efforts
connects back into your home base you
have the ability to pass consumers
through multiple support channels and
you can play each channel to their
strength to again create a better
experience where people can then come in
and engage with you on sort of your
owned media on the home base or the blog
or the area that you have created now a
great example of this of leveraging
touch points is a company called smarty
had aart party um it's a party planning
site they sell um high-end disposable uh
party products you know plates and
glasses and things like that and they do
an excellent job of using blog content
and social channels to attract visits
and then leading buyers from the blog
into their sales process so for example
you can see here a Facebook post they
put up that talks about a new product
that they've just released they had a
contest that went with it and they gave
free product away for a couple people
and they Linked In into a blog post that
they put together that says here's how
to use this product to create favor or
an appetizer or something that you can
use at your next party now when you look
at the blog post they put up and you
zoom in a little bit you'll see that at
the bottom they had a link to go and buy
the product so they're using the
Facebook post and a teaser to draw
people into their website where they can
give more information get them more
actively engaged and then eventually
push them into that conversion funnel
that's an example of leveraging targeted
touch points on a specific social media
channel to draw someone into a home base
now let's see this approach in action
and how we can take one of the ways that
uh companies tend to use social media
and make a slight tweak but really make
a big difference in their ultimate
impact so an example here is beler
flowers a small florist in the US that
was using YouTube to sell boxwood trees
for Christmas several years ago and they
ended up making a couple mistakes and
what's really interesting is I was
actually doing a webinar once where I
included them as an example and they
were actually on the call cuz it was a
florist webinar and they did end up
implementing some of these changes and
said it worked out really really great
so several years ago I was on Twitter
and I saw this tweet come by that said
boxwood trees are now available for
Philadelphia flower delivery your cat
will love them too it linked from
Twitter over to YouTube where there was
a little homemade YouTube video about
sort of the owner's grandson decorating
this little boxwood tree and then I
think they took it off to a relative
that might have been in a nursing
facility you know where they couldn't
have a full Christmas tree cute video
does a decent job of making me go hey
that might be really good for my
grandmother or my great aunt now there's
a couple challenges here one of the big
ones is that you have to actually go and
look for the links there weren't there
wasn't anything embedded you know they
didn't have the call outs with the links
straight into go buy the product so you
had to actually look around and see if
you could figure out what the URL was or
go back and Run a search for it of
course that's all assuming you don't get
distracted by all of the you know up
next or related videos and run off down
a rabbit trail that you know 20 minutes
later you find yourself going oh my
goodness why did I even come to YouTube
in the first place we know that tends to
happen there so assuming you stayed
focused and you actually found that link
and you clicked into the site when I
clicked into the site there were no
boxwood trees and I looked all over for
boxwood trees I even used the search
function to look for boxwood trees and
most people tend to use the search
function they just go right back to
Google and they run a search again but
as I was clicking around I realized that
they actually had a Blog which means
they had the opportunity to write a
great post about the benefit of using
boxwood trees for aging relatives or in
small apartments and to embed that video
right there into the blog post because
by embedding it into the blog post now
they're removing some of the
distractions of being in that YouTube
environment and they're allowing me to
be in their blog environment where
they're controlling what the layout
looks like on top of that they also have
the ability to put an image and an add
to cart and a call to action button
right there in the same blog post to
lead me into where I can purchase that
boxwood tree instead of making me hunt
around and look for it now if you
consider the difference of making these
slight changes and you look at the
before and after you'll see that the way
they had it set up I had to be on
Twitter see that
the tweet on Twitter click into the
video watch the video look around for
the URL to the site and you know ignore
all the other distractions on YouTube
click through to the site search for the
boxwood tree read all the pricing and
then click to order now if you use this
Homebase
mentality now when I'm on Twitter and I
see this link and I click I come into
the blog post and I can watch the video
right there on the blog post I can view
the pricing information right there on
the blog post and then I can click to
order that's two clicks instead of seven
different steps up in the first one now
if you know anything about conversion
optimization you know that the fewer
steps that you have the higher the
ultimate conversion rate so again very
very big difference and that's just in
the conversion process that doesn't even
count the inbound links the potential
for traffic traffic that might click
around to other areas of the site and be
interested in a purchase lots of
benefits to looking at it from this New
Perspective now a final word of advice
is that social media provides an amazing
opportunity to make a connection with
customers it's great to get out there on
different channels and really engage but
you need to remember to invite them into
your conversion funnel and a lot of
times that's going to mean inviting them
into your site or inviting them into
some point of conversion activity that
gives you the ability to contact and
engage with them in the future we are
going to be talking about Facebook at
ising we're going to talk about how
businesses use Facebook advertising how
the what are the benefits they can get
from it we're going to show you with a
demo on how to set up your Facebook
advertising and we will close today's
session with a few dos and don'ts of
Facebook advertising but before we go
into that make sure that if you like
today's video or if you like the simply
learn Channel don't forget to subscribe
to the channel below and if you like the
video feel free to like it and share it
with your friends so let's get
started today's world has changed
dramatically when it comes to reaching
your audiences fact is that everybody is
trying to get the attention of the
million of prospects out there in the
market everybody is screaming try my
product try my product or try my product
but most businesses they now have to
realize that today's customer has
changed yeah today's customer is looking
for instant gratification they want a
product now wherever they are whatever
their F device that they're using yeah
and they can Pro they can Source their
products from everywhere in the world Y
and it is your challenge to make sure
that when they are in the buying mode
that you are there to help them it's a
new economy out there it's a service
driven economy look at products like
Uber or um Airbnb where a whole new
ecosystem has developed of people
offering their products their services
to a global audience in marketing terms
we're using a term called solomo
standing for social local and
mobile yeah when you bring those three
elements together of social media local
marketing and mobile marketing you stand
a really good chance to connect with
your customers at the right time Google
has um summarized this in what we call
Google moments on average people have a
couple of hundred moments during a day
where they grab their mobile phone to do
a search on their mobile phone they
maybe want to buy something they want to
book something they want to share
something they want to learn something
all those little moments are
opportunities for you to connect with
your customer or your prospect and
that's your opportunity but that's also
your challenge to make sure that you are
there when your customers are having
those moments when they scream I want
your products and there are plenty of
channels that you can use to reach those
customers yeah we know about social
media we know about your website there's
things like influencer marketing there's
email marketing and there's more and
more competition out there that are
trying to use those channels to reach
your audience but fact is there is one
channel that really stands out of all
these channels and that is
payperclick
advertising payperclick advertising is a
well established part of what we call
the digital marketing
Trifecta and this Trifecta consists as
the word Tri says of three components
owned paid and earned yes so the owned
is your own website are your own social
media profiles and your social media
pages but owned is no longer enough you
need to supplement your owned media with
paid media and this is what we call
payperclick
advertising and then the third element
of the digital marketing Trifecta is
what we call earned media and earned
media is where you can still use the
powerful um effects of public relations
in an online world or where you can work
with influencers
yeah to help you develop your online
presence and connect with your
audiences but one of the best ways to
start getting to your audiences is to
use
advertising yeah and there are various
platforms for advertising there is um
Google yeah there is Google search
advertising Google display advertising
and there is Facebook advertising now to
put these two in the context Google did
about $210 billion of Revenue in
advertising in
2021 Facebook is about half of that $15
billion do in
2021 and the most powerful models for
advertising are search ads and display
ads yeah so a search ads is in the
Google search which is what
Google offers the display ads and video
ads are offered by Google and by
Facebook and we call this payperclick
advertising which means you're not
paying for showing your ad but you're
paying when people click on your
ad okay so let's have a look between uh
to this advertising in a bit more detail
yeah Facebook advertising was introduced
Ed on around
2007 yeah so um in 2007 it was launched
by Facebook yep so but it has grown
drastically since then in
2011 ads were being shown in the news
feed yeah Google Facebook called it
sponsored stories in
2012 ads came on the mobile yeah mobile
ads are now considered the most powerful
um forms of payperclick advertising in
2014 Facebook introduced a thre level
advertising structure which was very
much introduced by Google as well where
you have campaigns you have ad sets and
you have your ads and when you go in
setup and you'll see that later your
faure ads in Facebook you will have to
go through these three at elements yeah
campaigns ad sets and ads to set up your
advertising on Facebook in 2 in 26 sorry
in 2016 Facebook introduced chatbots and
ads in messenger which became a whole
new area for advertising for Facebook
yeah connecting with um customers on
Facebook messenger and offering that for
advertising as well and in 2018 there
was a whole range of ad for formats
available on Facebook from videos
stories messenger Carousel slideshows
collections so a whole range of ads to
choose from when you start your face
setting up your Facebook ads now what is
the future yeah what does the future
hold for Facebook
advertising as you may have read um that
both Facebook and Google are having a
lower Revenue in their advertising given
the whole world economic uh situation
we're slowly moving towards a a
recession even yeah Facebook and Google
and Microsoft all the big Tech players
are feeling the impact in that yes so
that is one Element now one of the other
reasons why Facebook's Revenue has gone
down in advertising is the tracking uh
capab abilities and um a lot of
businesses they track people when they
visit their website and then you can
Target them with ads we call this
retargeting in marketing terms now Apple
has announced um earlier this year that
on iOS people can say which is on the
iPhone people can decide to not being
tracked yep so that has put a whole sort
of kind of a um a a a um a uh a
different set of um Dynamics in Facebook
advertising on the iPhone and it is not
as effective as it was before that
announcement from um from Apple so the
future of advertising is all about
security it's about privacy and of
course in the end it all comes down to
how good are your ads how what is the
quality of the content in your ads are
you able to stand out from the crowd
yeah so those are the big challenges in
Facebook advertising now you have to be
aware that Facebook advertising is
completely different than Google search
advertising you to put it into a context
Google search advertising is what we
call intent based yes so when I have a
question or I'm looking for something or
I need a plumber I go to Google Search
yeah and I search for plumber near me
and Google will give me some ads with
plumbers near me that is not the way
Facebook advertising Works Facebook
advertising yeah is not intent based it
is basically it is your challenge when
you advertise on Facebook is to stop the
user from browsing and click on your ads
so it's more interruptive you need to
make sure that they stop what they're
doing which is much more difficult yeah
so you'll see that Facebook is therefore
slightly more challenging to actually
generate
leads yeah to get new
customers Google advertising is much
better for that but Facebook advertising
is much better to reach a global
audience very targeted yeah and work on
awareness developing your proposition
helping your prospects to go through the
buying cycle yes so Facebook ads they
help spread product and brand awareness
in the news feed or on Instagram or on
messenger to a very specific targeted
audience now another element which is
important to understand when it comes to
Facebook advertising is to do with
Organic reach when I have a Facebook
post and I do sorry when I have a
Facebook page and I do a post on my page
the people that will like my that have
liked my page will see my post on their
news feed that's how the
theory is yeah of course not everybody
will see those posts because that
wouldn't work because then you would get
way too much advertising in your feed
yeah so Facebook is very selective in
the number of posts from advertising
from businesses or sorry yeah from
businesses that will show on your news
feed yeah and in fact that percentage of
people that will see your post your
business post on their personal news
feed is less than
3% so again if you have a Facebook page
let's say with 10,000 followers and you
do a post on your Facebook page less
than 300 people will see your
post now businesses are not happy with
that yeah they said hey Facebook why are
you doing that I want to reach my entire
audience and Facebook says well hey you
you still can yeah but it's going to
cost you some money and Facebook says
you have to go and advertise on Facebook
to reach your audiences so businesses
Now understand that Facebook is what we
call pay to play you to reach your
audiences you have
to supplement your organic reach with
advertising and the beauty about
Facebook advertising is that it is a
fantastic way to reach your target or
audience and that is the biggest benefit
that Facebook advertising can give you
it's all about the targeting there is so
many targeting options in Facebook and
I'll show you when we go into the short
demo on how to set up your ads so what
are the reasons why businesses go into
Facebook yeah what are the reasons what
are the benefits that they will get from
it and the first big benefit that they
get is that they get access to an
audience which is out there yeah and it
is not just a small audience we're
talking about Facebook at as of today as
close to three billion active monthly
users that is a massive numbers and most
of these people they check their
profiles at least once daily so is a
huge audience to reach and there is no
better social media Network to reach a
global audience than on Facebook yeah so
that is one of the reasons why you want
to start advertising on Facebook the
second reason one why you want to start
advertising on Facebook is that Facebook
gives you a fantastic platform to
advertise your products to People based
on their demographics based on their
interests based on their location based
on their um their history of browsing
based on so many different segmentation
factors which means that you can make
sure that your ads reach the Right
audience which is a really good benefit
that you will get from Facebook
advertising the next benefit that you
get from Facebook advertising it is that
it is very cost
effective yeah you can just start with a
small budget you can slowly increase
your budget you can relate your B budget
to the returns that you're getting from
it so it helps you spend less and
achieve more it is one of the
advertising platforms with the highest
return on investment of your um on your
money so very cost cost effective to
advertise on
Facebook here are some other reasons why
businesses use advertising on Facebook
it really helps them with increasing
brand awareness as I said earlier the
difference with Google search
advertising Facebook is not intent based
people are not searching in Facebook
looking for Content which could include
your ads they are actually browser
on Facebook and it is your challenge
yeah to um to be creative enough to make
them stop browsing and pay uh attention
to your ads so it really helps in
increasing brand awareness it's let it's
an opportunity for you to Showcase your
brand and to help them add value to
their lives so by doing that you
establish trust you establish credit
ability yeah and you provide recall
value for your brand so it is all about
taking the customer by the hand and
helping them in going through the buying
cycle yeah so when the buying cycle is
about awareness is about building
interest yeah then building that trust
that they then will turn into buying
your
product the second big benefit that
you're getting from Facebook is to
Target people that have already
expressed an interest in your service we
call this
retargeting you may also have heard
about pixel targeting or pixel marketing
it basically means that if somebody
visits your
website yeah you can then retarget those
people with an
ad from a technical ele as a perspective
it means that you need to put Facebook
will give you a piece of code that you
need to put on your website and then as
soon as some somebody visits that
website that triggers that code it
automatically connects with Facebook and
then Facebook will capture that user
data that you can then use to Target
them with a specific ad so a big
opportunity there for the retargeting
but things will be changing here in the
near future yeah Google has announced
that by 2023 24 it will stop enabling
third parties to leave cookies on the um
on on on websites yeah to Target people
so that whole retargeting area will go
and will undergo some big changes in the
near future and then of course Facebook
advertising can really help you increase
Revenue
as I said earlier it is a fantastic way
to to connect with people and take them
by the hand through the buying cycle you
can educate your audiences about what
your product has to offer yeah and the
more people know about your products the
more likely they are prepared to make a
purchase and to share their
experiences so lots of benefits that you
get now let's dive a bit deeper into
this and let's look at the different
type of ads that Facebook has available
so first there is the single image ad
these are single ads single image ads
that have an option uh optional text on
the top and a link description that
links to your website and a call to
action that is very important to have a
good call to action in your ad the ad
images they need to be 1,200 by 62 28
pixels so that's where you have an
opportunity individual to stand out in
the news feed and make people stop and
then click on the link as you see here
for instance sign
up the next ads are the
multiproduct ads they are usually
carousels so it enables you allow
consumers to see all the products or the
servic
that you have available they're very
efficient they're very um Visual and
they have lots of creative options um in
them so they're very popular and they're
Lots being being used Lots by uh by
businesses so that's your multiproduct
ads usually via a
carousel then of course you have your
video
ads Now video ads are thir 30 second to
two minute ads and they are amongst
Facebook's most engaging most popular
ads they get about 10 to 30% more views
than other ads and not only views also
engagement why because people love to
engage with video when you engage with
video you have the opportunity to touch
emotions of people which is much
stronger in building trust building Rel
relationships with your
audience and particularly video on
mobile yeah works really well so it's a
high growth area of video advertising
and one area that you definitely need to
look at if you want to be successful
with Facebook
advertising then you have the lead ads
lead ads they offer a slightly different
way to advertise your products they let
you get used usernames emails phone
numbers actually without leaving
Facebook yeah and that's what makes them
really powerful within Facebook
advertising you can actually create a
sign up form or you could even drive
them through Messenger and have a
communication with them to get their
details through a
chatbot so people don't leave Facebook
you do the whole process of lead
generation and lead capture within
Facebook and it can be easily
synchronized with your existing CRM
system and then you have collection ads
collection ads blend video and product
catalog photos so they um are really
good if you want to advertise multiple
products at once yeah if you want to do
this so collection ads work really
well okay so so that's a short
introduction of Facebook advertising the
benefits that you get why people would
use them why businesses would use them
and the different type of ads so in the
next section let's go and have a look at
how do you create an ad what are the
steps to create a Facebook
ad so here you see I am on a Facebook
page and this is the page for riat far
Russia which is is a um a hotel uh in
Marakesh and I am the admin for this
page and what I'm going to show you on
this page is how to access the
advertising platform and how to set up
your ads yeah so let me first before I
do this show you what Facebook is trying
to do everywhere whether it's your
desktop or your mobile to make sure that
you go into advertise creation mode yeah
so you'll see it everywhere
promote ad Center create ads create
automated ads boost post wherever you
are you will come to sections like boost
post or go please create an ad on the
mobile it's even more obvious yeah here
is the same page but then on the mobile
device and if I scroll down you see on
the first post immediately boost the
post so you'll see that Facebook is
trying everything to get you to
advertise yeah and I think it is a bit
annoying yeah but it's also you need to
be aware that all the various places
that Facebook will try to to hook you
into advertising they lead to various
subsections of the advertising platform
yeah so if I click here on Boost the
post it will take me to a what I call a
quick and dirty boost uh advertising
module yeah so I say I'm going to good
morning from our rooftop I'm going to
turn that post into an ad yeah and I can
immediately decide what goal do I want
for my ad do I want to add a button what
is the URL yeah do I want to edit the
image who is my
audience yeah and then what is the
budget what is the duration where am I
going to show these ads and how am I
going to pay bang bang bang boost post
now yeah so it looks very interesting
and very effective to do this but what
you see here is you will only get a
subsection of what Facebook advertising
can do for you yeah and if you think hey
if that's okay with you that's fine but
you're missing 90% of the other features
to make your ad as effective as possible
in other words my advice to you would be
don't click on the boost a post button
on your mobile yeah or your desktop
because again it leads you to a limited
functionality of the advertising module
and the advertising capabilities that
Facebook can offer you so back to the
desktop the same applies here if I click
here on Boost
Post Yeah there's nothing wrong with
advertising for a post you can take one
of your most successful posts or for a
video and you you can create additional
reach for that post through advertising
but don't do it through the limited
advertising functionality again this is
a quick and dirty module everything on
one page and it will um you can click
boost post now and it's an easy way to
start spending your money yes so that is
if you click the Boost post the same
applies if you go to
the create ads or create automated ads
yeah so let me show you to create
automated ads it takes you through a
very automated process of creating ads
which is great when you're a beginner
but again it will only give you limited
functionality of what Facebook
advertising has to offer you so again my
advice would be
don't go to the automated ads click on
create ads that again gives you limited
functionality gives it all in one page
again you don't want to do
that yep and then you click on the ad
Center that gives you again a summary of
the advertising slightly more
tools yeah but it's all to lure you into
spend money in a very very quick way so
then where do I go for my
advertising the place where you go is to
the Facebook or how do you know call
Meta The Meta business Suite The Meta
business Suite gives you everything you
need for your advertising it allows you
to manage multiple advertising
accounts yep and it gives you access to
the full functionality of what Facebook
has to offer you so let's go there The
Meta business
Suite so here you
see everything you need for your
advertising yes so here you see it's
your read for Russia and it's not only
for your
advertising you can manage your posts
here you can schedule your posts manage
your inbox your notification manage your
content manage your shop plan your post
now we'll cover all these areas in
future videos but for now we want to
focus on the
advertising again even here they have
ads as a quick and dirty method to
create your ads again where I want you
to go click here on all tools and now
finally this is where you want to go it
gives you access to the full advertising
functionality to create your ads to
manage your ads to manage your audiences
to setup events when you want to connect
get data from your website and where you
can create your
forms this is where you want to go yeah
so if I click here on the ads
manager that takes me to the full
advertising
platform
now here you see by the way turn off ad
blocker yeah which is important
because in your creation of your ads
Facebook will
obviously simulate your uh your ads yeah
but if you have your ad blocker on the
ads will not show in the preview so it
is important that you switch off the ad
ad blocker so you create your browser
environment exactly as users will have
in um when they they see your ads so let
me go into switching that off which is
more tools extensions and you see here
my ad blocker is on so I'm going to
switch that
off yeah let me do a
review yes so here you have your account
overview you have your uh your dash your
sort of your dashboard now you see I
haven't run any campaigns yeah so I'm
not going to so there's not much to see
here in this um this this tool so let's
go here under my
campaigns yeah and this gives me the
basic sort of structure of your
advertising on Facebook yeah remember
remember we talked about campaigns adets
and ads yeah those are the three
elements of
your advertising campaign on Facebook
you create a campaign and I'll show you
what you need to set up in the campaigns
then within a campaign you can have
multiple adsets and those adsets within
a campaign inherit the settings of the
campaign and then within adsets you have
ads yep and Those ads they inherit the
settings of the adsets and the settings
of the
campaign all right so you see here we
have three or two campaigns or three
campaigns there is a new lead campaign
there is a page likes and there is a
traffic campaign so now I'm not going to
show you these campaigns I'm actually
going to show you how to create a
campaign so let's go into that here is
create if you have experience with
advertising in payperclick advertising
you will recognize this approach Google
ads has it as well it is what we call
guided campaign
creation yeah so when you start your
Facebook ads and when you start your
Google ads you can select do you want an
awareness campaign do you want a traffic
engagement leads promote your apps or a
sales campaign yeah and basically once
the the campaign objective that you
select
will set a number of the settings yeah
sort of specifically for that campaign
objective so it makes it easier to align
it with your business goals and the
whole setup will be done easier yes so
here you see an awareness objective so
that is to good for reach for brand
awareness for video views yes so it's
showing the ad to the to as many people
as possible who are likely to remember
them traffic is to send people to a
destination like your website this is
really good to get link clicks to get
views on a landing page or get people
get into conversations with people on
Messenger or Whatsapp engagement ads is
get more messages video videos views
post engagements is good for Instagram
for messaging apps good for video views
engagement on posts lead ads are collect
leads for your business or brand they're
good for instant forms on messenger good
for conversions and to get calls here is
to promote your apps like in app
installs app events and here is sales
that is for your catalog sales for
instance yeah we're going to do a simple
one I'm going to set up a traffic I want
to drive people to a landing page yeah
so here I'm going to click on traffic
yeah and I'm going to click
continue so now I'm going into the
campaign settings so here you see the
three structures again the new traffic
campaign new traffic ad set new traffic
ads that I'm going to
use okay so here is my traffic campaign
I'm going to create a name with which is
I'm going to stick with new traffic
campaign am I going to use any AD are
there any AD categories yes so is it
about elections is it about politics is
it about employment about social issues
yeah remember a few years ago there was
this Scandal when there was brexit and
the Trump elections or the in
2018 I believe it was there was a lot of
data being sold by this Cambridge
analytica that they data they took from
Facebook and they sold that to the
campaign teams of the US election and of
the brexit yeah that had a big impact on
privacy on Facebook and on um
advertising for for elections and
politics so and now Facebook has set
some extra sort of security guidelines
for specific ad
categories now what are the campaign
details here here you see by default it
is set as an auction paperclick works on
an auction basis this is not a
paperclick course but basically it means
you will do a bit on your ad how much
you're prepared to pay for a click Y and
that will then go into an auction and
that will determine the position of your
ad we want to get more
traffic do you want to do ab testing yes
and we want face Facebook to do that
yeah or you switch that off and what is
your budget do you want to create
distribute your budet across ad sets
yeah if you want to do that you can
switch that on and then you have your
campaign budget so we're going to set a
daily budget of
20 yes so go back to the it's fun
setting yeah and then what is your
campaign bit strategy I just want the
highest volume and there's more options
you can schedule your ads so you can set
it at specific times my advice is to run
the ads all the time yeah particularly
in the learning phase when Facebook
launches your campaign it goes into
learning mode and then Facebook will see
by itself when your audience will um uh
will um will respond and they will
adjust the ad scheduling accordingly so
there is your traffic
campaign details then we're going to
your traffic ad set where do you want to
drive your traffic to your website to an
app to messenger we want to drive it to
the
website now Dynamic creative is an
important one yeah do you want to want
Facebook to create your ads or do you
want to do it yourself when you want
Facebook to do it you provide creative
elements like images and headlines and
then Facebook will automatically
generate the best ads for you yeah so I
kind of like that yeah so I always
switch that on on here you see the
schedule when do you want to start yeah
so do you want to send an end as well so
that would be then let's say November
the
22nd and then here is some more options
you can say set at spend limits and here
is where the real
meaty sort of stuff happens in Facebook
advertising this is where you can select
your audience you can save specific
audiences in the audience manager yeah
so you can have a number of audience if
you have an office in one country or
another country you can just he select
select the audience for that particular
particular country or you can just
create a new
audience okay so you can exclude
audiences you can set the location you
can set the age location let's look at
that if I click here on edit people
living in or recently in this location
people living people recently people
traveling in this location so this is
really powerful if you want to Target
people who are visiting a uh an event
like a football match or what have you
and you can include and this is where
you can search location you can search
by City let's say
London yeah so London England or I can
say let's do for instance reading in
England yeah and I can even say uh give
me yeah so I can search location give me
uh
rg7 I can do by post code yeah so I can
actually people doing in the reading
area by post code and I really like this
so if I say for instance RG
76 yeah so here you can see how you can
Target a specific area yeah and this is
particularly for your local marketing is
very
important yep so that is the uh the
local targeting is really good so you
can and then by the way here you see
your estimated audience size and when
your audience get bigger you see
estimated daily results as well and then
you can do more you can search by um
where was this you can search by
detailed targeting by demographics by
interests and behaviors yes so if I want
to people who like
reading
football club yeah so here is the
reading FC soccer team yeah so here are
I can now sent an add targeting
specifically people in that particular L
area who like and we have the UK as well
yeah so uh in reading and that
particular area who like football who
like Reading Football Club yeah or I can
um at other areas as well there's also
the suggestions if people like reading
they may also like these type of things
Neymar soccer or maybe they like
Manchester United yeah so this is just a
tip of the iceberg the whole
segmentation in Facebook advertising and
the targeting is extremely
powerful okay here are your placements
for your Facebook ads best is to let
Facebook decide where to place your ads
but to show you where your ads can be
shown on Facebook if you click on the
manual placements you see here they can
show on Facebook they can show on
Instagram on messenger and on the
Audience Network now what is the
Audience Network Google has that as well
yeah in the display ads which are ads
that show on millions of websites that
that Facebook has an agree or that
Google or in this case Facebook has an
agreement with so it shows your Facebook
ad outside Facebook on millions of
websites okay so that's the Audience
Network then if you look at the here's
the feeds where your ad can sh can show
your ad can show in stories and
reals your ad can show instream
videos overlay and post Loop ads on
reals Facebook search on messaging in
article apps andite so there is tons of
places where your ads can show but the
best thing is to let Facebook decide
where your ads are going to show okay so
these are your ad set settings so let's
now look at the
ad so here you see the Facebook page and
in our case it is the riat
[Music]
Faria
page there you go yeah we'll make it you
can op in for Branded content tools you
can look at the ad setup we can do
manual upload you can get data from your
product catalog and here you specify
what type of AD you want to show is it a
single image or a video or is it a
carousel yep and then here you have your
ad
creative and your media and then select
images select videos and then here you
have your primary text headline
description your website URL this is
where you can do your url parameters
when you want to track your
campaigns yeah here you see the ad
preview the ad preview is off and now
it's on yeah but of course I need to
select media
so let's
see find images so here we're going to
say go to my
website and create an image for me
approve yeah so now it will actually
show me some
images select images yeah so here you
see images from my
Riad yeah that it picks up from my riat
or from my website here's the website
yeah so let's take
uh let's take this image and we'll say
continue yeah
so select a destination link for your ad
let me see where we're going to put that
[Music]
one there you go yes so now because I
put in the destination link you will see
how the ad start building but this is
the photo that I selected yeah now I'm
not going to show you the details of and
I'm not going to use as an example here
I just want you to show you the fields
where you can play and create your ad
yeah and then you see here in the ad
preview where you see it in the feeds
there is a mobile preview as well yep so
you see here the feeds you see here the
stories and the reals how they would
look on Instagram the
instream yep and here in the search in
article and on
apps yes so there you have it that is
your traffic ads so we've now done our
campaign we've done our ad set we've
done our traffic ads and then basically
what you going to do is you're going to
publish your
ad now when you're going into
publish yeah you can then go back to
view the
details and then you see that the ad is
um done and it is actually in review by
Facebook so if I now go back to my
campaigns yeah let's close this one you
see here is the new traffic ad yeah and
you see here it's processing and then
here you see immediately the details
that you can get from your campaign yes
so you see the pro processing you see
the ad set name the bit strategy the
budget you see attribution setting so
basically attribution is how you track
the results of your
ads um and then you see here the results
in number of Link clicks how many people
reached how many Impressions what is the
cost per result what is the quality
ranking the engagement ranking the
conversion ranking the higher D
rankings the better Facebook considers
your ads and the more and the better the
positions for your ads here you see your
amount spent and here you see the end
date of the
campaign yes so that is how you set up
your Facebook ads as a kind of
introduction to the Facebook
advertising yeah so if I now go back to
all my campaigns
campaigns yeah so you see here let me
see if I have some no you see there's no
none of these ads actually run or did
run in the past yeah so I can't show you
the the results but we'll go into more
details at a later um the later session
on uh on Facebook advertising for now
this is I think the best overview I can
give you yeah and um if you want to get
more than details then we'll go in a
more in-depth session of the Facebook
advertising okay now that is all clear
let's look at the dos and don'ts of
Facebook
advertising what should you do and what
shouldn't you do with your
ads so there are various dos the first
of all make sure you continuously test
your
ads and the good thing is that Facebook
will do this for you yeah you can tell
Facebook please test my ads you can give
Facebook a collection of creative
materials a collection of headlines yeah
and it will actually mix and match those
headlines and it will use the ones that
will give the best um the best
conversions so it's very important that
you continuously look yeah at your
performance and and see if minor changes
to your ads will lead to a better
performance second make sure that your
images and that your videos are
engaging remember there is no intent in
Facebook advertising you have to be very
creative to stand out from the crowd and
you can only do that by making your ads
engagement or then by making your ads
engaging
in images and
videos so the not only the images or the
videos but it's also the messaging that
you use use a message that will stay
with your
audience yeah so it's the combination of
the visuals and the key message of your
ad that will make people stop if by
looking in a split second at your ad
yeah they get it then they will stop and
they
will click on the call to action so make
sure you use a message that
is powerful and
effective also keep it simple or we say
kiss keep it simple and stupid make sure
that people easily understand the
message that you're trying to convey
with your ad don't make it too
complicated don't use complic licated
visuals don't use complicated messages
keep it
simple and make sure that you reach the
Right
audience yeah Facebook's biggest benefit
is the targeting you can Target micro on
micro level targeting people in very
specific
areas yeah so that is the dos and of
course there are don'ts as well so the
first thing is is be sensible with your
budget don't spend your whole Budget on
one single campaign yeah so start small
and basically grow your budget based on
the results that you're
getting yeah if you have to use visuals
and messages that are um appealing then
of course don't make sure that you po
put too much information in the ads
again keep your ads simple don't clutter
them with too much text and too many
visuals make sure that you proofread
your ads don't have typos in your ads
there's not a lot of text in your ads so
please make sure that you double check
the quality of the ads when it comes to
the language and the um uh the cremmer
yeah so don't forget to proofread your
ads be sensible in the activity level
that you have on your Facebook page yeah
up until a few years ago it was it was
actually promoted by Facebook to do as
many posts as you think are relevant for
your business people did four or five
posts a day nowadays it is not about the
quantity it is about the quality so
don't do too many posts on your Facebook
page be sensible think from a customer
perspective also when it comes to your
ads yeah so too many ads or showing the
same ad to the same people all the time
yeah may have an adverse result and then
finally make sure that your image
relates to your product so don't put up
an image that doesn't relate to the
advertised product on that note if you
are looking to learn social media
marketing and become a digital marketing
expert then look no further than the
simply learns postgraduate program and
digital marketing don't miss out on this
opportunity Find The Cost Link in the
description box for more information the
people who choose to keep up with your
content on the Instagram they are like
your own personal cheerleaders following
you through every post story and update
you share do you want to boost your
popularity on the platform you need
those followers they are the key to
building your audience increasing your
reach and showing the world what you are
all about whether you are a business
influencer or just an average user
getting more followers is the name of
the game on Instagram from clever
hashtags to paid promotions these are
plenty of tactics you can use to grow
your following and become the Talk of
the Town so get out there and start
building your insta fan base everyone
I'm B kandal and I welcome you all to
Simply learns YouTube channel
today we'll be learning on how to
increase Instagram followers so first
let me ask you a
question did the Instagram get launched
is it a 6th October 2010 or B 6th
October 2011 or C 6th November 2010 or D
6th August 2009 you can comment down
your answers in the comment section
below now let's get on on with our
session but before we get into Integrity
of things let me take you through simply
learns professional certificate program
in digital marketing or better known as
postgraduate program in digital
marketing it is the post-graduate
program course by simply learn in
collaboration with purd University and
meta blueprint in digital marketing this
comprehensive program is designed to
equip you with skills you need to excel
in the fast space world of digital
marketing with this program you will
learn everything from fundamentals of
digital marketing to the latest trends
and techniques used by top marketers
worldwide you will explore topics such
as SEO sem content marketing social
media marketing email marketing and much
more this program is led by Industries
expert who bring their real world
experience to the classroom giving you
an Insider perspective on what it takes
to succeed in the digital marketing
world and with Hands-On projects and
practical assignments you will have
chance to apply your knowledge and
develop the skills you need to stand out
in the competitive field so if you're
looking to jump start your career in
digital marketing or take your skills to
the next level then simply learn
professional certificate program IND
digital marketing is the perfect place
to start to learn more about the course
you can click on the link in in the
description box below now without any
further Ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's session we will start
off the discussion with various steps to
increase Instagram followers moving
forward we will also discuss best
practices to increase followers finally
we will wrap this session with the best
tools to help get more followers so
let's get started with a few steps to
help increase Instagram followers first
up you need to lay the groundwork you
need to identify your ideal Instagram
customers and create a plan you can
include keywords in the in your profile
and bio next you need to create some
interesting and engaging content we have
to craft a stunning Instagram feed we
can use lengthy captions that are both
engaging and
informative then we have to make ourself
discoverable you can tag your location
and other relevant individuals in posts
and use hashtags to expand your audience
afterwards you have to be able to engage
with your community and build relations
you can start by collaborating with
similar companies and influential people
also you can interact with your
community and build trust and loyalty
finally you need to keep learning you
don't have to be afraid to use different
Instagram features and keep up with the
trends to stand out from from others
best way to learn is to keep trying and
keep learning now let's check out some
of the best practices to keep in mind in
your Endeavor to increase followers
first off use relevant hashtags in your
post and stories to reach a wider
audience next you need to post high
quality visually appealing content that
resonates with your target
audience then we have to engage with
your follow ERS by responding to
comments and asking
questions then we can also collaborate
with other users particularly those who
have large or engaged
following then we have to use Instagram
features such as deals and Instagram
lives to share more personal and
interactive content next we have to
utilize Instagram's paid promotion
options to reach a larger or targeted
audience then you can also consider
using Instagram's explore feature to
discover and engage with user who are
interested in similar content as to
yours afterwards we can also use
Instagram stories to share behind the
scene content and give your followers a
more personal look at your life or
business then you have to also post
consistently but you need to be careful
not to flood your followers feed at last
you have you can use Instagram's
analytics tools to track the success of
your posts and adjust your strategy
accordingly finally let's close this
session with the best tools to help get
more followers the First Tool in our
agenda is plan ofy this tool allows you
to schedule and publish your post as
well as analyze their
performance the next tool we have is
Hood suit
this tool offers a variety of features
including the ability to schedule and
publish post engage with followers and
track analytics then we have a tool
called later this tool is specifically
designed for Instagram and allow you to
schedule post track analytics and find
relevant
hashtags after that we have
boostr this tool can help you to get
more Instagram followers by Prov
providing a targeted followers through
paid promotions following that we have
social be this tool offers the ability
to schedule and publish post engage with
followers and track analytics finally we
have social drift this tool helps you
get more Instagram followers by using
artificial intelligence to engage with
users who are likely to follow you learn
in today's video we are going to be
talking about Instagram advertising and
Instagram reals what is it what do you
need to know about them what ads are
available Instagram how can you optimize
these ads for maximum performance and
how can you use Instagram reals to grow
your following even further now I am
Mark campman I'm your digital navigator
for this video but before we start if
you like this video click the like
button and if you want to join our
learner community on YouTube subscribe
to our Channel by clicking on the link
below so are you ready let me start with
giving you some interesting Instagram
stats that will show you that Instagram
has to be part of your digital marketing
strategy now Instagram is only 12 year
old it is now the seventh most visited
website in the world yes listen to this
it's the seventh most visited website in
the world and it is the the um fourth
most used social media platform by
monthly active users
1.22 billion um users every month
they're ninth Instagram is ninth on the
Google's most Search terms list it's the
second most downloaded app in the world
on the uh the app stores and Instagram
is most popular amongst the Gen Z
population Generation Z Generation X
males are the fastest growing
demographic Y and that takes Instagram
into a B2B into a business world as well
India has the most number of Instagram
users in the world and people spend more
time on the Instagram stories than in
the Instagram Newsfeed telling you a lot
about the importance of stories these
days and Instagram stories ads they
generate about
25% of Instagram's advertising Revenue
now do you need any more facts to
convince you that Instagram is one of
the most popular social media networks
and that it has to be part of your
digital marketing strategy so let's dive
a bit deeper into the Instagram
advertising opportunities and the reals
that you can use in Instagram so in this
session we are going to be talking about
Instagram ads in digital marketing why
is it so important what are the benefits
that you can get from Instagram ads
we're then going to look at the
different types of Instagram ads that
you you that you have available I'm
going to show you some Instagram ad
Types on Instagram and I'm also going to
show you where on Facebook you can go to
create to create the F the Instagram ads
we're then going to dig into the
Instagram reals yeah it's a new feature
about two years ago it is kind of the um
the the follow-up from igtv it is
Instagram's response to Tik Tok success
yeah and Instagram reals are short
vertical videos that are very powerful
in the um and and used by many people
these days so we're going to dive into
these we're going to see the benefits
that you can get as a business for them
and I'm going to show you quickly where
to go on Instagram to set up these uh
these Instagram reels I'm then going to
give you a few tips on the Instagram
reels and then we're going to close off
today's session with some frequently
asked questions that I'm getting a lot
in the when it comes to Instagram
advertising and Instagram reals so are
you ready for this let's get started
let's look at Instagram ads in digital
marketing so let's talk about Instagram
ads and branding first why is it so
important to use Instagram advertising
for your branding well more than 25
billion businesses use Instagram to
promote their services and
products yeah so when they are all
working on developing their brand
through Instagram so 90% of the
Instagram accounts they follow at least
one business on Instagram and 62% of
users say that they are more interested
in a brand after seeing them in an
Instagram story so it's a very important
platform for Brands to connect with
their users yeah and many Instagram
users they actually use Instagram to
research new products and services and
most Instagram users almost more than
80% they say they take an action after
seeing a product on
Instagram yes so no surprise that many
brands are active on Instagram yeah and
on average you can say that the brands
do about one and a half times posting
every day yeah so there's no doubt that
Instagram should be part of your
business yeah it is an effective tool
for advertisers to boost brand awareness
and increase engagement with their
followers and their customers and it's
not only a platform to Showcase your
brand but also a channel through which
you can interact with your followers and
build customer loyalty and then I'm not
even talking yet about the Ecommerce
opportunities you have on Instagram by
opening up a shop by promoting your
products on Instagram so a platform
where you definitely have to
be so it canect as a new channel for
your business which can extend your
online presence and when you are on
Instagram you can promote you can sell
you can increase sales of your business
yeah you can gain many many benefits
from being on Instagram and here are
just a few of them so you can keep up
with what's happening in the world so if
many people if everyone yeah billions of
people are on Instagram why aren't you
so there is the new Instagram shop
feature that can help you and your brand
to get more sales so you can open up a
shop on Facebook you can then connect
that shop with your Instagram and you
can promote your products you can tag
your products in your Instagram posts
and that will lead to sales through your
um your Facebook and your e-commerce
shop it's fantastic for competitor
analysis what are your competitors doing
on Instagram what are they promoting
what are they advertising you can learn
a lot about what works and what doesn't
work in the the market Instagram is also
a place where you can connect with your
customers where you can deliver customer
service yeah so it's not just offline or
not just on Twitter but you can use that
on Instagram as well
so Instagram these days is a very normal
a very basic platforms and it's almost
like you're having your website
customers expect you to be on Instagram
as well these days so if you do that
properly it can help you in getting more
customers growing your online customer
base on Instagram and it can help you in
developing your brand to generate more
sales and to grow your online reputation
by setting the tone and the style of
your post you can immediately develop
and present an online sort of identity
that you can then transfer into your
online
reputation another powerful aspect of
that you have with Instagram is that you
can work with influencers yeah there's
many influencers many Instagram um users
with large followings they offer their
services to Brands to help them in
promoting their products and services so
that is not enough for you finally yeah
the virality on Instagram is very very
strong so if you have good content good
posts good stories Good reals you can go
very high and wide and far through the
uh the Instagram um the Instagram world
and many people will view your videos
and share your videos so it's a platform
you can no longer ignore and you
definitely want want to be
there so in 2020 a new style of post was
created which was called the Instagram
reals which is kind of the followup of
the igtv which was a kind of a vertical
video kind of YouTube channel that you
could get on um on on Instagram now it
is sort of an response of Instagram to
the growth of uh of Tik Tok and creators
on Instagram like Justin Bieber lzo
Stanley Tui they really helped to
transform this um feature uh from a
almost like a Tik Tok wannabe to a
fullblown competitor of Tik Tok they are
full screen vertical videos that can be
up to 90 seconds
long yeah they come with many unique
editing tools and an extensive library
of audio tracks as well so it's very
easy to make these short videos and to
start sharing them and you will see that
the view and the engagement that you get
with these Reals in in Instagram is
extremely high on top of the sounds re
can include multiple video clips filters
captures and in and interactive
backgrounds so you can add stickers all
the tools that you expect in
that you see in stories that you see in
Tik Tok you see that in the Instagram
reals as well now they're clearly
different from Instagram stories yeah
Instagram story they did disappear in 24
hours once you post a real it is
available on Instagram until you delete
it so they are also favored by the
Instagram algorithm yeah which is more
likely to recommend them to people who
don't follow you you yes so it is a very
good tool to grow your following but
we'll talk about reals a little later
when we go into the uh after we've gone
into the advertising on Instagram so
let's look into um advertising on
Instagram here are some interesting
facts about Instagram advertising each
month there are 2 million advertisers
active on
Instagram yeah so that is a big number
of people the estimated advertising
reach for Instagram users is
1.32 billion users yeah so there and
that is an important one the Instagram
advertising reach has outpaced
Facebook's advertising reach in the last
year so then did you know you can reach
22% of the GL global population age 13
or older in Instagram so a platform an
advertising platform that you cannot
ignore yeah and through Instagram reals
you can reach another potential audience
of close to a billion people so and
interesting fact to know is that the
split in female and male is about 45 and
55% on the advertising audience for the
uh Instagram
reals so how do you create Instagram um
ads through the Facebook advertising
manager yep and we've done a um a short
or a video about Facebook advertising in
the um in in the earlier video of this
series but um so I'm not going to go
into this but I do want to show you um a
new feature in the Facebook and
Instagram advertising advertising setup
but before we go into this let's have a
quick look at Instagram and see if we
can find some ads so if I go out of here
and I go to um
Instagram yeah so here you see my mobile
let's log in and we're going to
Instagram yeah so by just by browsing
through your news feed you will already
come across ads yeah so let's see where
we see an ad popping
up so here you see one yes so Sahara
Services official and because it's an ad
you see it's a sponsored ad and here you
see the type of ad that we see here is a
photo ad just one photo that they have
with a call to action in this case visit
the Instagram
profile so here you see an ad yeah which
is again is sponsored but here you see I
can flick through the photo so this is
what we call a carousel ad yeah so there
are multiple photos or in this case
videos so you could also see this as
kind of a video ad but this is a
combination of a video ad and a carousel
ad where you can flick through multiple
photos so what I've done I've saved a
few um a few ads yeah that is easier so
I don't have to browse so if I click
here on the saved and here you see some
ads yeah so here you see an example of a
photo ad but multiple photos and that's
why we also call this a carousel
ad okay here you see an example of
another carousel ad yeah so you can see
that it's an ad because it says
sponsored again multiple photos and a
call to action yeah here you have a
photo ad where it's just one photo and
here you see another Carousel ad with
two
photos and here you see a video
ad yeah so these are the ads that you
see on uh in the news feed
besides that there are ads in the
stories and here at the top you see the
stories so let's go here browse through
the stories so here you see and we
immediately see here a sponsored ad from
Barcelona Tanger yeah and this is a
video ad yeah what I like about the ads
on the stories and that's why they are
so powerful they have a very sort of
natural blend with the stories before
and after them they don't really look
like ads and particularly if you're
making them full screen vertical ads
yeah they blend in very well with the
the with the news feed yeah of the story
feed yep so here you see another
ad yeah with as a story so you can call
to action are you looking for the click
on the more yeah and then you can have
different more information in the ad as
well so very
powerful yeah here you see another
ad okay so those are your ads on on the
on the stories and then here you see the
reals yeah now
um yeah but we'll come back back to the
reals later and here in the reals you
will be will be able to see and to
Showcase your ads as
well okay so that is the uh those are
the ads on um uh on Instagram yeah so if
I summarize
this yeah if we look at the uh the
Instagram
ads so the first ads that we saw were
the photo or the image ads yeah so
particularly for campaigns where there
is a very strong visual aspect yeah
strong visual information that you can
summarize in one single image they are
the best um for creating image ad these
pictures can be produced using your own
photographers or designs or
illustrations or or you can even take an
existing post that you can promote or
that you can boost as an image ad as
well so very straightforward very simple
but the image ads are the simplest way
of um creating Instagram ads here you
have a story ad so a story ad multiple
visuals that go in a story engagement is
typically greater with story ads yeah
because it ort of cats the entire Mobile
screen and it's much more engaging than
ads in the uh in the news feed yep so
you see here there is not really video
in there but it is moving kind of images
moving text yeah and audio in this ad
from from Spotify so story ads are
extremely powerful one of the most
popular types of ads in Instagram and
again very easy to to create you then
have the video ads so if you want to
give the viewers a more indepth look of
your brand your products your services
then run a video ad on Instagram
so make them short you can make them
Square you can make them full uh full
sort of vertical full screen but the
important thing is try to make the
content
engaging yep and that is where video ads
are so powerful and they can bring a
message across in a very powerful way
video ads on Instagram they are probably
the ads with the highest
conversions yeah for um for people that
view the ad and if you want them to take
an action so yep so those are the video
ads and then you have the reals ads so
in mix with reals you can have 30 second
long ads that are sort of comparable to
story advertising so they're full screen
vertical videos and again they properly
merge with the organic reels yep and
they have feature they have sound they
feature Sound and Music so very powerful
ads where you can get very good call to
actions learn more learn more buy now
yeah different sort of call to actions
that can really lead people either to
drive them to your website or drive them
to your shop where they can buy your
product yep and then we have the
carousel ads and the carousel ads is
what I showed you where you have a
collection of photos or videos that
people can swipe through yep so they can
particularly they work really well in
your Instagram feed and they are really
good for showcasing multiple products in
your ad what you also see is that people
use Carousel ads where they have one
large sort of horizontal photo that they
split up in three sections so it is
almost like browsing through the photo
from left to right so very powerful ads
that you can get on um on Google on
Facebook and on Instagram
advertising okay now before we go into
the reals let's go to Facebook ads and
show you some new featur
on uh on the advertising for the um for
Instagram advertising so here you see
the Facebook business manager yeah so it
is the meta business Suite which is sort
of a new integrated platform um which
brings together a number of functions it
used to be the Facebook business manager
but they now have brought it all under
the meta business Suite so if I go there
for my riat Foria page it takes you to
everything you need to do and to plan
and to manage and to track of your
Facebook or your Instagram account yeah
you see here I man can manage the
Facebook page and I can manage the
Instagram page now we're not going to go
into the whole of the meta business suit
I just want to show you the advertising
and a new feature here in advertising if
I click on all tools and then I click
here on
ADD yeah so this is kind of a quick
creation of ads I can automate my ads I
can choose a goal for my ads or I can
boost existing content and I just want
to show you how easy it is these days to
make an ad for your Instagram so if I
want to boost a post yeah or I can get
more leads or whatever I want to do yeah
boost post an Instagram post or real
let's go into that yeah so content type
I'm just going to do a post for this
sake yeah so we're going to boost this
post yep and then here you will see how
the ad will look like in your Instagram
feed in this case yep and that's where
you can change the text of your ad so
it's a really good feature to quickly
launch an ad of an existing post post
make sure you've got your ad blocker
Switched Off to get access to this yeah
you can have other previews as well
let's see what that will give
us yeah so here you see the feed in
Instagram Explorer here would the
Instagram
feed here would how it looks in
stories here is how it would look in
Instagram
reals yes so really useful tool to
quickly see how your ads will show on
Instagram yeah for an existing post and
then of course you can have the same
facilities if you want to create a new
post okay so that's all I'm going to
share with you on Facebook and Instagram
advertising and how to create your uh
Instagram ads through the meta business
Suite right so let's go back to the
presentation and let's look at the
Instagram reals
so yeah so where are the reals in
Instagram if I click here on Instagram
and then here is my home yeah if I click
at the bottom on the little icon here I
can then go to reals and this is exactly
like Tik Tok I can just flick up and
that take takes me to the next
post okay so very useful and very simple
way of um of creating and sharing
content in very popular way and a lot of
people spend time on the reals to find
really cool content okay so here I can
go to the search and I can search for
items so I can search for instance look
at marketing how to yeah and here you
see books to master marketing which is
in a real format so this is how I can
then access posts in relation to
marketing yeah and um and other elements
yeah books to
read yeah so lots of stuff here on the
reals that you can use to find content
in every top topic that you're
interested in yep so uh here is more
reals on on
Morocco yeah so very useful tool now how
do you create a real you click on the
plus icon and you basically select here
at the bottom post story real or live
you click real and then you see the four
op five options that you have here for
the audio the length of the video the
speed yeah the grid that you want to
change the scale and there's even a
timer so there's lots of functionality
that you can use here in your um in
developing your video Then by pressing
the center button you can start
recording the video yeah and there is
also opportunities to get um take for
instance do little characters dancing on
your desk yeah or on your keyboard you
can make them slightly
bigger yeah we lost the character where
was he and now we're recording we've
lost so here's our character I can blow
him up a bit yep and we then see him
dancing on our screen yeah happy with
that stop it do
next yeah I'm going to not not add a
sticker here is the video that we've
just
created yeah I can edit a clip if I want
to I click next and then I can share it
to reals I can write a caption I can add
stickers and all the standard stuff that
you can do on your uh on the reels yeah
so very cool very like Tik Tok and this
the best thing about it it is so simple
to make is very
intuitive okay so that is a quick
introduction of the
reals so how do you fit reals into your
digital marketing strategy let's have a
look at that in a bit more um in a bit
more detail yes so it is a really good
way to give your audience a behind the
scenes overview yes so which works well
to get engagement and to get Trust on
your brand yes so look at the culture in
the company how you make your product
how hard people work look at the the
customer services how they work it's a
really good way to give people a
behindth scenes look of the company and
again to build this brand trust people
really appreciate that yeah so that is
one of the things that you can do with
Instagram reals another very powerful
aspect of Instagram reals is that you
can use it to generate what we call user
generated content why not ask your
customers or your users to create reals
around a topic that you work on yeah and
share it with with a hashtag yes so it's
a great way for people to getting to
know the company getting to know the
products start using
influencers yeah get competitions going
where you do photo contest um or maybe
video contest and you can turn those
into reals with with the pictures or
make them uh actually let the users
share the the reals they created
themselves yes so sharing user generated
content is a second big benefit that you
can get from using Instagram reals now
Instagram reals because they're short
people have short attention span they're
also really good to educate your
customers yeah or educate your audience
they're a great great way to develop
yourself as a as an expert in your field
by giving their audience value yeah on
how to use your products how to
um to to answer questions about your
products yeah on how to do specific
things in uh in using your products so
get people to learn around your product
and if you make that a recurring type of
real people will come back for them
because they want to learn more about
your products it's also good to see your
products in actions so combined with
user generated content why not ask your
audience yeah your customers to make
short reels on how they use your
products yes so but if you want to do it
yourself you can really try to highlight
what sets your product apart from your
competition
so yeah use that to your advantage in
using Instagram reals to highlight your
products and to see your products in
action and of course it goes without
saying if you make it fun if you make it
more personalized yeah that is a
fantastic way to connect with your
audience yep and that is where children
work really well where pets cats dogs
work really well try to get casual try
to interact with your followers through
very sort of emotional casual content so
and often what you will see that these
type of reals will have very high number
of views because people just love to
browse through that type of content yeah
create your own challenge or create your
own Trends encourage your fans to
participate and use a special hashtag to
share the cont content they create yeah
for you so that's the big benefits that
you can get from the reals yes so use
that to your advantage good so let's
look at some tips and tricks on
Instagram advertising now remember most
people
watch content on their mobile Instagram
is a mobile app so so make sure that you
design your ads with Mobile in mind make
sure that you optimize your ads for
mobile there's nothing worse than seeing
a um an Instagram story ads with a
horizontal video and then black above
and below yes so optimize it for the
mobile and mobile is vertical so use
that vertical format because the
immersion is better but also it's much
easier to crop a vertical video to a 4x5
aspect R ratio or a square ratio than a
landscape video yes so make sure you
design your ads for mobile first tip two
let the visuals speak for
themselves yeah make your ads less
worthy and use Font sizes that are
optimal use color yeah make to use
capitals make sure that it is optimized
for mobile devices use big fonts that
stand out use colors that stand out and
that the visuals speak for
themselves tip three yeah use animations
use Motion Graphics it is not just video
that you need to have but animated text
animated things happening on the screen
they are videos as well so let the
screen come to life either through video
or through animation and Motion
Graphics and of course very important
Keep The Branding keep the messaging
that you have keep it at the front yeah
and the first three seconds people will
decide if they want to watch the entire
ad or continue to scroll yeah so make
sure that in the first three SE seconds
you capture people's attention and
you've put your branding and your
message
across and then of course you sound yeah
you sound in your ads so although lot of
people they may want to watch it without
audio Yeah make it accessible by people
with music muted volume use trendy
soundtracks to engage those who choose
to listen to your
videos yeah consider using captions as
well or text overlays that's very
important if you have somebody speaking
in your ads yeah always use captions or
overlay of text to make sure that if
people have the sound off that they can
still understand what the ad is all
about right so that is all on the
Instagram ads and the Instagram reals so
let's look at some of the questions that
I'm getting yeah from people when we
talk about Instagram reals and Instagram
advertising so one question I'm getting
a lot is if I do my reals
yeah I didn't get much engagement what
should I do to improve yes so now first
of all in general Instagram reals have
have a very high
engagement yes so they're probably the
part of Instagram with the highest
engagement that you will see and I will
show you y so if I go to my Instagram
here on the of my my riat for Russia let
me close this
here yes
so save the draft close yeah so I'm
going to my Instagram
so this is my profile and here you see
my reals now if I post a video a normal
video I used to get maybe I could I get
some views but nothing like thousands or
thousands of views yeah so since we've
been using Instagram
reals yeah we've now get views and place
on our videos here 1,200
44 here is a view
11,000 views of the
video Yeah here you see 6,000 views of
the video these were numbers we would
never get yeah on the Instagram news
feed or the Instagram stories so here
you see you do get the engagement of
your um of the reals on Instagram yeah
and it's one of the big reasons is that
in stagram favors the Instagram
algorithm favors Reals in your um yeah
in sharing your content okay so make
sure that your video content is up to
scratch maybe the music could be
improved a really good way is to look at
what your competitors are doing yeah and
maybe they do things that you're not
doing so try to learn from that okay
question two how do I choose to write
soundtrack for my Instagram reels good
question yeah it's very important that
you get the right sound for your
Instagram reels now Instagram has a
whole library of sounds that you can
choose from in creating your uh your
reals Facebook has a huge library of
thousands and thousands of sounds that
you can download royaltyfree and use in
your uh in your posts in your ads yes
so very important first of all is that
you look at what's trending in the world
yeah when it comes to picking a
soundtrack yeah so learn from that what
are the hits at the moment what are the
most popular sound music videos on
YouTube what's the most popular music on
uh on Instagram learn from that yep and
then make your decision ition on what
music you want to use in your
video okay will reals get me organic
audience or do I need to promote them as
well so the beauty about digital
marketing is that you decide what you
want to do yeah whether you just want
organic or whether you want to advertise
yeah so just to be clear for everybody
when I say organic audience it means
that if I do a post without any
advertising how many people will see my
post how many people will see my video
my real and how many people may like it
or share it yeah and we know and as I
said earlier the reals have a
high fairly High organic reach from the
three areas in Instagram posts stories
and reals reals giv you the highest
organic reach at the moment but we also
know these days and if you look at some
of my other videos that I posted on
YouTube on digital marketing that social
media is no longer a free right social
media these days is pay to play yeah so
if you really want to use Instagram and
Instagram reals to grow your business to
find leads then you need to
combine
organic marketing with paid marketing
yes
so start looking into what we call the
payperclick advertising and see how much
wider and how much bigger the audience
is that you can Target yep and then try
to invest some money in the
pay-per-click advertising and see what
results you
get so always good to look into that
have your options open but the good
thing about digital marketing
you decide what you want to do in this
case Instagram is a social media
platform that needs no introduction with
nearly 1 billion monthly active users
and 500 million daily active users
Instagram is a platform r with marketing
potential more than $7 billion Revenue
has been generated from Instagram mobile
and it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers not only that marketing on
Instagram has has the following
advantages
too you have increased conversions
according to research more than onethird
of the people using the app have used it
to purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of
conversion you also have advanced
targeting options this is in part thanks
to Instagram's parent company Facebook
Instagram has access to just about all
advertising features offered by Facebook
ads with this you can advertise to
people based on their age location
gender interests and much more you can
also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a
consumer so let's have a look at how
marketing is done on
Instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your
bio your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and
engaging use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more your bio should also
include a URL to where you want to drive
traffic to be it your Brand's website or
a page for a particular product make
sure to track this link as well to see
how much traffic it brings here's an
example of how Samsung uses its bio
effectively you can see it's a very
straight forward it's got a branded
hashtag it talks about all the services
Samsung offers there are links to other
pages and a link to the website as well
it's to the point and covers everything
you need to know about it next up at
number two we have create a Content
calendar now if you ask anyone who works
with social media one of the most
important things they'll tell you is to
have a Content
calendar a Content calendar enables you
to keep track of your posts it'll help
you plan ahead and automate the process
of publishing your posts when your
audience is most active a calendar helps
you decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time a consistent assistent post
schedule will enable you to make the
most out of Instagram it'll also keep
your audience engaged and also give you
access to historical posts if you want
to repost your older
content next up we have number three get
greater reach with ads paid ads can
enable you to get more followers
engagement leads and
conversions the caveat here being that
you will need to pay for it too the ad
options are pretty similar to what you
have on Facebook like audience segment
ation based on likes interactions buying
habits and more you also have a variety
of AD formats to choose from like story
ads image ads video ads collection ads
and more moreover they can also be set
up from Facebook ads manager here's an
example from an ad from body shop in
which they're using a single image ad
the advertising works because of its
interesting creative and attractive ad
copy that attracts the customer to
interact with the post and click on the
link let's go to number four have a
visually consistent feed Instagram is a
platform in which people gravitate
towards aesthetically pleasing
content to authentic expressions and
diverse perspectives the objective is
that your feed needs to match with your
Brand's identity and must appeal to the
audience within your industry what works
nowadays are candid shots muted Earthly
tones with a lowkey editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand
approachable as you can see in the
images all of them have aesthetically
pleasing images and a somewhat blue or
underwater theme and that's the kind of
thing you should aim for your content
following an understandable and
interesting aesthetic depending on the
product you're trying to sell now for
number five tell a story the images
videos and stories you post need to tell
stories that can Captivate your audience
and establish a connection with them
this makes it more likely that they feel
closer to your brand and buy your
products your captions can tell stories
that can help your brand appear more
human and build deeper connections with
your
audience your content needs to align
with what your audience cares about or
solves problems they face here's an
example of how the page Patagonia talks
about forests in America each of their
posts tell stories about a different
issue that affects nature their brand on
Instagram revolves around bringing
awareness to such issues that's the kind
of stories you should tell with your
brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags using the right hashtags can
make the difference between your post
showing up on the explore tab for
everyone to see and it getting lost in a
sea of
content your hashtags shouldn't be too
generic like hash New Year or hash style
since they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers research on successful
hashtags and limit yourself to less than
seven in each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and
unprofessional find out what and how
many hashtags your competitors use and
how you can do something
similar you could also create a hashtag
for your brand these need to be short
easily memorable and involve your brand
name in some way let's now go to number
seven take advantage of ugc ugc or user
generated content gives your followers
to further involve themselves with your
brand ugc also by them as well
regardless of the field your brand
belongs to ugc can be used to convert
followers into Advocates of your brand
here's an example of how Starbucks uses
user generated content and takes
advantages of Their audience to
advertise their products in this post
here they're attracting customers with
an image of happy children dressed in
products sto at
Starbucks the post posted by another
user would be appreciated appreciated by
the audience and improve brand
loyalty next up number eight take
advantage of video ads most
instagrammers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even the photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising video
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads single video
ads that can create 60-second ads corros
are a combination of images and videos
and Instagram stories that enable you to
combine images and videos to create
visually attractive
ads here's an example of the brand Pizza
73 using story ads to advertise their
pizzas it's successful because you're
showing off the product they are
advertising with well shot videos and
captions now for number nine partner up
with
influencers connecting with influencers
will enable you to connect with thought
leaders within the industry indry and
enable you to show off your brand to a
larger Audience by connecting with them
your brand will have greater
authenticity and Authority influencers
need to be given new tools resources and
guidance to carry out their role
effectively and to work together as
partners micro influencers are also
considered to be more affordable and
they have a closer connection with their
audience here we can see how Ralph
Lauren have collaborated with an
influencer to advertise their products
the influencer showing off the latest
Ralph Lauren has to offer this
encourages his interested followers to
check out the page and buy something for
themselves next for number 10 host
contests and giveaways contests enable
your audience to engage with your brand
with 3.5 times more likes and 64 times
the comments you can give away a product
or a service which enables you to boost
engagement and brand awareness contests
and giveaways need to be planned Brands
need to be partnered with contest rules
need to be identified posts need to be
created and much more monitoring the
contest and then running it is also
really important you would need to track
your contest performance and promote the
results on other social media platforms
as well here's an example of a contest
run by Domino's Pizza which encourages
people to contribute their own short
stories and connect better with the
Brand number 11 take advantage of
stories and igtv stories enable you to
create a combination of photos and
videos that disappear after 20 4 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand SE more approachable and
authentic adding links to the Instagram
stories can also help with driving
traffic to your
website igtv on the other hand although
now seemingly on the decline still has a
few advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like feature
ads and interviews another new tool they
have introduced is Instagram reals
Instagram's answer to Tik talk Instagram
released reels through which users would
be able to upload 15sec clips and since
it released very recently it's arri with
marketing
potential finally we have number 12
track and learn identify effective
hashtags visual Styles and the best
times to post doing this you can develop
the best practices for your brand social
listening and analytics will help you
fine-tune your marketing strategy and
increase Instagram engagement on that
note if you are looking to learn social
media marketing and become a digital
marketing expert then look no further
than the simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing don't miss
out on this opportunity Find The Cost
Link in the description box for more
information we're going to be talking
about what are YouTube channels how do
you set them up how do you optimize them
and how do you subscribe subcribe to
them but before we start let me quickly
introduce myself I am Mark campman I
will be your digital navigator for this
video and if you like the video please
click the like button or if you want to
join our YouTube Community why don't you
hit the Subscribe button so what's all
this about in YouTube why is YouTube so
popular what makes it so special and why
do you need a YouTube channel well the
numbers they speak for themselves over 2
and a half billion people open YouTube
at least once a month that is onethird
of the world's
population YouTube generates around $30
billion of Revenue in 2021 that is $78
million a day these are extraordinary
amounts and this is primarily
advertising Revenue now 25% of global
mobile usage is for YouTube it's one of
the most popular mobile apps and YouTube
is the main source of video for 78% of
its users look at the younger generation
they don't watch the restal TV they
watch TV on YouTube so on the back of
this a whole community of video creators
have emerged people who go on YouTube to
present to share to discuss to debate to
invent to compare and become famous with
posting their videos we call them
YouTubers and I don't have to mention
people like kangam style Justin Bieber
sha Mendes Ariana Grande daa Lipa and
what about brands that made it big on
YouTube the Dollar Shave Club Blend Tech
with blend will it blend and it's the
YouTube channel they use as the social
platform for their videos a YouTube
channel serves as the homepage for a
user's account anyone can view YouTube
without having an account however you
need to create a YouTube channel if you
plan to upload videos add comments or
make playlists but more about how to do
this later businesses can also have a
YouTube channel these channels are
different from the personal channels
because they can have more than one
owner of
manager so how do businesses benefit
from YouTube well posting on YouTube
will help people find you on Google
remember Google owns YouTube by
consistently utilizing YouTube for your
business you can increase your chances
of showing up in the search results and
improving your own
rankings YouTube will also expose you to
a huge Global audience YouTube is
available in over 80 languages and it re
sees more than 30 million visitors a day
who watch nearly 5 billion videos it's
the second biggest search engine coming
only after Google itself and the YouTube
app again as I said earlier is one of
the most popular apps in the store
YouTube gives you qualified traffic
people on YouTube often have a question
they search for and if your video can
answer the question they have you will
get a qualified lead it's much like
Google search but then it's
visual also video content is 12 times
more likelier to be watched than text to
read video can evoke emotion they can
make you think they can make you feel
and if they make you think and feel
you're not likely to forget those videos
and that's much more that can be said
for most other types of online
marketing video also help to humanize
your brand they bring it to live taking
your messages from flat and static to
Dynamic and engaging videos help your
brand build trust and loyalty in a
unique way you can also use YouTube ads
to reach an even bigger audience YouTube
advertising runs on through the Google
ads platform and has some very powerful
features and more about these ads on
YouTube later
videos can also be repurposed across
many other channels so they can help you
drive additional traffic to your website
you can share them on your social media
channels you can embed them on your own
website or you can include them in your
email
marketing to summarize video marketing
is a must for your business and if
you're not on the video train you will
miss the next stop publishing regular
videos is key and YouTube offers you a
YouTube channel as your YouTube homepage
for all your videos so here's a bit more
background information about the Y
YouTube ecosystem it's important to know
that there are three players in the
YouTube ecosystem there's you the viewer
there's the content creator or the
people that upload their videos and
there are Brands brands who want to
reach you to sell their products and
it's YouTube's challenge to keep
everybody happy in this ecosystem to
keep you happy to show you the best
videos keep content creators Happy by
enabling them to make some money and to
keep Brands Happy by connecting them
with the biggest audience possible so
how do Brands connect with you very
simple through advertising show your
short video ads before or during the
videos you watch in fact 84% of YouTube
viewers bought from Brands after
watching videos or ads they see on
YouTube and then how do content creators
make money very simple YouTube enables
them to earn ad revenue from ads that
run before or during their videos every
time an ad shows in front of or during
the video they get a percentage of the
ad revenue and I'm sure you've seen
those ads while you were watching
YouTube videos but not every YouTube
content creator qualifies for this you
need to have at least 1,000 subscribers
to your channel and a minimum of 4,000
watch hours on your channel in other
words advertising in YouTube is the oil
of the YouTube ecosystem it keeps
everybody happy and there are a variety
of ads marketeers can choose from many
of them find pre-roll skippable ads the
most effective you know those ads that
you can skip after a few seconds just a
little side note Here YouTube ads on
mobile are the most effective for the
simple reasons that many people watch
videos on their mobile but also many
peoples have blockers on their desktop
so your ads will not be seen on their
desktop YouTube has recognized the power
of mobile video and and mobile ads and
has announced that it will share 45% of
AD revenue on YouTube
shorts now what are YouTube Shorts
YouTube shorts are short vertical videos
and they are YouTube's response to the
phenomenal growth of Tik Tok and
vertical videos are key these days if
you want to boost engagement consider
using vertical videos and here's why it
has a 90% higher completion rate
compared to Vertical videos about 80% of
consumers claim that the format is more
engaging and 65% of people find Brands
using vertical videos for their
advertising to be more
Innovative so enough of the theory let's
look at the YouTube channels and look at
what you need and how to set up a un
YouTube
channel first of all you need a kit to
make videos whether it's your computer
your webcam a camera a smartphone and of
course you need video editing software
and very important you need an in indoor
or outdoor environment to make your
videos and then of course you need to
make the video this will be a topic for
another simply learn video in its own
right but here are a few
tips what made people watch
videos people watch videos when they are
educational informational entertaining
funny controversial or shocking lots of
examples
in these categories of videos in YouTube
now what type of videos do people like
to watch there's a whole range of
different types of videos but if you
want to look at the most popular ones
you talk about unpacking videos review
videos Challenge videos whole videos
parodies covers live videos howto videos
it's a whole range of styles of video of
topics of video that you can create
whether it's for Consumer videos or for
business
videos now what type of videos can you
make there's a whole range of different
types there's standard format video
which is horizontal there's the vertical
video which I talked about a little
earlier there are stop motion videos
yeah there are time-lapse videos you
could do 360 videos and the big growth
these days is in is in augmented reality
and virtual
reality yep and then what do you need to
think about when you shoot your video
there are three very important aspects
of making your video think about light
think about sound and think about having
a stable camera
position yeah light is very important
there's no better light than outdoor
light and if you haven't got out if you
don't shoot outdoor but indoor make sure
you have a good lighting
setup sound can be very deceiving if
you're interviewing somebody on the
video outside you think there is no wind
but then when you hear the video back on
your computer you hear the wind it's
it's quite an interesting uh phenomenon
but it's a fact so best is to have a
high quality microphone that you use
when you interview or when you record
your videos and think about a tripod as
well make sure your camera is in a
stable position so that's the theory
behind all this let's now look at some
YouTube channels and show you how to
make a YouTube channel and here is the
simply learn YouTube channel a very
clear Channel with lots of content for
people to learn about all topics in um
in technology so here you see the banner
yeah with some good messaging in there
you have your logo here you see the
number of
subscribers yep so you see it's a
verified account by YouTube and here is
the Subscribe button yep and when you
are subscribed to a video or to a
channel they you get um sort of
personalized notifications or you can
switch off the notifications but the
beauty about people subscribing to your
channel is that they will receive a
notification when you publish a new
video then here you have a menu of
things that people can go to there's the
homepage for all your videos there is a
list of all your videos you can organize
your videos in playlists you can look at
the comments that you're getting in the
community section you can set up
different channels and you can group
those channels under your account and
here is the about page where you have
about information about the company yep
and this is you can optimize this with
keywords so Google will um Index this
for the uh for the search as well so
let's look at this homepage again and
the um The Branding yeah so here you see
a feature video and there are two
elements in this that are important here
first of all you saw just when I got on
the page before I subscribed you saw a
different video yep and then when you
come back to the page you can see
another video so basically you have a
video that you can put here for
firsttime visitors where you can promote
your company or your channel and then
you can have another video set up for um
returning visitors and then here you
have all your videos and you can
organize them in playlists and in a
minute I'm going to show you how to set
this all up and how to create your own
channel okay so this is simply learn
another example would be one of my
favorites on social media is social
media
examiner here is the social media
examiner YouTube channel way to grow
your following online yeah so here you
see the the featured video here you see
The Branding very good branding with
strong messages on there an industry
report that people can download you see
here you can put a few links to your
social media or your website or where
people can download for instance the
industry report here you see The
Branding the logo yeah again I can
subscribe to it and then here you have
the descriptions of the video and the
different channels the different um
playlists okay so and here you have the
group the different channels that they
have under their um their their main
channel the social media
examiner okay so you see coming back and
I see another video here so finally the
other one I want to show you is GoPro
GoPro they are very active on YouTube
very active on uh on on having videos
having videos from their users from
their subscribers having very clear
playlists yes so um and this could be um
different playlists from um users the
different products features and what
what have you what you also see here is
access to the
store yeah where they sell products and
if I click on this I can then go to the
GoPro website where I can buy this this
product so this is an overview of the
YouTube channel on the desktop but as we
all know most people and particularly
the younger generation they watch
YouTube videos on their mobile device so
whatever you do and in The Branding as
well on setting it up you need to make
sure that it looks well and it looks
good on the mobile as well so let's look
at these channels on the mobile device
yeah so here you see the mobile you see
exactly the same um elements of it you
see your banner you see your uh your
your logo number of subscribers and your
feature video and then you have your
other
videos yeah so it's a lot easier to
navigate through one thing that you need
to be careful of is that the width of
the banner is not as wide as the width
on the uh on the desktop yeah so in your
design you need to take that into
consideration otherwise half of this
text will be chopped off yep so this is
simply learn if we're going to social
media
examiner yep so here is the social media
examiner page yeah their Channel again
the the banner and you have uh
subscribed yep and then here you see a
different color yeah where simply learn
it was brownish here it was greenish you
cannot change this color that is
something that YouTube will decide based
on the overall color it can pick it will
pick up on your um on your desktop on
your uh on your YouTube channel okay so
and again remember the banner how white
you you go and then the other one was
the
GoPro yep here is the GoPro Channel same
look and feel here it is grayish yeah
with the banner the logo and then the um
the feature
video right time to have a look at how I
create a YouTube channel and how I
optimize it so I can grow my number of
subscribers to my channel here you see
the overall YouTube interface and it's
very important that you get into YouTube
and that you sign in with your Google
account and once you have your Google
account set up and you're logged into
your Google account you can create a
YouTube channel so how do you create a
YouTube channel here you see a your user
yeah and here you see your user icon and
for me it's just why I haven't put any
visual there yet yep and if you haven't
done anything on YouTube yet then this
is the screen that you will see yeah
here you see the videos that you can all
access the subscriptions how you can
explore and you can use YouTube without
having uploaded any video yourself or
without having created a channel if you
want to upload a video on YouTube you
click here on the plus of course
everything I'll show you you can do on
the mobile as well but my experience if
you are in admin mode and you want to
add text you want to add your about you
want to make different selections then
it's much easier to work on the desktop
so for demo purposes I'll be showing it
on the desktop toop okay so if I click
here on my user icon I get to the menu
of things I can do in my account my
Google account and my YouTube account
here you see create a channel I can also
go to YouTube studio and in YouTube
Studio I can edit all my videos and
optimize them I can check with another I
can switch to another account I can look
at my members ships my data I can look
at the device theme I'm using the
language the restricted mode whether you
want certain videos not to have
presented to you your location keyboard
shortcuts Etc but what we're going to be
looking at is the create a channel so
I'll just click on create a channel and
here I'm going to add my name and my
name is basically
I'm going to call it
Mark Cube yeah so my channel is called
Mark Cube I can upload my picture here I
can also do that at a later stage so
let's create the Channel first and then
I'll show you how to do The Branding so
we'll click on Create
channel yep and then you will see that
your channel is ready so what I can do
now of course I can upload my first
video I'm not going to do that yet I'm
going to go straight into to customize
my channel and then once my channel has
been set up I'll show you how to upload
your first video so here is customizing
your
channel and there are three elements to
it there is the layout of your channel
there is The Branding of your channel
and there is the basic info of your
channel yeah so let's look at the
branding first but before yeah remember
we had the video Spotlight which was
your featured video so here you can
specify which two videos you want to
have in the featured section whether it
is a video for people who haven't
subscribed and then the feature video
for the people who come back and have
subscribed and then here you have your
featured
sections remember you can have the
videos you can have different sections
that you can add here like popular
uploads live past live streams upcoming
live stream the playlists subscriptions
feature channels all in the menu that I
showed you earlier but we'll come back
to that in a little bit Yeah here is
your menu on the left which is also
important yeah so and we'll come back to
that in a minute as well so first we're
going to do is look at The
Branding yeah and here I can add my logo
I can add my banner image and I can add
a video Watermark which is standard
Watermark that will show in all your
videos so very simple we're going to
upload the images so here you see my I
created these in advance yeah so here
you see my YouTube logo yep so very
simple icon and I can now select okay
what section will I do I want and make
sure it fits within your image area and
you click done and you have your icon
your picture in set up here you see the
banner image you see at least 2048 by
1152 pixels and 6 megabytes or or less
if I click upload I then have my banner
image I click open yeah and here
remember what you see on the desktop and
what you see on the mobile so here it is
important that you look at the text that
you have on your banner and make sure
that it is viewable on all devices I'm
happy with this so I click
done I'm not going to do the watermark
and then I'm going to click public
yep so the changes have been published
so if I'm now going to look at my
channel view the channel on YouTube you
now see I have my banner I have my uh my
banner here I have my logo but of course
there's still a lot I have to do I have
to look at work on the about I have to
add maybe some other items in the menu
and of course I have to upload a video
so let's go back to the customize the
channel and what I'm going to look now
is to the basic info so first of all I
have my description so in the
description I'm going to tell people
what my channel is all about welcome to
my YouTube
channel a
place to learn
everything
there is to
know about digital
marketing yeah and I can make this as
big as possible very I have a thousand
characters available and very important
think keywords here yeah if you follow
digital marketing courses keywords are
the Cornerstone of your digital
marketing strategy I can add a language
and here I have my channel you URL and I
can change this if I want to yeah so
it's a standard web address for your
channel it includes your unique Channel
ID yeah but you can change this as
well yeah so I can say here
Mark no actually I cannot change this I
will be able I think to change this
let's have a
look customize a customize URL is a
shorter easy to member URL that you can
share with your audience and where you
have 100 or more subscribers you have at
least 30 days all of your channel you
have uploaded your branding as well yeah
so to
have your number to have your customized
URL you need to have these 100
subscribers and have a channel that's at
least 30 days old so I can't change this
right now and then here you can add the
links remember the links that you see on
on your banner you can add a link yeah
so here I can say the link is um Mark
campman or let's
say
simply
learn.com and I can say
https
simply
learn.com yeah and I can add a link I
can say um Facebook
and I can say
https
facebook.com forward SL simply learn and
I'm going to add uh
Instagram and I'm going to say
https
instagram.com SLS simplylearn
okay yep and and then here I can say
which links do I want to show on the
banner yeah I can add a whole load of
links here but then I can say just show
me the first three links on the banner
here's the contact info that is Mark at
SLE
learn.com yep so here is my about
section ready and then here I can click
publish and now I can go back to my
channel and what you see now my channel
is ready we have the banner we have the
home uh the logo and now here you see
simply learn.com the website the
Facebook and the Instagram it will
automatically pick up the logos from the
Facebook and the Instagram and the other
social networks that you want to add
here all right so the next thing is that
we need to look here at the uh the
topics that we want here yeah we have
Home Videos playlists channels and about
so I can add multiple channels if I want
but let's go back to
customizing yes so we've done the layout
we've done we're going to look at the
layout now we've done The Branding we've
done the basic info so here is the
channel trailer we're going to do in a
minute when we've uploaded our first
videos so let's add a section and that
would be the created
playlists yep and we want to add a
section let's say uh popular uploads
okay and then I can say give me the
created playlist I want to the
top yeah I want um the uploaded videos
and then I have the shorts and I have
the popular uploads okay and again I'm
going to click publish I'm going back to
my
channel
yep so and now you won't see the order
yet because I haven't put in any vid any
videos of course but you will see as
soon as we start adding videos then you
will can you can see that we um uh that
you get the order that we've
specified okay
so finally before we're going to upload
the video when we go into customizing
your Channel you need to be aware here
of the features as well yeah the menu
items that you have so here is your
channel dashboard so in your channel
dashboard you see the videos that you
uploaded and it gives you basic Channel
analytics yeah and here you have some
news from YouTube um about new features
new training Etc here you see the
content so here you see a list of the
videos that you've uploaded their
visibility status is there a restriction
on the video what is the date that you
uploaded and you get some basic
analytics views comments and
likes okay here are your playlists that
you've created here you get your basic
YouTube channel
analytics yeah you're looking at your
comments that you get so here you can
sort of um review the comments you can
set some moderation guidelines here you
can also add subtitles to your videos
now we'll go into that in more detail
when we go into YouTube and uploading
videos and how to optimize your YouTube
videos but Google will
automatically subtitle your videos and
you can edit the um the subscri the
subtitles that Google will uh will do
yeah and very important to remember if
you use the Google subtitles for your
video it will not be indexed for search
for the simple reason that there may be
words that Google misinterpreted in your
video so you always need to edit the
video take the typos the um the words
that are misunderstood by Google change
those and then soon as you then change
the revised version of the subtitles
Google will then index the um the
transcribed file yeah for search here is
copyright information here is
monetization of your videos is important
we talked about this earlier yeah so
remember where you can have advertising
showing before or during your videos and
that is you will have to become part of
the YouTube partner program and once
you're a member of the partner program
you'll be eligible to earn money from
your videos but you need to have a
minimum of 1,000 subscribers and a
minimum of 4,000 watch hours on your
videos you need to set up two-step
verification and you need to um um agree
to the community
guidelines okay here is customization of
your channel yeah we sort of went
through this earlier and then here is a
little nugget in YouTube that not many
people are aware of and that is the
audio library YouTube holds a huge audio
library of tracks and sound files yeah
and sound effects that you can actually
download and add to your videos you can
search the library so it is a huge
library that you can add for free to add
to all your videos
and then finally there is the settings
of your channel so you can specify the
conversion or the currency for your
channel that you'll be using you can
specify the basic info of your channel
yeah you can have the country of
residence in my case we can set that on
the United
Kingdom yep and it can add keywords
which is digital
marketing
yeah and I can say
social media and I can say
YouTube Etc yep there is upload defaults
so for every video that you upload you
can specify a standard element in the
title standard element in the
description visibility you can specify
and public private or unlisted so P
unlisted means it will not show in the
go in the YouTube search result
there is advanced settings that you can
say you can also in your video specify
chapters and you can spend those
chapters will then be sort of summarized
in the description of your video and
that will be noted in the timeline of
your video as well so it's really good
to structure your
videos there's permissions yeah and this
is where you can invite other people to
make changes or to edit your Channel
there is your community that's where you
can set moderation guidelines and then
there are agreements yeah there's the
subject to the the terms of service okay
so those are your settings so very
important that you understand this menu
right so our channel is ready however we
haven't got any video in our Channel yet
so let's go and add a video so here to
add a video
we click
plus okay and we're going to upload the
video or we can also go live yeah so
that's why we're going to do a live
broadcast or a live stream so upload a
video and here I'm going to Dr drag and
drop a video or I can select the file
and here is my about us short
infographic yep so here is the about us
infographic that is the title of course
I can make that as a exciting as
possible here I can tell the uh short
introduction to our
company I can select a thumbnail of
course I have it hasn't selected a
thumbnail yet because it is still
uploading and optimizing the video yep
you can then say what playlist do you
wanted to be part of what audience yeah
there is an automatic CH kits fil filter
is it made for kids or is it not made
for kids so it's like a a business type
of theme yeah here is Page
promotion is that pay promotion in the
video do you want automatic chapters
allow automatic places you can add text
this is all about optimizing your video
and that is for a different video that
we will be talking about how to optimize
your YouTube videos okay and then it is
is going okay so that is all done we're
then clicking
next yeah I can say do I want subtitles
do I want to add an end screen do I want
to add cards remember you see that on
videos where at the end of the video you
see two cards where you can click on uh
to go to another video again I'm not
going to do that for this video and I'm
going to click next yeah there is some
copyright checks on music and then we
click next and here here is the video I
can then save and publish I want it to
be public I can schedule the
publication yes so but this is all there
is to it and I'm going to click
publish so I have now published my video
I
can share it straight away on social
media again we're not going to do that
are just going to click close And now I
see my video in my content list yeah I
see a thumbnail I see the title I can
see the different details and if I now
go back to my
channel I can see my video in my channel
but you see here I have just put it as
an upload because I haven't added any
playlist yet yeah so I need to go here
to my customize my channel and I'm going
to click first I'm going to add the
channel tra triler and the video I want
to add to this is my about us
infographic and people that subscribed
I'm going to give them the same video I
am now going to add a playlist so here
are my playlists oh I first need
to publish
this yeah there we go I'm now going to
go to my playlists and I'm going to
create a new playlist
and that is sort of
info Graphics or let's say video
graphics all right and I'm going to
create my
playlist okay so now I'm going back to
my uh content and I'm now going to say
go to edit this
video yeah let's see if the playlists
are
here yeah go to the details thumbnail so
here I now in the video details I'm
going to my playlist and I'm going to
select the video graphics playlist done
and I'm going to click
save so now you see if I go back to my
channel yeah so I'm back to my channel
that my channel now looks slightly
different
yeah I have my presentation my featured
videos okay and I have my
playlists and I have my
uploads yep so this is how you can build
your channel how you can optimize your
channel add videos to your channel um
add playlist to your channel so I hope
that was a um was a simple uh yet
effective overview for you how to set up
your channel
so that is it on the channel so let's
finish today's video with giving you
some tips on how to promote your YouTube
channel it is very important that you
promote your channel for the simple
reason you want to get
subscribers yep remember your YouTube
channel is your so your YouTube social
media Network it is where you can
develop your brand it is where you can
get people excited it is where you can
build
relationships with people who watch your
videos so it's very important that you
do everything that's possible to promote
your uh your YouTube channel so how do
you go about promoting it first of all
very important in video marketing is the
title of your video yeah you see here
the about us infographics you see that
is the title of this video is pretty
boring if you look at most titles of
videos on YouTube yeah let's say let's
say if I search on YouTube for let's say
social media you immediately see the
titles that are powerful how social
media rewires your brain is social media
hurting your mental health yeah uh like
selfies and self-promotion the hidden
dangers of social media five crazy ways
social media is changing your brain
right away yeah here a bit more neutral
but still powerful how to develop a
social media strategy step by step the
these are the type of things that people
like to uh to watch because those titles
are very
engaging yeah hand inand with the title
is also the thumbnail that you're using
for your
videos yeah so here you see a good
example 365 days of journaling that's
the thumbnail that they uh they use yeah
if you go to social media examiner you
see good examples of thumbnails
yeah and they are all they have the same
color style they have the same bold text
bold titles they still show people yeah
so these are very
powerful thumbnails for your video and
look at yourself if you're doing a
search on YouTube yeah what videos will
you most likely watch videos where you
like the title and videos where you like
the thumbnail when they spring out when
they scream out of the search
results okay so very important that you
um that you look at that okay next thing
how do you optimize your channel is by
making sure that your videos are
optimized yes so if I go to my videos
your videos and then here you have your
video and I go to edit the
details I can edit the title the
description remember keywords I can edit
the thumbnail I can edit tags yeah I can
edit um language lots of stuff that you
can optimize about your videos another
important factor is make videos that
that your audience wants to
see understand your audience yeah in
digital marketing terms we um advise our
clients to make customer
personas and customer personas you
specify their pains their needs and
everything that is important for them
when they buy your your product yeah so
by understanding what you're a
wants you then can tailor the content of
your videos to their
requirements the next important aspect
of your YouTube uh channel is engaging
with the community yes it's very
important that when people start adding
comments in your videos that you engage
with
them yeah that is one place where you
sort of build your uh your community you
engage with people but you also engage
with YouTubers in your Market associated
with your Market yeah comment on other
people's videos so start engaging with
other content creators in building your
online YouTube reputation as it were and
start sharing your videos yeah with them
so that is it important one another
important aspect of your uh channel is
that you need to cross promote your own
videos within your videos yeah so it's
very common if I go to Simply learn yeah
I go to their Channel and I'm sure they
have it on one of the videos if I go to
let's say here um data
analytics yeah so it's a long course but
if I go to the end of the video I'm sure
you see that here at the
end yeah so you see here at the end the
next video that they promote so you
cross promote your other videos within
your video that you're showing it's a
very powerful aspect of um the uh
growing your YouTube channel cross
promoting your video
yeah another one is very powerful is
what we call video
series yeah they
are very good in driving traffic to your
channel yeah why because people want to
if they like it they will come back for
the second episode or if they jump in
for instance for the first time in the
fourth episode if they see the episode
if they like the episode episod and they
say hey I want to watch episode one 2
and three as well so very important is
to create series of videos a good
example is social media
examiner yeah when you go to the social
media examiner YouTube page and you go
to the playlists here you see the
journey and the journey is a uh
basically a series of videos of the
history of the company yeah so you see
episode one episode 2 episode 3 yeah
they even have multiple Seasons yeah of
this and this was very successful in uh
their their marketing promotion yeah so
create YouTube
series okay so back to my channel
another way of promoting your channel
and promoting your videos is to make
sure that your videos are outside
YouTube as well so if I click on the
video yeah and I click share instead of
just sharing the code here yeah the the
URL I'm actually going to take the embed
code so the embed code gives you an
iframe which will actually show the
video on your website if you add this uh
iframe code to your web page yeah and
people will watch can watch the video on
your um your website but it will count
as a few on uh on YouTube yep and then
when people click on Youtube it'll take
them to your channel where they can um
where they can subscribe to your channel
yeah we talked about playlists very
important to promote your
channel yeah the playlists are important
and make sure you add calls to action to
your video at the end of the video get
people people to do something to buy
something or to sign up or to register
for an event going live always works in
promoting your channel yeah doing live
broadcast live behind the scenes or when
you're at an event do live broadcasts
really good way to promote your channel
you can promote the event you can
announce the event it will lead to buzz
before the broadcast during the
broadcast and after the broad
podcast yeah we talked about
collaboration with other creators with
other brands and then of course Very
powerful you can actually promote your
own ads by
advertising yeah so I can go to Google
ads I can create a video ad and at the
video ad is my short video and then that
video will show before and during um
videos that people watch yep and that
will drive views on your videos and
Views obviously will turn into
subscriptions to your channel as well
and then last but not least of course is
publishing your videos and your YouTube
content on social media channels as well
yeah Twitter of course is a very obvious
um place to promote your videos but uh
use it on um on other social channels as
well now Facebook doesn't necessarily
like it when you link to the YouTube
video because Facebook wants you to
upload the whole video yes so then
people will stay within YouTube within
Facebook to watch the video but there
are other social media channels where
you can promote your videos as
well okay well that concludes the
session on your YouTube
channels I hope you like this yeah so
remember a YouTube channel is your
social
media Network for your videos on Google
and on YouTube yep and it gives you a
fantastic tool to widen your reach to
reach a global audience and to start
building relationships with your uh
subscribers yep and help them in the
process of uh familiarizing themselves
with your products or your services
ultimately leading to them in buying
your product of your service YouTube
ideas for 2021 YouTube is the social
media platform that needs no
introduction launched back in the Year
2005 YouTube was a fresh breath of air
for the people who were slowly becoming
aware of the hype that surrounded the
internet several other platforms like
Daily Motion WME and VMO which
admittedly have their own fans have
tried to stand up against the Vamo that
is the YouTube and failed slowly but
surely marketers began to realize the
enormous potential that YouTube offered
they could add small advertisements like
they do in the cable TV they could show
banner ads and do much more and all of
the thanks to the robust advertisement
features that Google already offered if
you're not already sold on why it's
important to advertise on YouTube here
are some facts that might change your
mind Mind YouTube has more than 2
billion users across the world a good
fraction of that audience could be shown
your product and could turn from users
to customers next important fact is that
eight out of 10 marketers consider
YouTube to be one of the best platforms
to advertise their products and services
followed by that people watch one
billionair of YouTube per day as you
watch this video you are contributing to
that number next 62% of the business use
YouTube YouTube to post content this
could be just videos on their products
tutorials event announcements and much
more 70% of the YouTube watch time comes
from mobile this means that when you
create an advertisement for YouTube you
keep the mobile users in your mind and
finally 90% of the people say that
they've discovered new products or
brands on YouTube which means that by
posting on YouTube your brand awareness
is highly likely to increase now let's
talk about the video
ideas the first one is behindth scene
videos these videos give you the
opportunity to showcase your audience
how your business or brand operates a
creatively made video on the inner
workings of your business will show off
a more human side of your brand and make
you more relatable to your audience it
is also guaranteed to get you loads of
views and engagement here's an example
how Amazon showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like Amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall
process next we have the company culture
a video that highlights your company
culture will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does this
can help better connect with your
audience here's an example a company
culture video created by GoDaddy the
popular domain
register the video talks about how
GoDaddy creates a fun inclusive and
energetic environment for its employees
it includes interviews of employees
talking about why they enjoy working in
GoDaddy so much and this helps the
audience relate with the company and
could also catch up the interest with
some potential job Seekers next we have
the third idea that is the marketing
team a brand is nothing without the
people working behind it and that's
where these videos come in these videos
will help shine a light on the people
who create the products that the
audience knows and loves this helps
create a personal connection with the
audience these individuals can end up
becoming mascots for your brand here's
an example of Meet the team focusing on
Olympus group the video goes into the
history of masket makers brand and the
people that make it a grand success the
light-hearted tone of the video also
greatly helps with making it more
relatable now we have number four
product showcase or announcement a
product Showcase Video aims to show the
features and benefits of the Brand's
latest offering to its audience these
short concise videos can inform the
audience about everything they need to
know about the new product or service a
product announcement video on the other
hand can can be used to give the
audience a more detailed look into the
product or service than the product
showcase it can include comparisons to
older versions or competitors the aim of
such video is to show customers how the
new product works and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
Apple's iPhone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like next at number four five
we have event announcements these videos
can build a hype regarding an upcoming
event it will also give you the
opportunity to engage with your audience
and build their
interest this promo video for the data
Innovation Summit 2020 Hypes up the
event posting the greatest Minds in the
tech the most Innovative companies and
much more the next video idea we have at
number six is the explainer videos these
videos are aimed to tell users how a
particular product or a service works
these tend to be much more useful than
wallof text explaining how something
works they also have an added advantage
of simplifying complex Concepts and
features to your audience for example we
have our own video on digital marketing
we cover a number of different concepts
like SEO social media marketing search
engine marketing and more on a visual
manner making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer next at number
seven we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from these videos
aim to be guides to information complex
Concepts hints tips and tricks relating
to your industry here we have our own
digital marketing course video as an
example unlike the previous example I
mentioned this video goes into much more
detail regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing on that note if you
guys are interested in learning about
digital marketing I suggest you start
from this video it's a great one to get
started with now on the next video idea
at number eight we have the product
tutorial a product tutorial video will
take your audience through the various
features of your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product you can also explain the
best way the product can be used here's
a video of how the meditation app
headspace explains the apps usage with
an interesting and creative animated
video now let's go ahead with number
nine at the number nine we have the
webinar a webinar thanks to its nature
provides your brand with loads of
opportunities to interact with your
audience they are usually very
accessible and easy to make they are
also very cost-effective and can be
reused as video content after the
session is complete here's an example of
Simply learns webinar where we talk to
the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
Audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost here's an
example of a live stream that constantly
keeps a track of subscribers increasing
for some of the most popular YouTube
channels next at number 11 we have Ama
or ask me anything
sessions the AMA or ask me anything
sessions are usually live streams or
pre-recorded sessions that feature
questions collected from the audience
although it originated from Reddit these
videos are finding a success on YouTube
thanks to the interactivity that it
offers these sessions can also give your
audience the opportunity to interact
with you provide suggestions feedback
and much more here's an example of AMA
session with the actor Matt Damon where
questions covering a wide variety of
topics collected from Reddit were
answered by
him next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your Niche can go a
long way to grow your audience this
sessions are doubly advantageous to
firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry style word and since this video
can be shared on your channel as well as
theirs you can expose your channel to a
brand new audience here's an example of
an interview between Marcus brownley a
popular Tech YouTuber with Bill Gates
the interview covers a wide variety of
topics and maintains a pleasant theme
throughout let's now go to number 13
testimonials a testimonial video help
highlight the positive feedback from a
client or a customer they provide social
proof and provide a unique perspective
on your products and services these
videos can greatly help improve people's
trust on your brand sharability and
credibility here's an example of Simply
learns testimonial video that covers a
learner's Journey as he grew in his
career thanks to Simply learn
certification a video like this can be
greatly relatable to the audience and
even encourage some of them to take up a
certification let's go to our next video
idea that is the number 14 whiteboard
videos a whiteboard video offers you a
visually attractive way of explaining
complex Concepts usually this involves a
trained experts breaking through a
complex topic on a whiteboard nowadays
there has also been the trend of digital
whiteboard videos that work thanks to
the visual style and Charisma of the
narrator here is an example of the
Whiteboard video Simply learn created
covering various concepts of social
media marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end in an interesting
example for foldable flight Channel
users submitted their ideas for paper
airplanes that would go to the farthest
distance the channel received a
significant amount of submissions and
saw considerable growth next we have 16
the lists list videos are some of the
most commonly found content on YouTube
most users enjoy this type of content
thanks to it being small easily
digestable and
bite-sized these videos can cover a wide
range of topics like options to choose
from the best products techniques and
much
more the main advantage of these videos
are the provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here's an example of a list that we have
created on the top 10 skills you need to
become a data analyst in the year 2021
if you're interested don't forget to
check it out at number 17 we have case
studies case studies talk about how your
product or service have benefited
clients and users videos like this can
greatly improve relatability and making
your brand seem more likable here's a
video that analyzes Coca-Cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
Tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being opened for the
first time while these are fairly common
for technology these videos have also
found success in fashion apparel these
videos enable the users to experience
the products for the first time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products here's an example
of PS5 being unboxed by Marcus brownley
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers and
other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews with tech reviews you
can talk about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you didn't its price and other
practical information and much more here
we have an example of OnePlus 8 Pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or TV episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
Engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable here's an
example of a reaction video involving
teenagers reacting to the latest Tik Tok
videos these videos usually enable a
large amount of likes comments and
keyword research so basically what we
want to do is Center our keywords just
like our website we want to Center our
keywords around or our content around
good keywords so the videos on YouTube
are no different than the web pages on
our website so if we have somebody who
states YouTube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind Google it's
not a search engine per se it's a video
platform but if it was a search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
Google so YouTube is pretty popular
majority people use YouTube search every
day to watch videos on a number of
different topics so they can find these
videos in Google but because YouTube's
so powerful and so popular people go
directly right into YouTube for their
searches and so the whole idea behind
YouTube being the second most well-known
search engine is centered around
keywords so if you have the right
keywords for for your video then the
chances of you ranking higher increases
on YouTube so we're going to share with
you a few easy ways to do keyword
research this is the most important step
in getting your videos to rank on
YouTube just like for those of you who
watched any of the SEO videos we
produced at at simply learn you know
that keyword research is so essential to
getting your web pages to rank on Google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important for your videos as is for
your web pages so we're going to go into
a few things to do here to find the
right keywords so we have the search
suggestion you can look at your
competitors we have different tools we
can use some other factors involved and
Google itself so let's start talking
about some of these ways to really hone
in and do some good research on your
keywords to align them with your videos
so first thing is search suggest so
YouTube has a feature called
autocomplete so if you've done any
searches on Google it's very similar if
you're typing something into YouTube
search then YouTube is going to suggest
other related popular keywords so let's
take a look at that if we go back to
YouTube for a second and I just type in
machine learning YouTube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other popular keywords
that we can potentially use or in this
case if I Choose You Know machine
learning tutorial I'm going to see a
video about machine learning tutorial so
here you can see simply learns rank
number one for machine learning tutorial
but there are other videos that show up
in my search results so we want to be
able to use the search suggestion box in
the search box field so when we're
typing in something you know YouTube
just like on Google is going to give us
those suggestions so if we're focusing
uh a video on machine learning then you
know we have some ideas of some other
keywords that we could center around
because these are our popular keywords
these are keywords that people are using
to search on YouTube so that's one
suggestion looking at competitors is
another suggestion so we could search
for keywords used by our competitors in
their video title and description so let
me talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to that
particular channel of your competitor so
when you go to your particular
competitor's YouTube channel you want be
able to click on the videos tab when you
click on the videos tab then you're
going to sort by most popular and then
what you could do is see a list of
videos and then when you look at a list
of videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords used in the
title and description and then once you
do that you're going to have a list of
keywords that you can use yourself for
that video so for example let's go back
to YouTube so if I go to type in simply
learn here's her Channel page just by
clicking on simply learn I click on
videos ever wonder if there's so now I
can see all the videos wonder if there's
an easier way go back so here I can see
all the videos sort by most popular once
they do that then I can choose a video
this is the most popular video right now
for simply learn if I click on that
video it's automatically going to start
playing but what I could do is simply
just look at you know the content
description so just by clicking show
more I can see all the content that
align with this video that's one way to
do it is simply by looking at your
competitors now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video and so what you want to
do is you want to look at the HTML and
so that means looking at the page source
so just like web pages what YouTube does
is they look at metatags so if you're
call from SEO in order to get your pages
to rank you need to have a title tag and
a metat tag description so videos are no
different what we're doing uh for
YouTube is aligning certain keywords
with the video so if you take a look and
do a search for keywords by viewing the
page Source you're going to see all the
keywords associated with a particular
video so for example if I go back to
YouTube and I look at the page source of
a video Let's just say this video here
Facebook's ad tutorial I'm going to pull
up the page source all I need to do isrl
F and type in keywords and now for that
Facebook video I can see all the
keywords associated with the video so
you can see there's a lot of different
keywords we're aligning with this video
and so why do we want to do that because
we want you know our video to show up
for keywords that people may type in and
so if we use that YouTube autocomplete
it's going to give you those ideas there
most popular keywords so if they're
related align those keywords with the
video so here you can see Facebook
marketing Facebook ad strategy Facebook
ads for beginners so forth and so on so
there's a lot of key words we've aligned
here with that particular video and
again all you need to do is look at the
page source so right clicking view page
Source do a contrl f for keywords and
you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you could do that for your
competitors videos as well so you could
see what keywords your competitor is
using for a video that's most popular
for their Channel and is also ranking on
YouTube and on Google so using the
autocomplete gives you those keyword
ideas looking at your competitor's
videos also gives you some other ideas
for keywords that you can align with a
video that's relevant that you want to
rank for so let's look at uh some other
ideas here so you can install plugins
and there are plenty of plugins
available on the Chrome browser that
will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video so a
couple of examples are vid IQ and tuddy
those are extensions that work in Chrome
and what they do is they give you the
exact tags that a particular video is
using so for example if I go back here
and I look at a video on YouTube let's
just say the machine learning Basics
video I have vid IQ installed on my
Chrome browser so just by clicking on
that vid IQ is going to give me a lot of
information about that video they're
just going to give me an overview of
their particular metrics they're going
to give me some other information
associated with Facebook some engagement
metrics really what I'm interested in is
those keywords so if I scroll down a bit
here I can see the video tags associated
with the machine learning Basics video
so vid IQ is telling me is these
keywords are associated with this video
and not only does it show me what
keywords are associated I can also see
where they rank so for machine learning
Basics this particular video ranks
number one if I go down I can see what
is machine learning and how does it work
I can see it's rank number two here I
can see machine learning algorithms it's
rank number nine so I can get some ideas
of the types of keywords that are being
used as tags for that video further down
I can also see some Channel tags but
really this is the video tags or the
idea place I want to be able to look to
get an idea of the types of keywords
that are associated with the video that
are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way for you to really get
an understanding of what key words to
use at the particular video so
autocomplete you can look at the page
source of a competitor's video or you
can use a Chrome extension in this case
I'm using vid IQ to give me some
information about the video tags for
particular video so according to an
industry study using keyword words and
video tags will help you rank well on
YouTube so you have to use keywords and
video tags if you want your video to
rank there's been a lot of studies
YouTube is so popular and videos are so
prominent in today's world where if you
have videos and you're going to upload
them to YouTube then associate the right
keywords with those videos so some
important factors when we look at
keywords what we want to do is look at
search volume we want to look at
competition we want to look at relevancy
we want to look at the primary and
secondary keywords that we want to use
so well chosen keywords will help you
rank so we just gave you some ideas on
how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were really to use the
autocomplete on YouTube or Google
they're going to give you some popular
keywords you can look what your
competitors are doing by looking at the
page source and just looking at the
keywords that are aligned with that
video or you can use a third party
extension in Chrome in my example I use
vid IQ that gave me the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords so what we want
to do is we want to make sure we choose
keywords with high search volume they're
going to drive more traffic to your
video however we want to balance it out
with keywords that have low difficulty
and are easier to rank for so you don't
want to choose something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy so if we're talking
about machine learning Basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because what Google's
going to do and YouTube's going to do is
give us keywords that are very closely
related to the video that we're trying
to optimize for and so we have a number
of different keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have good volume and low
competition and so the whole idea is we
want to choose a keyword that that
defines the nature of the content and
then what we want to do is support that
with secondary keywords so we want
keywords that are highly relevant to the
primary keyword so that's the way to go
about aligning your keywords you want
keywords that are high volume low
competition or relevant and you want to
choose that one keyword that is really
what the content's about and then those
secondary keywords that support the
primary so if you have a machine
learning video you could choose your
primary keyword word as in this case the
machine learning Basics video so well
chosen keywords help you rank well on
YouTube just like the machine learning
Basics so if I go back to our video our
machine learning Basics video if I just
type in machine learning Basics I'll be
able to pull it up and so here it is if
I click on it I'm going to go to YouTube
and so here I can see this keyword we
know humans learn from their is well
aligned because it's in the title it's
in the copy and it's aligned as a a
keyword tagged with the video so we know
that that keyword has good volume low
competition is relevant because that's
what the video is about the basics of
machine learning it's an introduction to
machine learning so instead of honing in
on just introduction to machine learning
primary keyword is machine learning
Basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords what is
machine learning because somebody who
doesn't know machine learning is
probably going to type in that keyword
and then introduction to machine
learning is a good secondary keyword
because it's explaining the basics of
what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning so that's the whole idea behind
choosing keywords you want that keyword
that really is going to define the
content and then support that with those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
Google shows on the video where results
page so what I mean by that is your
video can get more views if you rank on
Google as well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on YouTube it's
also to be found on Google so if I go
back to Google and I just type in data
science for beginners and I type in
videos then you could see we're ranked
number one so even if you're not looking
at the videos clicking on the videos
link on Google search you can always
just when you do a search what Google's
going to do is also put in the video
here on part as part of the search
results so what they're going to show
you is the top videos that are ranking
for that particular keyword and so we
may not rank overall for data science
for beginners but we're ranked number
one in the videos category and so if
somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads so what Google
is doing is they're saying hey this is
so relevant this particular video for
the keyword query data science for
beginners that we're going to show it
above the organic listings even though
it's a video so the whole idea is to be
found on YouTube and Google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both search platforms so according to
back Linko Google Ranks videos with
keywords like how to tutorials so you
know a lot of the videos that you find
on YouTube are going to be instructional
based and so what Google's doing is
they're saying hey if somebody types in
how to or tutorial or an introduction to
anything that's going to signal to
Google that it's instructional it's
going to help you rank so when you
search for machine learning tutorial or
how to become a machine learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples we have machine learning
tutorial in our title or how to become a
machine learning engineer so keep that
in mind if you're creating a video and
it's educational in nature you know use
those key terms like how to and
tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video title so we want to
use our Target keyword in the title of
the video and again we want to make sure
if it's educational to include that
keyword tutorial or how to so for every
video title YouTube has a limit of 100
characters so we really have to pick and
choose really wisely so if we look at
the video that we were focusing on a
couple of minutes ago so machine
learning Basics here we could see under
100 characters we have machine learning
Basics what is machine learning
introduction to machine learning and
then the brand name so that is the title
of this particular video so it takes
into account the primary keyword the
secondary keywords in the title and it
also includes that really that key term
that really Google Google and YouTube
like and that's what is machine learning
so it's helping us Rank by having our
keywords in the title with that key
phrase what is okay so that's a a good
tidbit on creating a good video title is
to align it with the right keywords your
primary and your secondary and so we
want to use those catchy words and
numbers to gain High clickthrough R just
like you would on the title tag of your
web page we want to do the same with our
video title because the video titles
what's going to show up in search so if
I go back to you know search here we
could see you know data science tutorial
data science for beginners so we want to
make sure in this case you can see data
science in 5 minutes so that was
purposely done so that hey I don't have
time to watch a video I only have a
couple minutes data science in 5 minutes
okay great I'm going to click on the
video and now I have an opportunity to
watch something and learn something
under 5 minutes so choosing the write
words in your video title is going to
help you get that click theough rate up
remember clickthrough rate is clicks
divided by Impressions and an impression
is how many times your video shows up in
the search results on YouTube or Google
so we want to keep our click the rate
high and in order to do that we want to
be able to write some really good title
tags for our video so use catchy words
like a number or how to or what is cuz
that's going to resonate with people
when they're searching now for the
description what we want to do is we
want to use the target word at the
beginning of the description the title
and the tags itself so if I go back to
my video here machine learning Basics we
know it's in the video title and right
off the bat if I look at the description
of the video here I can see this machine
learning Basics video will help you
understand what is machine learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description and so that's going to
bode well for optimizing our video the
description length is 5,000 characters
so we have a lot of characters to work
with so if I go back to my video I click
show more we have a lot of characters to
really describe what the video is about
okay there's no shortage no shortage of
including keywords into the content so
you have 5,000 characters go ahead and
see if you can work in naturally your
keyword but one of the key tips here is
just make sure that first sentence
starts out with that keyword that's a
good tip of course you always want to
make it sound natural as possible you
don't want to stuff it with keywords at
the same time work them in naturally
work in your keywords naturally and then
include hashtags in your description to
help the audience find your video is
easily so if I go back here you know we
want to be able to include hashtags so
hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media it just
signals to the end user hey this is what
the video is all about and if I go ahead
and type in that keyword then it's our
video has a better chance cuz it's
aligned with that hashtag and then
there's Target keywords and LSI keywords
latent semantic indexing keywords we
want to be able to use those keywords as
Target keywords with our video so if you
recall the example I gave a few minutes
ago we used the Facebook ads tutorial as
our example here I can see all the
target keywords associated with that
particular video so don't be afraid to
use those LSI related keywords meaning
keywords that are related to the content
use them as Target keywords with the
video so between your LSI keywords
Target keywords and then using our
primary and secondary keyword in the
title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword in the description and
then using hashtag TS in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword then we should
find that our video will eventually rank
on YouTube so just doing these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank so at the end of
the day we want to be able to use the
tools available to Us YouTube Itself by
looking at our competitors those
extensions like vid IQ the auto complete
to really find our good keywords and
then incorporating those keywords into
you know the title tag the description
as Target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on YouTube on that note if you are
looking to learn social media marketing
and become a digital marketing expert
then look no further than the simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing don't miss out on this
opportunity Find The Cost Link in the
description box for more information if
you try to figure out what those seven
are you might come up with a list but
let me share it with you because it's
the outline for this short course um
first thing is you've got to make
YouTube a key part of your social media
marketing strategy I know it probably is
it may be but we're going to tell you
where it fits and why it probably isn't
getting the kind of resources that it
deserves in this uh first part we're
also going to talk about how you can
create the type of video content that
your target audience uh will want to
watch
and uh we're also going to talk about
scheduling your videos and optimizing
your content and then in the next module
we'll get to the rest of uh top seven
strategies so let's begin with uh the
first thing that you really got to get
your arms around it turns out according
to recent research YouTube is the
largest video sharing site I'm sure that
didn't shock you you knew that part but
it's also the largest social media site
in the United States
and that may surprise you in other words
YouTube has slightly more unique
visitors a month in the US than
Facebook and I can't tell you how many
people who have a social media marketing
strategy say oh yeah yeah f Facebook
Twitter uh LinkedIn right need to have
LinkedIn all of those are social media
those are things that you should have
programs around but excuse me YouTube is
too big to be ignoring oh by the way
there's some other people say yeah yeah
but what about Vimeo well Vimeo is on
the list of the top 10 but it's in 10th
place so yeah let's start with YouTube
in this particular course if we have
time to get through the um other nine
underneath it God bless you good luck
but you know what we're going to focus
on YouTube now one of the things that
marketers have been complaining about
lately is that Facebook has been taking
away some of the features that made it
such a wonderful place place to do
marketing on it's a little harder now
things are changing things aren't
working the way they used
to
even industry
analysts at Forester have said you know
what it's time to tell it like it is
Facebook seems more interested in your
ad dollars and less interested in you
actually using it as a marketing
platform meanwhile at the same time
YouTube has been going through some
Transformations and in order to be a
little more more brand friendly one of
the things that they've done um lately
is they've cleaned up the comments area
underneath videos and now they'll do
some Auto searching for well let's just
put it this way hate words uh trolls
there's a lot of things now that you can
do to uh moderate the comments
underneath your YouTube video that
actually makes it a more interesting
social media to engage your prospects
and clients with so I think if you knet
all this out what it means is is that
yeah YouTube needs to be a key part of
your social media marketing strategy and
even if you don't make it like number
one on the list which frankly I think it
probably should be it still needs to be
right up there uh it's not an after
thought it's not something that you
should get to when you have the spare
time it ought to be a priority and that
means if you've delayed getting your
arms around this thing or well we
created a YouTube channel and we
uploaded a few 30 second uh ad spots and
nothing magical happened it's like yeah
yeah yeah that's why you're here in the
short course let me tell you what you do
next one of the things that you need to
understand is what are people actually
watching and it turns out repurposed 302
television ads ranks really low on the
list
and if that's all you're putting on your
YouTube channel check out what actually
is being watched more often than not
it's um everything from product teasers
to howto videos in other words there's
ways to use YouTube for marketing
purposes Way Beyond a repurpose 302 spot
this is also true with B2B YouTube is a
wonderful B2B marketing platform in fact
this is a case study of a company
called
sonosite they're in the medical products
industry they sell to hospitals so it is
a B2B sell and they sell several
hundred, worth of portable ultrasound
equipment and they used YouTube quite
effectively to surprise surprise shorten
the sales
cycle and in a B2B sale that's money in
the bank how did they shorten it well
there's always a committee that makes
these kinds of decisions and not
everybody on the committee get to meet
with the sales rep and so not everybody
in the committee is fully up to the
speed with the features and benefits of
the product but if there's Video
available of how the product works all
of a sudden a whole lot of those
questions that may slow up the sales
process get answered and sales get
completed in fact they were able to grow
their revenue 12% year-over-year
by basically using video to shorten the
sales
cycle so you want to be able to create
the kind of video content that your
Target customers watch the most and
trust me it is not hard to get corporate
approval to create how-to videos we're
not talking about you got to convince
them to do more funny cats I mean that's
not what you want to work what you want
to use uh to Market your products unless
you're selling cat food of course but
guess what you can create uh a range of
video content that will engage your
process ects will move them along um you
know the purchase process and at the end
of the day uh can be a key part of both
your social media marketing campaign and
frankly your content marketing campaign
it it's uh pretty useful
stuff now here's the bad news this is
another reason why people who've tried
to dabble on YouTube haven't seen much
success and then came to the premature
conclusion that well this just doesn't
work for us the answer is they
dabbled meanwhile a whole lot of other
people who've been incredibly successful
on
YouTube are uploading content if not
daily then at least several times a
week and this includes brands that you
know frankly are doing very very well as
well as some of the YouTube Stars which
frankly all of us should watch because
we can learn a lot of interesting
lessons from people people who you know
have built their own franchise on
YouTube so you know surprise surprise
you need to start thinking about how the
heck do we go about creating more
content I mean that's going to take
effort well of course it does well it
helps to have a plan and it helps to
understand that you can have more than
one type of video one type of video that
um YouTube calls hygiene content to
define the in sort of terms that I think
most of us marketers would understand
and might want to reuse around the
boardroom table we can do our keyword
research discover which questions people
are asking on YouTube and then create
videos that answer those
questions one of the people who does
this incredibly well is Matt cuts at
Google you know every one of the videos
that he is uploading on almost a weekly
basis is uh Matt you know uh I just got
this question from um a guy named Matt
and uh let me answer it well sometimes
Matt writes questions to himself so it
must have been a slow week but the point
is it is compelling viewing I mean those
of us in the industry who are trying to
keep up with the latest wrinkles at
Google or watching math videos every
week so that's one type of content you
can also create a web series where if
it's Monday then we're going to feature
yet another one of our wonderful
customers talking about how they're
using our product in their industry ORS
business and then occasionally you can
create something really special and the
people who sort of taught me this trick
are over at the discovery digital
networks and I don't know if you've
heard of it but there's something called
Shark
Week and who invented Shark Week the
people at the Discovery Channel and when
does it happen some week in August and
what does it feature a whole lot of
video about
sharks and who declared the Shark Week
well they did they made it up you can
make stuff up too so whether you're
doing Q&A whether you're doing uh
ongoing series whether you're doing
something special once a year guess what
you can build out a programming schedule
just the way those big honchos up at NBC
ABC and CBS do for every fall you can do
it for your annual YouTube
channel so key to being successful key
to being effective
develop a programming strategy and then
plot out your content because you know
what it's a heck of a lot easier to
create more content if you're not trying
to pull a rabbit out of your hat every
other week uh it it helps if you have a
plan because then suddenly you can shoot
half a dozen episodes on the same day
you just happen to upload them over the
next six weeks uh that's a way to keep
your budget uh sort of in line and your
production capabilities don't have to
grow beyond what you can afford and yet
you know you now have a heck of a lot
more content that you can play out over
the course of a
year you'd also want to optimize your
videos so they can get found in search
right right but let me share with you
the first rookie mistake that most
people make when it comes to optimizing
a
video they use Google Keyword tools to
try to figure out what terms to put on
their YouTube
videos and pardon me when people use
Google to do a search believe it or not
they use different Search terms or in
some cases they may use the same term
but in different volumes than when
they're on YouTube and let me just share
this quick example with you it turns out
that Google Trends now not only gives
you what the Google interest is in a
particular term you know they've had
that since day one but uh you know in
the last year they've also added a drop-
down menu option to say oh I want to see
YouTube search Trends so you can use the
same tool to see both and this example
here shows the terms
Chevrolet and
Chevy and in Google it's a horse race
it's about 50/50 you know even Stephen
you could pick either term what the heck
in YouTube it's no contest Chevy has
almost twice as many searches on YouTube
as
Chevrolet and so this is just a quick
illustration that when you want to do
your video research you want to use
video research
tools then of course you want to
optimize your video and there's uh more
to it than just putting the right
keywords in the right places that used
to work and it used to be sufficient
that's what YouTube calls metadata so
you want to put those keywords in your
titles and your descriptions in your
tags okay got it YouTube changed its
algorithm to include something called
watch time in other words if people
start to watch your video and go H
boring or oh corporate
propaganda and they stop watching you
don't have very much watch time and
guess what your video doesn't rank very
well so you know surprise surprise
surprise you're going to have to create
some pretty compelling video content or
some pretty interesting video content or
some how-to videos where nobody in their
right mind is going to bail out halfway
through and only know how to complete
half of the project in order to get your
watch time up and then last but not
least you certainly want to make sure
that your video is distributed in lots
of places why because the YouTube player
is sort of interesting in that if it's
embedded in a blog for for example and
somebody watches the video by clicking
it and watching it while on the blog and
they never come to YouTube to watch the
video that view still counts and if they
watch it all the way to completion guess
what that counts in the algorithm back
over on YouTube in the watchtime
part and so yeah find ways of not just
Distributing your video but Distributing
your video in places where it is likely
to be viewed and watched by relevant
audiences hopefully all the way through
to the end and that can be blogs that
can be your own website frankly it can
be your Facebook page it can be your
Twitter account it can be your LinkedIn
account it can be your Pinterest account
you know what you can share YouTube
videos to all of those and you
should so you want to be found you want
to be discovered you're going to have to
optimize your videos and your playlists
and your
channel in order to reach and keep your
audience why all of those because if you
do a search in YouTube You'll discover
that videos playlists and channels all
come up in the YouTube search results
and let's not forget YouTube is the
world's second largest search engine
there are more searches done on YouTube
a month than are conducted on bang the
only thing that's behind is Google
itself so again optimize your videos
optimize your playlist optimize your
channel and help your videos get
discovered hello again and welcome to
part two of the YouTube and mobile video
short course in part one we covered four
of the top seven things that you need to
focus on so let's start with part
five most of us started off in the era
where if you optimized your video you
could get sufficient traffic to actually
help it get discovered these days
there's more than a 100 hours of new
YouTube video content uploaded every
minute and unfortunately the downside is
that makes it even harder for your video
to get found in organic
search so I know I'm going to sound like
I'm straying over into the dark side
this is not the dark side this is still
a white tactic but one of the things
that you may need to consider is when to
jumpstart your campaign by using paid
media so here's some of the things that
you have to understand to understand why
that's a wh hat tactic and by the way
it's a wh hat tactic even YouTube
approves it of
this one of the things that you need to
know is that when you create an ad in
YouTube one of your options is not to
upload a brand new video but to take an
existing
video and promote it in other words
existing content can quote be turned
into an
ad and what that means is you can take
the new video that you've just uploaded
it and you can sort of do double duty
you've just optimized it and hopefully
it'll get found for a couple of the
Search terms that you focused it
on but then you can use YouTube
advertising which is called true view
that's the name of their uh what Google
calls AdWords for
video and what you can do with this true
viw ad is take that basically existing
content turn it into an ad and then have
it
displayed over not two or three Search
terms which is about what you can
optimize it for organically
but you can actually advertise it
against hundreds perhaps even thousands
of relevant Search terms and what this
means is is that your video content your
video surfaces when someone does a
search on YouTube and if they click on
it well that's then when it's an ad and
it uh and you pay for it so you know
other than the sort of the crossover of
where the content came from you okay got
it it's like AdWords it's an auction
based system you know get it okay
whatever but here's one of the things
that happens and this is part of the
mystery of
YouTube for every two clicks that you
get that you're paying for somebody's
going to watch that video and say wow
I'm going to share that with a friend of
mine and then their friend watches it
and when they share the video and the
friend watches it that's not an
ad because it's your same content and
that means you don't have to pay for it
so one of the things that YouTube has
found by examining over
6,000 recent
campaigns is that on average for every
two paid clicks that the paid
Advertiser uh is paying for they're on
average getting one free
click again this helps jump start your
traffic it helps people uh discover your
video and oh by the way the bonuses you
get people to start sharing your content
if it's compelling if if it's
informative if it's something we're
sharing you can get organic views on top
of the paid views you can't do that with
regular AdWords and Google trust me but
you can do it with
YouTube so how do you succeed with true
view ads it's a little different because
in addition to being like the auction
based system in addition to being uh
AdWords for video you have a couple
other options as well one of them is you
can run that ad as a pre-roll in other
words before let's say somebody wants to
watch a very popular music video before
that video starts your quote ad which
again can be regular content that you've
promoted will appear before the video
that they wanted to watch as a pre-roll
ad or what uh YouTube calls a true view
um in stream
format and about 5 seconds each into
your video playing your ad
starting YouTube does something pretty
amazing that they pioneered and really
blew me away the first time I saw it
they put a little skip ad button at the
bottom of the video which means if the
viewer sees this as an intrusion I'm
sorry I wanted to go watch the music
video I don't want to watch this ad they
can click that skip it button and go
straight to the video and here's the
interesting thing for you as a marketer
if they skip your
content you pay
nothing in fact they have to watch more
than 30 seconds of it before basically
the meter starts running and you then
pay per
click wow so again you're not only
getting organic views you know one for
every two that you pay for but you also
are getting people let's think about
this for a second the only ones who I
have to pay for the ones who are
interested in watching more than 30
seconds of
it you know frankly that's pretty
revolutionary so again if you have not
checked out true view ads you you really
want to they can do some things for you
that uh frankly we haven't seen in any
other kind of AD format out there from
anybody
else so again the net net of this part
you can leverage paid video to put your
organic content in front of the Right
audience that's not something you might
think of doing because it's not a tactic
that you can borrow from somewhere else
it is unique to YouTube just as true
view is unique to YouTube just as um a
whole lot of the other tactics that
we're going to go through in other words
this is a big opportunity and it's one
that you want to get your arms around
even if it's a little
different now uh another tactic that
you're going to want to use is uh you
want to make sure sure that your video
is sharable it helps if you've got
content that is sharable but even so one
of the things that sort of put YouTube
on the map in the first place the reason
why it is known as a vide sharing
site is because it has so many wonderful
options not only can you embed the video
on blogs or on
websites not only can you like email the
URL to people you know yeah yeah yeah
got it but you can also share it to
Facebook and Twitter and to uh Google+
and Pinterest and a whole bunch of other
social
medias and one of the things that you
need to understand is about oh 500 years
of YouTube video
content is watched every day on
Facebook and there are about 700 YouTube
videos tweeted on
Twitter every minute
so again you know it's not just about
YouTube in itself the YouTube audience
is distributed and that means your video
is going viral if it's actually pretty
interesting and all those extra views
count now understanding that that's what
it takes to be successful why aren't
more Brands successful in fact they're
pathetic and in some Industries uh they
account for single digit percentage of
views of all the view videos watch
watched in that genre or or or industry
at most in in let's say the electronics
Industry where they do the best brand
generated videos Barely reach you know
in the mid 20s in terms of the
percentage of content that people are
watching in that
category what happened well what
happened is most brands are in a set it
and forget it mode we put the video up
we're
done and most of the successful channels
particularly the vloggers who are trying
to make this their
living understand that it's also about
engaging your audience which means when
they post a comment you're still around
to
respond and you know the difference in
engagement is night and day and that's
one of the reasons why a whole lot of
the amateurs are doing a whole lot
better than a lot of the pros on YouTube
because the pros don't realize that
maybe hanging around for 15 minutes
after the video goes up is critical to
success
so the net net of this tactic you
absolutely want to amplify what your
video content says by socializing it
interacting with your prospects and you
can do it at
scale because if you're interacting with
the first people who respond to you in
the first 15 minutes everyone who comes
by later sees your response and they
know the lights are on there's somebody
here who cares it actually encourages
them to say hey there's a community I
can build it around this video that's
part of the secrets of the
success the other interesting thing
that's worth noting is that YouTube
gives you YouTube analytics now this
wasn't always the case there were no
such thing is even YouTube insided until
2008 analytics wasn't rolled out until
late
2011 but now what YouTube is giving you
for free with your YouTube channel is a
very robust set of analytics that go
frankly Beyond Google analytics one of
the things you will not find in Google
analytics that you will in YouTube
analytics is how people were watching
your video and when they stopped and if
you suddenly discover everyone's bailing
out 30 seconds in you got a problem
because a you're not getting very much
watch time and what was it that was
happening at that 30 second Mark that
everyone went G give me a break I'm out
of here so there's a lot of things to
learn from your YouTube analytics you
can learn not only did people watch it
views has been around and and people
have been paying attention to that
metric but it's one of many you know the
one I urge you to to look at is your
watch time and by the way which Search
terms were people using to find your
video and guess what YouTube still shows
that even if Google doesn't and the
other interesting things is you can find
out which videos people were watching uh
when they decided to subscribe to your
channel which videos triggered people to
share it to others on social media so
you can begin to find out where people
were interacting with you which videos
out of all the ones that you've uploaded
actually connected with the community
that's killer
data and why is it important because you
then need to bridge the next
Gap because most of your um executives
are going to say well that's nice people
watched your video and they shared it
and that's great but what they really
want to know is did they come to the
website and did they buy
anything and increasingly it's becoming
a little easier it's still not perfect
to sort of bridge that Gap you know in
some cases you can use cookies in other
cases you can use um you know uh links
that are called annotations to get you
from the video over to your
website but the other key is beginning
to use a multi-channel
funnels in Google analytics to begin
understanding not only where your
traffic came from and what they did next
but oh by the way when they came back to
your site Days Later weeks later and
begin doing something else in other
words we may be Upstream generating
people who come and discover our
companies or our brands or our products
early in the cycle and then come back
either having bookmark that page or
using organic search or come back in
some other fashion when they decide to
finally make the purchase so again
multi- Channel analytics will help you
bridge that
Gap and at the end of the day you know
you really want to put together the
right key performance indicators the
right kpis to make sure that you're
measuring the success of YouTube
strategy and that goes Way Beyond
measuring
views one of the most frequent questions
I get asked is well how long should a
YouTube video be
well the answer is how long does it take
you to tell a good
story in other words there's no right
time there's either good stories or
there's not so good stories and there
some of them are short and some of them
frankly are a little longer and
unfortunately too many marketers have
drawn the assumption that short is
required and they are making videos that
are 2 to three minutes long and figuring
well that's it right interestingly
enough new research uh from a company
called pixability says well there are a
group of people that will watch videos
that are 2 to 3 minutes long that's okay
but even more are watching videos that
are 3 to 10 minutes long in other words
if it takes you a little longer to show
people how to do
something take the time to tell them how
to do it and don't try to force it into
the three minute limit you know at the
end of the day they want to be able to
complete the job not to get an overview
of it so take the time to tell your
story we are going to talk about YouTube
SEO we'll be covering what it is what
you need to know how you can optimize
your videos to get found on YouTube and
how you can use it to maximize your
views but before we go into this let me
introduce myself I am Mark campman I am
your digital navigator for this video
and as usual if you like the video click
the like button and if you want to join
our YouTube channel click the Subscribe
button below so you become part of our
our wonderful YouTube uh learning
community on um on simply learns YouTube
channel so are you ready to start let's
get into some numbers here yeah let's
give you some interesting stats about
YouTube Before We Begin and I'm going to
show you that YouTube has to be part of
your digital marketing strategy Did You
Know YouTube is the second biggest
search engine only after Google there
are 98 different
language versions on YouTube making it a
global social network now it would take
a life time to watch all the YouTube
content that's uploaded in the last hour
only so it's amazing amount of content
that is being
uploaded we as the world's population we
watch about five billion videos every
day on YouTube did you also know that
YouTube advertising is very important to
you YouTube and to Google yeah they
generate more than $30 billion per year
in advertising revenue and on top of
that YouTube has around
2.5 billion monthly active users making
it the second biggest social media
Network in the world so do I need to
convince you any further that YouTube
has to be part of your digital marketing
strategy so let's talk about what you
can do to increase increase your chances
that your videos are going to feature in
the YouTube search results and in the
recommendations by YouTube let's check
about what we're going to talk about in
this video we will be giving you an
overview of what is YouTube ASO yeah how
do you optimize your videos for YouTube
um how does YouTube search work and how
does your YouTube search engine
optimization work I'm going to share
with you about 10 tips for optimizing
your video for search on YouTube and
then at the end I'm going to share with
you my favorite YouTube SEO tools I will
also show you in a demo where to find
all the tools that you can use within
YouTube and within some of those tools
to optimize your videos for
SEO so let's start with explaining what
is YouTube SEO as mentioned mentioned
earlier YouTube is the second most
popular search engine right after Google
in fact YouTube searches are actually
more in numbers than Microsoft Bing AOL
and ask.com combined so we're talking
about a very important part of your
search strategy YouTube as I mentioned
earlier has about 2.6 billion active
monthly users as of 2022 making it the
second biggest social media Network only
um proceeded by uh by Facebook yes so
now SE 62% of global consumers say they
use YouTube and since the creation of
YouTube its Mission has been to provide
fast and easy video access to users and
the ability to share videos frequently
and since then it has grown Beyond
expectations now with so many people
uploading videos on the one hand and
watching videos on the other hand how
you do you make sure that your video
features in the top of the YouTube
search results and that's where YouTube
SEO plays a vital
role so before I explain YouTube seo let
me give you a little bit of a history
about
YouTube late 2004 an idea for a website
for users to upload video dating
profiles was born and in February 2005
the website launched to a small subset
of users as I said earlier as a video
dating platform now based on feedback
from their subscribers in April 25 or in
April 2005 YouTube turned into a free
video H in platform where each clip had
a unique Link in April 2005 the first
video ever was uploaded on the website
by one of the uh the Youtube Founders
and in May 2005 YouTube launches its
better version to the public for the
first time and it became a massive hit
in a year later October 2006 Google
acquired YouTube for the not too small
amount of 1. 6 billion
US in 2007 YouTube allowed YouTube
creators people who upload videos to
earn money from their content based on
ad Revenue yeah turning their hobby into
a career and that of course gave a
tremendous push of people getting into
YouTube creating content for YouTube
where they could link it to advertising
where they could make a substantial
income now in no November 2008 YouTube
expans it ad offering to sponsored
videos and free pre-roll ads and in 2009
they launched a new music video service
called fivo in collaboration with Fendi
so it moved on in 2010 one of the most
famous YouTubers Felix kelberg joins
YouTube to create content under the
Channel's name
PDP and that is now one of the biggest
channels that you can find on YouTube in
April 2011 YouTube entered the broadcast
business launching YouTube live and in
August 2012 2012 it became the go-to
place for presidential elections by
launching the YouTube elections Hub it
grew exponentially and by 2013 re
YouTube had reached over a billion
monthly
users so other interesting facts in
January 2016 the music video for Adele's
hello was the fastest video on YouTube
ever to hit 1 billion views and a very
strategic move for YouTube was in
November 2018 when they rolled out a
stories like feature YouTube shorts yep
where they would sort of relate to
Snapchat and Instagram stories where
videos are automatically deleted after a
day in November 2019 YouTube announced
that the service would phase out the
classic version of YouTube Studio yep
and to all YouTube creators by Spring
2020 and I'll show you later what the
latest version of YouTube studio is all
about in July 2021 YouTube did a massive
cleanup of all unlisted videos prior to
2017 were set to be private making them
unplayable and in 2022 YouTube becomes
the second biggest social media Network
after Facebook so a whirlwind of a
development of a growth of an adoption
in the market it's being played and
being used all over the world and it is
the channel of choice for the younger
generation to watch TV and to watch
video so a spectacular development for a
fantastic channel so what is YouTube SEO
now YouTube SEO is a set of activities
that you need to do to enhance the
search rankings of your YouTube videos
and or your YouTube channel in other in
other words when a user does a query on
the YouTube search bar yeah which is
related to your videos what you do what
do you need to do to make sure that your
video features higher in the YouTube
search rankings or in the recommended
videos based on that search now many
businesses of today they see the power
of search for YouTube has showing up and
the importance of showing up higher in
the search results it helps them to
reach more people because more people
will click on the uh the video links it
helps them in building and promoting
their brand it helps them in creating
customer engagements more people will
like the videos more people will engage
with the video videos and it is a great
opportunity for Brands to Showcase their
expertise so it is a Nob brainer for
businesses to be on YouTube these days
and to put all the effort in place to
show up high in the search
rankings so as you know the engine of a
search engine is what we call the
algorithm so before we dive a bit deeper
into the YouTube SEO let's have a look
at this YouTube algorithm YouTube says
in their own documentation that the
algorithm is a feedback loop in real
time that recommends videos to
individual viewers according to their
different
interests now quality of the user
experience
wasn't that important at the initial
start of YouTube for the first seven
years YouTube rewarded video videos that
got the highest number of clicks or
views yes so all based on number of
clicks and number of views but soon
content creators started to abuse the
algorithm approach and tricked people
into getting more views because of
clickbait video titles or catchy
thumbnails so Google had to do something
about this and to tackle this misuse of
clicks and Views and improve the user
experience
they announced an update to the
algorithm in 2012 they prioritized
considering videos that had higher
attention time a higher watch time a
longer watch time but still YouTube
wasn't able to provide what an
individual user was looking for so in
2016 they announced another update to
their algorithm and that's why they
announced to do to use machine learning
and deep neural networks for its
recommendation system completely
changing the user experience of a
YouTube user in other words YouTube is
focused on hooking users into valuable
addictive content based on their
interests yes so how does YouTube SEO
work let's dig a bit deeper into the
YouTube algorithm overall the YouTube
algorithm affects the search results and
the recommendation streams so what do I
mean with
that in response to a user's query the
YouTube's algorithm analyzes videos
across thousands and thousands of
channels to return a list of the most
relevant
videos and the YouTube search results
are highly affected by YouTube's
algorithm yeah and the factor
that will make your video pop up in a
user search query are your video's
comments the likes the watch time you
can call this engagement your video's
title the description the keywords the
tags we call this the metadata that
matches the user's query yeah so a lot
of reasons yeah why the YouTube
algorithm picks your video to show up
higher in the search results now the
algorithm goes through a two-fold
process for recommending videos to a
user yeah there is the search results
but the second part of this the SEO is
the recommending video to a user which
you see on the left side after your
search results first it ranks video
Based on data of their performance
analytics so for instance videos that
are trend in they have a higher
priority second it matches videos based
on the users history and the similar
content they may have watched earlier so
ultimately they would end up spending
more time on the platform going through
as many videos as possible automatically
watching as many ads as possible so now
you got an idea about the end goal of
you YouTube's algorithm in 2022 and how
it works to create a better user
experience right now that you understand
the YouTube
algorithm how can you make this
algorithm work with you what I'm going
to do here I'm going to share 10 tips
with you on how to optimize your videos
for search so let's start with tip
number one tip number one is to make
sure sure that you conduct your keyword
research before you optimize your videos
make sure your keywords are relevant to
your
video because they allow YouTube to
determine the video topic and index the
content and relate it to the user
queries so here are five simple steps
for you to do to do your video keyword
research first start with topic tocs
that you want to be an authority for
identify those topics and then for each
of these topics you generate keyword
ideas you find those keyword ideas by go
going on YouTube for the YouTube suggest
um and you can go to Google as well you
go to other video platforms you go to
keyword recommendation tools yes so you
generate keyword ideas then for those
keyword ideas you're going to look look
for monthly search volumes and the comp
difficulty for those keywords how
difficult is it to get a higher search
ranking for those keywords and there are
tools that you can use to find out about
these keyword um metrics you're then
going to conduct a YouTube Ser analysis
so you're going to analyze the search
engine result page for your keywords and
find out what you can see yeah serp
analysis is very important because it
helps you to determine the types of
keywords that are currently ranking for
that keyword or the type of videos that
are currently ranking for that
video it helps you in determining the
quality of those videos and it also
helps you in determining the search
intent for those keywords why are people
searching for those words is is it with
a buying intent is it with a learning
intent or is it with an informational
intent and the fifth tip on your keyword
research is to select those Target
keywords that are the most uh that have
the highest search volume have the the
the the the the best competitive um
difficulty yeah so it's finding the
right balance and come up with a list of
keywords that you can start using for
your videos and then you're going to
assign those keywords to your video Yeah
and make sure that those keywords are
relevant to the content and that you use
them in the title that you use them in
the thumbnail that you used them in the
sub the the um the transcription of the
video and I'll tell you more a bit about
that in a little bit yes so it is all
about capturing the content content of
the video make it unique and encouraging
viewers to watch your content so keyword
research is a very important
topic second is to make sure that you
use the right title for your videos
titles is critical there are two
elements of your video that will
decide whether people watch a video or
not it is the title of the video and it
is the thumbnail of the video and more
about the thumbnail later so get a good
catchy
title make sure your keywords are in
your title as well yeah so it's not only
about explaining the content of the
video in a very strong title but
also encouraging people to click on the
video link yeah so your keywords and
your title play a very important role in
this
right let's look at the third tip that
is the description of your video Yeah
and for the algorithm the description is
very important the algorithm uses the
description to check the topic of the
video so make sure that your description
includes the keywords as well so the
video description is the text below each
of your videos and viewers can read the
YouTube video description by clicking on
the C more button below the video yeah
so these descriptions usually include a
short explanation of what the video is
about including the relevant keywords
links to any resources mentioned in the
video maybe affiliate links website
links maybe social media
handles definitely ask the viewer to
subscribe and chapters and timestamps
and Google now has the feature to sort
of split up the content of your video in
timestamps and people can jump from
timestamp to time
stamp so YouTube descriptions including
all the right elements like the
informative text the links the buttons
they can help the viewer to discover
your video can help you to increase your
subscribers to increase your views and
to increase your watch
time so tip four is about
tags very important to add tags to your
video YouTube uses tags to effectively
index and search for videos but also to
suggest other videos you might be
interested in they help again the
YouTube algorithm to understand what
your content is all about and to serve
it to the right
users so here are some best practice
tips on using tags don't overdo them
don't use too many
tags you use trending text yeah so find
trending topics with YouTube AO
suggest yeah so and use those trending
Texs be specific with your tags for
example a road trip is a tag that is
less Broad and has a higher chance of
ranking well in search engine than for
instance the word vacation because that
is too
generic also include synonyms think
about the words your audience is likely
to use when describing the topic of your
video and use those synonyms to broaden
the reach of your tags and if you're you
out of ideas use a tag generator to
identify related and potentially
trending tags a really good tool for
this is tune
pocket right let's move on let's go to
the next tip tip number five YouTube
creates transcriptions and captions for
your videos and you can create your own
transcription because the algorithm
can't interpret visual content only text
and code so if you can transform your
video in text through a transcription
that can really help in your search
Effectiveness so a transcription is the
translation of what is spoken in the
video and you can use this trans
description for subtitles in your video
as
well they will also help you to generate
captions for your timestamps in your
video now very important YouTube will
automatically generate a transcription
file but be aware this transcription
file will not be indexed for search the
because a raw file may have typos or
wrong translations wrong interpretations
from the Google automatic
transcriber so what you need to do is
that you edit the transcription file and
take out the typos and the mistakes and
once you've done that you've then
uploaded that transcription file up to
your video and once you've uploaded It
Again YouTube will then index the file
and use it for the
search so very important and I'll show
you later where you can find that trans
transcript
file tip number six think about the
length of your
videos focus on both the watch time and
the video
length and let's be realistic about it
if it takes 20 minutes to explain how to
do something yeah on your video then
make a 20 minute video if you can say it
in one minute then make a one minute
video Don't Waste people's time by
stretching out a content just to hit a
certain number of minutes it's not about
how long your video is it is about when
people stop watching your video if you
can keep watching if you can keep people
watching longer than average then you'll
get more views and eventually you will
get more
subscribers now YouTube wants to
recommend videos that people stay
engaged with or in other words watch
longer so if you can increase your watch
time for your videos then YouTube will
reward you with better rankings in
search results and recommendations
across their site which ultimately leads
to more viewers so a good way to keep
people
engaged is to use screens and YouTube
cards and that is tip
six yeah so an endscreen is the YouTube
feature that appears in the last 5 to 20
seconds of your video and you can use it
to promote videos playlist merchandise
and external websites your end screen
can help you to get more views more
traffic and subscribers from every
video YouTube cards are a bit more
flexible they are interactive cards that
you see throughout a video that let you
share clickable links to relevant
content throughout your video
you can use those cards to promote a
related video or playlist to promote
your YouTube channel to encourage
viewers to take a call or to take a poll
to direct responses to a verified
offsite location like a specific landing
page or to ask viewers to donate to a
charity this will only work for the US
by the way so non us um viewers canot
not do those donations to
charity right next tip next tip is
making sure that you increase audience
engagement by increasing the watchtime
of your
video yes so this is all about the
content of your video and be clever with
the content in your video try to use
elements of surprise in your video or
changing the pace of the music or ask
for audio participation for instance by
adding a quiz in your video very
important to maintain people's
interest yeah and some other tips that
you can do to keep people's interest is
to make sure you have a strong video
opening yeah where you captur people's
initial interest to make sure that you
use chapters in your videos yeah because
that will give people a guideline of
what to look out for use pattern
interrupts as we call them like music
past different Graphics different camera
angles or use storytelling techniques
why are people so interested in stories
because stories use techniques like good
and bad yeah or one extreme to The Other
Extreme yeah to actually keep people
engaged in the um in the story maybe
create longer videos for a more targeted
audience where you know they have a
better interest in watching your videos
maybe look at developing a series of
videos yeah because then you build up
loyalty and you build up kind of a
viewer membership for your video series
and then obviously use the YouTube
insights the YouTube analytics to learn
about how how effective your um your
interrupts in your video are finally
then there is tip number
eight tip number eight is an obvious one
make sure that in every video you upload
on YouTube that you promote your channel
and promote the likes the people to like
your video yeah at the beginning and at
the end of your video just like I did on
this video and I'm doing it now if you
like this video click the like button if
you want to subscribe to our video click
the Subscribe button or subscribe to our
Channel yeah very important that you do
that now a tip that is often overlooked
is the power of the
thumbnail yeah people make a decision as
I mentioned earlier to watch your video
based on the title of your your video
and the thumbnail and the more exciting
your thumbnail the more likely people
will click yeah so now YouTube will
create thumbnails for you but if you
don't like them you can also upload your
own uh your own thumbnails so you can
design those on any tool um any creative
uh tool make sure that if you upload
your own videos that they accurately
represent your
videos include a shortened version of
the title of your video yeah make sure
that the text is large enough to read
Because particularly on mobile and
remember about 60% of people watch
YouTubes on their
mobile yes so make sure that the text is
large enough to read use contrasting
colors to capture the attention make
sure that you pay attention to White
space between the images and create add
your brand logo to your thumbnail as
well and the final tip it goes out it
goes without saying tip number 10 make
sure your video keeps your viewers
attention yeah your videos have to be
unique they have to be different they
have to be
engaging the best videos are
controversial educational funny or
shocking check your anal Antics your
YouTube analytics to see and to analyze
your viewing behaviors learn from that
and tailor your content to what you
learn in your
analytics okay so those are the 10
YouTube SEO tips and now let me show you
where to find all this in YouTube so if
you go to
YouTube yeah I'll show you here this is
of a company um and this is their
YouTube kind of Channel yeah if I go to
the channel of the company then here you
see the channel it is a shoe store and
here you see their videos now I'm not
going to explain the channels to you but
here you see if you go at the top right
okay you see this little photo here
you're going to click I'm going to
switch the account I'm going to
my solution and I'm going to here have
the dashboard I'm going to look at the
content this
one how we made 2 and a half th000
African kids happy with a pair of shoes
so here you see the metadata of this
video okay so let me show share with you
the elements that we discussed first of
all there is your video title that you
can add
here right how we made 2 and a half
th000 African kids happy with a pair of
shoes then here you have your
description remember keywords actually
what I did here I took the script of the
video and put it here in the description
yeah you have a lot of characters
available here I always start the
description with the HT with the website
because that is another free opportunity
to get a link to your
website yes so there is your title your
description then if I scroll
down then here you see your
thumbnail I've picked a thumbnail yeah
the one that YouTube created for me I
can also upload my own
thumbnail okay I'm not going to go into
the details I'm just focusing on the
elements that we discussed so here you
see show more and this is where I can go
to the automatic chapter
yeah so those are the chapters that
YouTube will create for you and here you
see the
tags so this is where you can add all
the tags for your
video
okay and then you have the language
recording date
Etc and then finally here you have the
visibility here you have the section for
subtitles or
transcriptions and your end screen and
your cards remember what we talked about
so let's look at these
subtitles here you see the
file that YouTube created and that we
have updated as it were took out the
pilots YouTube does this automatic you
can download it and then you can edit
it so very use useful very powerful tool
and this is by the way if you need to
transcribe any text for any particular
reason yeah just upload the text as a
video on YouTube and YouTube will
transcribe it for
you yep and then when you play the
video yeah you see here how the
text this is how she belongs to 40% of
the from population yeah so extremely
powerful feature of YouTube the uh the
transcriptions so close that and then
here you see your end screen that you
can pick so you could a video and a
subscribe you can put it at the bottom
you can put it at the top you can put it
in the middle or you can relate to two
videos and here you see the end of the
video where you can place those uh end
screens okay and the same with the the
cards so here you see the type of card
do you want a video card and then you
can say which video do you want to
relate it to do you want a playlist do
you want to promote another Channel or
do you want to uh add a link but you
need to be part of the YouTube Partner
program in order to add links to your
cards right so that is all there is to
upload loing your metadata to your
videos a very important part to your
YouTube
SEO cool let's go on and let's close
today's session yeah with sharing my
favorite YouTube SEO tools with you
there are five tools here and I want to
actually highlight two of them number
one is can
number two is social blade tube buddy
A's keyword Explorer and
ccii so social blade is a good tool to
examine any popular YouTube
video yeah and then A's keyword Explorer
is a tool where you can study keywords
and not necessarily only for YouTube but
also for your Google
SEO one of my fav
tools on YouTube is a tool called tube
buddy it is specifically dedicated for
SEO with a lot of helpful functions yes
so it actually helps you with
performance tracking analyzing keywords
yeah and it is a very simple Google
Chrome plugin let's go to
tube
buddy
Chrome
extension yeah here is Chrome tube
bu yeah so here you see the tube bu
extension and here I click add to
Chrome ADD
extension and you will now see up here
that we're going to to add an
extension yeah it has been added to
grome and now you see here the um the
extension okay okay so if I now go to a
video let's say simply
learn social
media yep and I pick a video social
media marketing course you you can now
see that we installed tube budy as a
plug-in and we create an account and we
logged in and look at what I see now of
the video that I have on my YouTube
screen yeah I have what we call
videolytics I can see the number of
views for the video the number of
comments number of likes yeah I can see
their social channels I can see their
channels uh the the YouTube channel
I can see the best practices does it
have a highr thumbnail have info cards
been added and Screen been added has
comments been pinned Etc so some work to
do here and here I get the tags that are
being used for this video I can also
show search rankings yep and I can have
additional tools as well where I can
look at various um elements like search
Rankin share tracker Etc so
very powerful tool on YouTube through
tube buddy that gives you a whole load
of metadata of each video so if you are
doing a social media video and you want
to upload that on YouTube look on
um videos that are similar to the one
that you want to upload and look at
their tags look at their best practices
learn from that and you can use that for
your own
video okay so that is tube buddy and
then the next tool I want to share with
you is a simple editing Graphics editing
tool it is a tool called
canva canva is what I call photoshop on
steroids it is a very easy site to
create Graphics to create thumbnails to
create graphics that you can use on your
videos and there's even video Tools in
here as well that you can use yeah you
can create a design you can just say
let's see what you can create
specifically for YouTube you can do a
YouTube Banner a YouTube channel logo
YouTube display ad a profile picture you
can make YouTube Shorts YouTube
thumbnails YouTube video chapters so
lots of stuff that you can create for
YouTube where it has a set of templates
for you that you can use in your um in
your design for your YouTube video or
your YouTube
channel so very powerful tool I love
canva yes ccii is a good tool for um for
analytics so you can bring your YouTube
analytics into ccii create a dashboard
and it allows you you to monitor the
success of your videos and your top
ranking keywords so lots of great tools
that you can use for optimizing your
videos and my fa favorites are Tu buddy
Kena and ccii on that note if you are
looking to learn social media marketing
and become a digital marketing expert
then look no further than the simply
learns postgraduate program in digital
marketing don't miss out on this
opportunity Find The Cost Link in the
description box for more information
channel in today's video we are going to
be talking about YouTube ads we'll share
with you what they are what type of
YouTube ads are available how do you
create them what are the benefits you
can get with them so there's a lot to
cover in this topic of YouTube ads but
before that I am Mark campman I am your
digital navigator for this video um and
as usual if you like the video click the
like button and if you want to join our
Channel click the Subscribe button that
you can find under this video but before
we go into the topic of YouTube ads let
me share with you a new program that
simply learn has put together together
with Purdue University marketing land
sech engine journal and yes meta as well
and the good thing about this course is
that you will get all the skills in
digital marketing to easily complete the
meta blueprint print courses as well
which are very high standard courses on
everything you want to know about
Facebook and Facebook advertising so I
can highly recommend this course and
just follow the link and the link will
be in the um in the notes below the
video as well so don't hesitate but join
this video right enough about this let's
go straight into um YouTube advertising
now let me give you some history to
begin with in 2007 YouTube introduced
the ability for creators to monetize
their videos with ads yeah so I'll come
back to that later there are three
players in YouTube advertising there is
the YouTube creators there are the
brands and there is Google itself of
course well the good thing about YouTube
ads that is brands are able to reach an
audience and video creators in YouTube
they are able to monetize their uh their
videos by enabling Brands to place ads
before or during this videos initially
these ads were displayed as overlays on
top of videos or as a pre-roll ad before
the video played now in 2010 YouTube
introduced true view ads they allowed
viewers to skip ads after 5 seconds and
only charge advertisers if you were
watched at least 30 seconds of the ad so
that was a benefit for um for the viewer
they could skip the ad but also a
benefit for the brands because the
people that watched the whole ad were
more likely to engage with the brand now
in 2015 there was a new introduction
from YouTube which was the sixc bumper
ads very short fleshy ads that you can
run um during uh during videos in 2016
YouTube faced controversy yeah when ads
um appeared on extremist and
controversial videos yeah so that led to
many videos pulling their ads and
YouTube really had to get their act
together so YouTube implemented stricter
ad policies and introduced new ad
formats such as sponsored cards and mid
roll ads in 2018 YouTube introd Ed the
non-skippable ads for viewers on desktop
devices so you could not skip the ad in
2019 YouTube introduced ad pods so you
could do two backtack ads before a video
starts and they can be skipped after 5
Seconds as well now today YouTube offers
a variety of AD formats for advertisers
including display ads overlay ads
sponsored cards skippable non-skippable
video ads bumper ads and mid roll ads
and we're going to cover these later in
this
video all right so let's move on let's
talk about what we're going to discuss
in this video we're going to start with
giving you a short introduction to
YouTube ads yeah what is it where how
can you use it but then look at the
benefits of using YouTube ads and then
of course you want to know what are the
different types of YouTube ads that I
can use and I'm going to share with you
the library of ads that Google has and
which ads you would want to use in what
particular circumstance circumstance now
a very big benefit of YouTube ads is the
targeting that you can do with the ads
so we'll cover the YouTube ads targeting
and then I'm just going to go into
Google ads with you and show you how to
create a YouTube ad and you will see
that it's a very simple thing to do and
then finally we'll close the session
with some tips and tricks on YouTube ads
and that should be it for Google uh
YouTube ads so let's dive straight into
this let me give you a short
introduction to YouTube ads to begin
with so let's talk about
video and advertising with videos video
advertising refers to the use of videos
to promote a product a service or a
brand it's very straightforward video
ads can be displayed on various
platforms like desktop on TV on social
media on websites and it can take
different forms yes so it can be a
pre-roll ad it can be a mid-roll ad and
it can be sponsored content that you can
see on the website video ads are very
very powerful because they are more
engaging and more memorable than any
other type of ads people prefer to watch
things and what they see see they will
remember they can convey emotion they
can convey storytelling and visual
appeal making them more compelling than
traditional ads you can also reach a
much wider audience and it can be easily
shared across social media so it
increases your reach and it increases
your um brand awareness now one of the
issues with advertising on desktops is
that a lot of people people have um ad
banners um of ad blockers installed on
their desktop and that is a um and that
Limits The Reach of General advertising
on desktop and also Limits The Reach of
your advertising on YouTube because if I
have an ad blocker installed I won't see
any ad on YouTube now there's different
ways of getting um getting about that
yes so try to work with the your um your
audience that they um that they don't
use an ad blocker to have access to your
your content but the reality is that the
best platform for
advertising um is on or for video is on
mobile yeah mobile devices they have
they have fewer ad blockers and you will
reach more people bear in mind that
probably 70 80% of people watch video
videos on YouTube on their mobile anyway
yeah so mobile devices they're becoming
increasingly popular for video consump
video consumption more people watching
videos on their smartphone therefore a
much better area much better channel for
you to advertise yeah so they can be
much
more effective on mobile to capture
users attention and to generate
engagement because mobile are more
personal yeah and they're more intimate
than other devices so mobile video ads
are more cost effective you can Target
specific audiences and you can optimize
them for the different U mobile devices
so all in all mobile ads very powerful
desktop ads still a very good medium to
use for your video advertising now let's
go to then to the the next level and
let's talk about YouTube ads so YouTube
ads are a form of video advertising
displayed on Google's YouTube
platform yes so advertisers they can
create and upload videos yeah to uh be
displayed but then they can turn them
into ads that they can be displayed
before during after YouTube videos or a
standalone ads and they can take
different forms as I mentioned earlier
they can be pre-roll mid roll display
ads sponsored cards bumper ads and what
have you and the big advantage of
YouTube advertising you can Target very
specific audiences based on demographics
interest behaviors and a lot more and
we'll cover that in a later uh section
of this presentation so it can be a very
powerful tool for brand awareness for
generating leads and for driving sales
so let's dive a little bit deeper into
this
targeting is one of the most
effective features in YouTube ads yeah
so there's lots of ways that you can
Target people in um in YouTube
advertising you can do demographic
targeting so targeting based on age
gender parental status household income
you can do interest targeting targeting
based on your a user's interest and
habits on and of YouTube you could do
behavioral targeting based on a user's
past behavior and interactions with ads
and content you can also do the
remarketing where you can Target people
who have interacted with your website or
with previous ads you can do custom
intent targeting like targeting users
based on keywords and phrases that they
have used when they searched on Google
and YouTube yoube you can do placement
targeting where you can very sort of
specify which channels videos or types
of content you want to use you can do
topic targeting yep so you can Target
videos and channels related to the
specific topics or categories of your
business you can Target by
location and you can also Target by
device so this again is one of the
biggest benefits that you can get in
using YouTube
advertising another feature is that
YouTube ads are part of Google ads yeah
and that is Google's advertising
platform that allows you to create and
display ads on various Google properties
including YouTube including Google
search Google Maps Google Display
Network you can do shopping ads so it is
a fully blown advertising platform and
YouTube ads is just part of that so it's
the same interface if you're used to
using Google ads for creating search ads
or display ads and I'll show you later
YouTube ads is just another feature of
that functionality you can even use the
same Google ads account to create and
manage your YouTube ads and you can set
the same targeting options you can use
the same audiences that you created and
you can use the same reporting tools so
very easy very simple to set up and it
makes it very easy for advertisers to
run and to track their campaigns across
multiple
platforms YouTube analytics is another
tool that provides data and insights on
the performance of your YouTube videos
and your YouTube channel and those
insights are very very powerful you can
track metrics like views watch time and
G engagement audience demographics and
it provides information on traffic
sources Revenue generation if you have
activated that and even audience
retention how long will people watch the
video and when do they drop off and you
can learn a lot about that on
fine-tuning your uh your content so
YouTube analytics YouTube insights can
be used to analyze the effectiveness of
your YouTube ads you can check use it to
monitor your growth of your channel and
to optimize your videos and it can be
accessed through the same analytics
dashboard and the F same YouTube Studio
dashboard and you can customize and
filter the data to get more specific
insights right so then also you need to
understand the kind of the ecosystem for
YouTube advertising there are three
players as I mentioned at the beginning
of the video there are three players
that are involved in the YouTube
advertising there is the content
creators or the video creators there are
the brands and there is YouTube or
Google and all three would like to make
money and the beauty is that Google and
YouTube they put together an
infrastructure that allows Brands to
make money and that allows YouTube video
video creators to make money so video
creators they have their videos on
YouTube and they have their Channel and
when you um qualify and meet certain um
conditions like number of followers or
subscribers to your channel um number of
hours that people have watched your
videos you can
qualify for the advertising sort of
partnership yep and then when you qu
qualified for that you Google will add
you to the video Network that Brands can
use to place their ads yeah so there is
a money making opportunity for video
creators brands have another objective
they want to reach as big an audience as
possible yeah and that's the beauty of
YouTube there are so many people using
YouTube so many people watching videos
on YouTube it is a fantastic platform to
show their ads on the content before or
during the videos from the YouTube video
creators yes so the YouTube video
creators can't live without the brands
to make money the brands can't live
without the YouTube video creators to
actually reach their advertising
objectives and then Google YouTube is
the third party managing this ecosystem
as it were and Google you YouTube is
always sort of doing the the The
Balancing Act of keeping both the video
creators and the brands happy yeah so
keep that in mind advertisers video
creators and YouTube the three key
players in um in YouTube so what are the
benefits then of using YouTube ads well
let's look at some numbers the main
benefit of YouTube advertising lies in
the size of YouTube YouTube has over 2
billion monthly active users and it's
the second most visited website in the
world over one billion hours of videos
are watched on YouTube every day which
is equivalent to over
114,000 years of
video now the most viewed video on
YouTube by the way is is baby shark
Dance by Ping Fong with over
9.5 billion views as of February 2023
and the highest paid YouTube
earner yeah so in 2021 was a 9-year-old
kid named Ryan Kaji who earned almost
$30 million from his YouTube channel
Ryan's
world so not only of course there's
partly advertising partly SP
sponsorships yeah so there's lots of
other ways to monetize your channel as
well so YouTube is a channel that is out
there and it is a a fantastic channel to
get a huge reach for your campaign now
let's dig a bit dig a bit deeper there
are several benefits for advertisers of
YouTube Because of its sheer sites it
gives you as I said the largest audience
reach yes so with over two billion
active users each month it is a
tremendous Network where you can reach
everywhere in the world yeah so you have
access to a huge audience and you can
reach a large number of potential
customers that audience is also very
diverse and it spends all age groups
genders and Geographic locations
everybody uses YouTube yeah so not like
Tik Tok where maybe a younger generation
YouTube spend all age groups so you can
tailor your ads to specific demographics
and Target very specific groups YouTube
gives you a variety of AD formats as we
talked about earlier and I will share
that with you so that is a big menu of
sort of um options that the advertiser
has because of YouTube's size and it
Advanced targeting a capabilities it is
also a very cost effective way of
advertising with a relative low cost per
impression or cost per click yeah so
making it very cost effective and
another big benefit of using YouTube for
your targeted advertising is the high
engagement in user on on the on YouTube
yeah YouTube users spend an average of
11 minutes per day on the platform that
indicates quite High engagement and they
have an an incline to comment to like to
share sh the content yeah so it's a big
opportunity for Brands to build a
relationship with their key
audiences so here are some more facts
about YouTube's targeting capabilities
yes so in YouTube you can reach 90% of
online audiences in the United States
yeah so YouTube is available in over 100
countries and it's support about 80
different languages now what does that
mean for your targeting yeah so it
allows you to reach users in basically
every GE geographical location from
entire countries to individual cities or
even zip codes yeah so they allow you to
reach users based on their language
preference so you for instance you can
Target people who speak a specific
language or who have set their preferred
language on the on their YouTube account
so another interesting statistic that
over 70% of instream ads on the YouTube
platform are now delivered
programmatically yeah which basically
means there is a growing Trend towards
automated buying and targeting of your
YouTube ads so all in all the targeting
on YouTube is a big benefit of using
YouTube ads so let's look at some more
Benefits YouTube advertising is very
cost effective but it is important to
carefully plan and execute your
campaigns to
maximize your um Effectiveness it can be
coste effective based on various factors
like your target audience your
advertising goals and your budget yeah
you're getting different advertising
formats so that can relate to the cost
and the benefits that you're getting and
the YouTube um advertising is typically
based on a cost per view which means you
only pay when someone interacts with
your ad and the average cost per view on
YouTube ranges from let's say $10 to $30
but again this can be slightly different
based on targeting ad format and
competition so also use the analytics
that you you get yeah to measure the
effectiveness of your campaign and to me
to to get the ROI of the campaign that
you're
using now for me one of the big benefits
of using YouTube ads is the increased
engagement YouTube's High engagement and
targeting options makes it a very good
platform for marketeer to reach a large
audience and to build relationships with
the customers yeah customers spend an
average of 40 minutes per session to
watch videos so with over two billion
monthly active users yeah you have a
huge audience available that you can
build their relationship with and the
good thing is YouTube videos are very
highly sharable so users they share
their videos they share the ads and they
want to share it with their family and
their friends through social media and
message messaging apps so there's lots
of features on YouTube like comments
likes and subscriptions which helps with
this engagement and helps building the
um the the relationship with your
audience YouTube's recommendation
algorithm also helps to promote videos
to users who are likely to be interested
in them and that increases the reach and
that increases the engagement with your
marketing campaign so by leveraging
YouTube's High engagement High best
targeting capabilities you can build
brand awareness Drive traffic to your
website increase conversions at a lower
cost compared to traditional advertising
methods yep and then finally and we
talked about that yeah it is all about
the measurable results that you get and
through the YouTube analytics you get
powerful data data powerful insights to
optimize your advertising campaign and
improve the return on your investment on
the platform so you can get very
detailed data in like clicks impress
Impressions conversions so you can
really make decisions on improving your
campaign based on the data that you get
out of the um out of the Google the
YouTube YouTube analytics yeah so you
can also track the performance of your
competitors and Benchmark their
performance against industry standards
and that can help you improve your
campaigns as well so lots of benefits
that you can get out of YouTube ads and
um that's why it is such a popular uh
advertising platform because Brands they
really believe that YouTube is probably
one of the best channels for
advertising okay now let's look at the
different types of YouTube ads there's
quite a few of them first of all it is
important to understand the term true
view ads so true view is a type of video
ad formats over by YouTube that allows
users to choose whether or not to watch
an
ad and with true view advertisers only
pay when a user chooses to watch the ad
so that can help that you only get
interested users engaging with your
content trueu view ads can be targeted
like we talked about earlier again yeah
based on demographics interest search
history Etc yeah so they can also be
optimized for specific marketing
objectives like brand awareness
consideration or action yeah so that can
help you achieve your campaign goals so
overall true View ads they are flexible
effective yeah and allows you to reach a
large audience while ensuring that you
only pay for engaged
views so the first type of ads are true
view instream ads true view instream ads
are very popular and effective for
reaching a large audience on YouTube and
for driving engagement and
conversion so day are a type of Tru view
ad that appear before during or after
other videos on the
platform yeah so true view instream ads
are skippable video ads so you can skip
them after five seconds so they can be
up to 3 minutes long and again the user
has the option to skip them after 5
seconds and advertisers only pay when a
user watches more than 30 seconds of the
ad or the entire ad if it's shorter than
30 seconds or engages with the ad by
clicking on a call to action or
companion
Banner okay so those are the true view
skippable instream
ads we then have to True view Discovery
ads true view Discovery ads are a type
of true view ads yeah that appear in
search results on the YouTube homepage
and a long Rel related videos on the
platform yeah whether it's the desktop
or whether it's the mobile they are
thumbnail images with a headline and the
description that appears in the search
results and on the YouTube
homepage so when a user clicks on the ad
thumbnail they are taken to the
advertisers video on YouTube so they can
also appear alongside related videos on
the platform and you only pay when a
user clicks on the ad thumbnail to watch
the
video so they are very common you see
them a lot on um on YouTube yes so those
are the true view Discovery ads next the
bumper ads I love the bumper ads they
are very creative and a very effective
way for advertisers to make an impact in
just six seconds and reach a large
audience they are a type of video ad
format that are sixc long they're short
snackable and memorable they're
non-skippable and play before the video
content that users have selected to
watch so they are really good for
advertisers to reach a large audience
quickly and effectively and they're
often used in conjunction with other AD
formats like true view in stream ads
they can be targeted to specific
audiences based on their demographics
their interest search history Etc and at
iers only pay for Impressions so they
pay for instance for every 1,000 times
the bumper ad is
shown right the next one are the non
skippable instream ads a very effective
way for advertisers to reach a captive
audience on YouTube and again to drive
conversion and drive engagement it's a
type of video ad that appear before
during or after videos on YouTube yes so
they are non-skippable which means that
viewers are required to watch the entire
ad before they can continue watching the
video they selected they can be up to 15
second long and they can include a call
to action which is very important yeah
so to encourage viewers to engage with
the advertisers brand or
product and you pay uh only when the
user watches the add to completion or
the first SEC for 30 seconds if the ad
is longer than 30
seconds right and then you have the
outstream ads outstream ads are an ad
type that appears on Partner websites
and mobile apps but not on the YouTube
platform
itself yeah so they Those ads they often
play on the page rather than in a video
player which means they don't require
users to watch them to continue viewing
the content they have selected they can
just browse on on the uh page they're
designed to be mobile first and are only
available on mobile devices makes them a
great option for advertisers looking to
reach an increase a mobile audience on
YouTube yes so they can be up to 15
seconds long and can be optimized for
specific marketing objectives like brand
awareness consideration or action so you
only pay when a user views the ad for at
least two seconds or interacts with it
in some way like tapping the ad to
expand it or clicking through the
advertisers
website right and then there is the
mustad ads mustad ads are a premium ad
format offered by YouTube and they
appear at the top of the YouTube
homepage yeah on desktop and mobile
devices they're typic Ally reserved for
large Brands and designed to provide
maximum visibility on the
platform so they can be up to 30 second
long and can include a call to action to
to encourage viewers to engage with the
brands so it's great for promoting new
products or Services great for building
brand awareness or driving traffic to
your website so you can run a mustad ad
for a single day or for a longer period
of time depending on the goals of your
uh campaign and uh cost can vary
depending on factors like the time of
the year targeting options selected and
the duration of the
campaign and then finally there is the
overlay ads so overlay ads is very
effective if you want to drive traffic
to a landing page and to generate leads
yeah for a product or a service but
sometimes they can be seen as
intrusive so it's important to create
ads that are engaging and relevant yeah
so they are display ads that appear on
top of a YouTube video while that video
is playing Those ads are transparent and
can be text or image based and they
usually appear as you see here at the
lower 20% of the video player to promote
a product or a service or a brand they
can include a call to action targeting
specific audience so you can run the
overlay ad for a specific video or for a
group of videos in a particular category
or
channel so cost for the for the brand
depends on factors like targeting option
selected duration of the campaign and
the competition for ad inventory so as
you can see a whole library of ads
available yes so uh um that YouTube has
and that you can use yep so good let's
move on let's look at the YouTube
targeting we talked a lot about the
YouTube targeting so let's summarize
this targeting on the next slide yes so
first of all there is the demographic
targeting so you can Target people by
age by gender by income and by children
yes so there's the be behavioral
targeting so you can Target viewers
based on their search history the
watched videos or the website app and
activities you can also remarket people
so you can advertise your you can show
ads to people who have visited your
website so if you have a website and
somebody visited a particular product
page and then left your website then you
can Target him on YouTube with an ad for
that particular product maybe doing a
promotion you can look at Affinity
audiences so you can Target certain
interest and trades with specialized
audiences and you can look at similar
audiences so you have a particular
audience selected and then you can ask
Google can you sort of select a similar
audience with similar interests or
behaviors so very extensive targeting
options and it is one of the key
benefits that you get out of YouTube
advertising
good now how then do I create a YouTube
ad to create a YouTube video ad you have
to go into Google ads yes so you must
have an account on Google ads you just
click sign in and that will take you to
your standard dashboard for your all
your activities in Google
ads and you will find out you will see
that Google or YouTube ads is just a
particular section of the Google ads so
what we're going to do we're going to
look at the create so we're going to
click on the create button and we're
going to create a
campaign and as you will probably know
with um Google ads there is goal
guidance yeah so you Google will advise
you on the type of goals that you can
set for your campaign and based on the
goal that you specify Google will
automatically select the type of
channels it has available for the
advertising you can also decide to do
campaign creation without goals guidance
yeah so what I'm going to do I'm going
to click brand awareness and reach and
here is immediately you can select what
type of AD what type of campaign type
you want to run do you want to do a
display ad or do you want to do a video
ad and obviously since we're talking
about video ads on YouTube then you
click here on
video so you're going to do a video
Reach
campaign yeah you can do an ad sequence
by showing ads in a particular sequence
to individual sh viewers yes so that can
be really good to show viewers a series
of ads following the customer buying
cycle for instance or you can look at
people or Reach people in Audi in audio
while they're listening on YouTube with
audio based ads so we're going to go for
a video Reach campaign and then here you
see the type of ads that you want to do
do you want to do the uh bumper ads or
skippable in stream yeah or a mix yes so
or do you want to do non-skippable share
your entire message with up to 15
seconds and remember these are the ads
that we talked about in the ad overview
so we're going for bumper skippable
instream or a mix yep and then we click
continue so here is the campaign name
we'll do your budget let's say we're
going to spend 100 pound a day you'll
then have your start date I'll put it a
bit further
out let's say the 1 of August we're
going to end in two weeks or selected
date required let's say we're going to
end in two
weeks yeah so that is a
6.67 daily budget so let's bump that up
I can also say yeah the daily budget
yeah so I'm going to do a daily budget
of1 yeah and then here I have the
locations yeah so now when I can be very
specific with my location I can even do
a uh let's say
rg4 I can just Target
by ZIP code as
well yes
so and I can make that as advanced as
possible yeah so here you can see a map
even so if I want
RG yeah so I want rg7 you see how the
map expands yeah RG I can do
rg40
or
rg9 yes so here I see how that kind of
develops and how you can be very
specific with the targeting for your ads
and here you see an estimate estimated
number of Impressions that you would get
you can pick a language you can do
content exclusions remember we talked
about that where advertisers were not
happy with the um the videos where their
ads were shown so here you can say
content
exclusion and then here in the ad group
you're going to specify your
segmentation that's where you're going
to specify your targeting now I'm not
going to go into the details here but
again these are all the topics that
we've sort of discussed in the
presentation yep and then here of course
what you need is your video ads so here
you're going to specify the link or
you're going to basically add the link
of the video on that you have uploaded
on YouTube of your ads because of course
your video needs to be on
YouTube yep so that is one so you create
your ads on every you video creation
platform yep and then you upload that
video ad on YouTube and then you have
the YouTube link and that's where you
paste the link of the YouTube ad if you
don't have an ad then you can just
create one in a few steps yeah and
YouTube actually has a video ad Builder
that you can use now where you can just
use templates how cool is this yes so
now of course you need to be aware that
if you use any of these templates you're
not the only one who will be using those
templates so it'll make your um campaign
slightly more generic yeah and um maybe
not as unique as you would like but the
fact that it's in there is a big benefit
yeah if you need to create an ad from
from scratch but there's lots of other
tools that you can use to create your
video ad yeah so let's just go to
youtube.com yeah and I will take a video
let's say from one of my clients so
[Music]
do that's this one how we made 2500 gets
happy yeah so I'm just going to I guess
I'm just going to take this link in my
ad I'm going to paste the URL here yep
and then here you see how your ad is
going to be like yes so here is the
skippable you have your display URL and
your your final URL when people click on
it remember that it's the same as with
Google advertising so you can use the
display advertize the display URL as
part of your promotion yeah so that
could be uh
solution.
co.uk SL
Sumer campaign or
something yep and then you can have your
final URL as well
yeah and then you can add a call to
action in your ad yeah that can be a
headline and here you see how all of
that is going to sort of show on the uh
on the
ad yes
so lots of ways of adding your ad here
and then you set a bit for your ad and
then you basically create the campaign
and your advertising uh your YouTube ads
is ready to be executed when um based on
the timings that you've set and that is
honestly that's how simple it is to
advertise on YouTube just go into Google
ads pick an objective that has video ads
as their one of their channels then go
through the campaign setting go through
the um ad group setting select your
targeting and then link it to the ad
that you've uploaded on YouTube as ad
that you want to use for this campaign
or use the YouTube Tool to create your
video ad in
YouTube good so that summarizes how you
create a YouTube ad and now let's close
today's session with giving you a few
tips and tricks on uh using YouTube ads
so first of all keep it short and
engaging short short simple and engaging
because YouTubers have a short attention
span yeah make sure you bring your
message across in the first few seconds
of your ad try to summarize your ad try
to use storytelling tell a story that
moves your audience that builds an
emotional
connection yeah so think about
storytelling Concepts like there's a
hero and there is an uh uh there's an
enemy so there is a victory there is um
yeah there's lots of ways that you can
build storytelling elements into your uh
your YouTube ads don't forget to add a
call to action to your ads because it
encourages viewers to either go for
instance to your website or to buy a
product or to sign up for an event or to
register for something yes so make sure
that you use a call to action in your
your videos and even mention that call
to action in your videos as well use the
right target um yes so Target the Right
audience so you add reach the Right
audience because that will give you the
best return on investment on your ads
optimize your ads for mobile that is a
very important tip yes course because
many people and we're talking probably
about 70% plus view YouTube their mobile
phones so the ads will be seen on their
mobile phones and very simple yeah so if
you use for instance text on your ad
yeah on desktop it will be easily
readable but on mobile it may be
unreadable so when you make an ad always
test it on your mobile device as well
and test and check the user experience
that people will get and then of course
continuously test and optimize your ads
to improve their effectiveness maybe the
description of your YouTube ad or the
description or the title of your YouTube
ad or the thumbnail of your YouTube ads
or the opening of your ad so there may
be different ways test and optimize to
make sure you get the best return on
investment of on your ad think about how
bookmarking has traditionally worked in
the world of the web it's text based you
know if you use the bookmarks or the
favorites that are built into your
browser you tend to end up with big long
lists and folders of just all sorts of
text links that we really don't go back
and end up using that much later down
the line because a lot of times we don't
take the time to customize those
descriptions and becomes kind of
difficult to remember why we might have
even put them in there in the first
place now with Pinterest on the other
hand because everything has a visual
context to it there's a much higher
level of recall it's much easier to say
you know not just I'm looking for that
corn frer recipe but here's the specific
corn frer recipe I'm looking at because
I remember that image behind it or when
you're looking for inspiration of what
you might want to have as an outdoor
project this year or maybe you're
looking for that infographic that had
that data you needed for your
presentation it's much easier to go back
in and find it visually than it is to go
through again the traditional text based
bookmarks that most of us are used to
working with it's also a place to go for
inspiration and to gather new ideas not
just to save the ideas that you found
other places on the web but to browse
through specific topics and to spot
those little pieces of information that
you say hey this has value to me I want
to save that and categorize that as well
finding inspiration on those topics that
you enjoy and that you're interested in
to that extent it's made a lot of
changes in the way that we do idea
searching online and in fact we've even
started to see a little bit of changes
in the way Google and Bing start to
present some of their information
because of the influence that we see
Pinterest having on how people search so
if you think about going to Google or
going to Bing and running a search say
for blackberry cobbler the results that
you get back may have a couple ads here
and there they may have some images but
for the most part they're going to be
text based descriptions that have maybe
the added credibility of a website you
recognize but you don't really know what
you're going to get on the other end
until you click that link go through to
the site and actually look on it now
when you run that same search on
Pinterest you're instantly getting a
visual representation of the content and
if you're looking for a specific type of
blackberry cobbler becomes a lot easier
to take a look and say oh wow that one
sounds wonderful but you're also reading
curated descriptions that are added by
human beings rather than the metadata or
the relevant content off the page that's
pulled by a search engine algorithm and
plugged into that space now Pinterest
also makes it very easy for you to
refine your search as you can see across
the top maybe you want an easy
blackberry cobbler recipe or maybe you
want a blackberry cobbler recipe with
oats they can take the user data and the
way the information is saved and
collected within Pinterest and help you
refine those searches further so it also
has a heavy impact again on the way that
people are now doing Discovery for
different ideas and Concepts so it's
important to be able to look at
Pinterest in sort of the broader context
of what we're used to with social media
so if for example Pinterest is one of
the newer channels to you but maybe
you're familiar with Facebook because
Facebook is sort of the Behemoth of all
things social media having a little bit
of side-by-side comparison can be a
helpful way to put Pinterest into
perspective so when we look at monthly
usage data for the two sites the average
person spends about 7even hours a month
on Facebook and about 90 minutes a month
on Pinterest now at its surface that
would seem like people are way more
invested in Facebook than they are in
Pinterest and to an extent that's true
again it has a higher usage rate it has
more frequent visit rate but it's also
important to understand the context of
how we use these two sites because
Facebook is a place that is a
destination rather than a starting point
we go to Facebook to participate in
conversations to see what people are
interested in and talking about and to a
great extent to have that conversation
and engagement on Facebook itself
Pinterest on the other hand is sort of a
strange hybrid of say a search engine
and a social media site because it's a
starting point it's the place that we go
to either build our collection to look
at other people's collections or for
inspiration so we're spending as much
time offsite as we are onsite again the
same way that you might go to Google 20
times a day but not spend more than 10
or 15 minutes total during the day on
the site because you're using the site
to get yourself to another location so
where Facebook becomes that place where
you're engaging with your fans Pinterest
is the place where you're attracting
your fans researching them and what
their likes and what their interests are
so again Facebook is the place where
we're going and we're trying to get
people to stay and engage and interact
with us and sort of spread things around
but with Pinterest there's sort of an
understanding that you're getting a
touch point in front of them and you're
getting an interest point in front of
them but ideally they're finding their
way into your site into your content
again it's a launch Point rather than
the actual engagement location there's
still a lot of misconceptions about the
site who uses it how they use it whether
or not it's a good fit for a particular
business or brand so I want to clear up
some of the misconceptions that a lot of
marketers and a lot of business owners
still have a lot of people still look at
Pinterest as sort of the way it
originally launched which was mostly
about women either planning their
wedding or ones who wish they were still
planning their wedding because suddenly
they had all these great ideas there's a
little bit of designers and Foodies
mixed in and maybe some men you know
hiding in the very very corners and
edges of the Pinterest universe but for
the most part Pinterest was originally
all fashion makeup Beauty food and Home
Design now we've seen a lot of changes
in the demographics over the last couple
years in fact there really is sort of a
new reality and we're seeing a continued
creep towards this new reality So
currently nearly a third of Pinterest
users are actually men 71% are women 29%
are men that accounts for about 133% of
the male internet population now having
a Pinterest account whereas 42% of
female internet users have an account
now when we look a little bit beyond
sort of just the male female
demographic the financial numbers
they're pretty good 64% nearly 2third of
them make more than 50,000 a year and a
pretty good good percentage of them also
make more than $100,000 a year now one
of the areas that Pinterest does differ
from some of the other channels like
Twitter is that it's a very non-urban
environment so if we look at a channel
like Twitter we see a very high Urban
population much higher adoption rates
there but with Pinterest we see a lot
more suburban and even way more rural
than we see on some of the other
channels again it's just a different
demographic that's checking in here so
it becomes a unique place to go and
reach some of the people that you might
have a more difficult time reaching on
some of the other platforms and channels
2014 was really a banner year for men on
Pinterest and we really by the end of
that year saw a lot of very significant
changes they accounted for 33% of all
the new signups coming in and if you go
outside of the United States that's
roughly 50% of the signups that are
happening so we saw 73% year-over-year
growth in men registering for the site I
think women will probably always be the
dominant uh demographic that's on the
site but I think we're going to continue
to see the number of men increase a
little bit more until we sort of reach a
leveling off now an important thing to
note again when you think about how
you're getting in front of your audience
and whether or not it's a worthwhile
place to check out it's very important
to realize more men Now read Pinterest
each month than Sports Illustrated and
GQ combined so again we're getting
really good depth of insight now when we
look at Emerging Markets Korea India
China the numbers are even better men
make up half of all users not half of
signups you know not half of growth it's
literally a 50/50 split when we look at
some of those Emerging Markets so if
you're doing a lot of international
marketing or if you're primarily focused
in international marketing it becomes
even more important to look at Pinterest
and how you might work it into your
Outreach efforts now some of the top
categories for men because most people
are very familiar with which ones
perform best for women you know food
home design you know gardening fashion
all of those perform really well for
women when we look at the categories for
men geek tends to be the number one
category so anything you know technology
geeky oriented does really well cars and
motorcycles men's fashion does extremely
well gardening performs very well for
men architecture humor and health and
fitness tend to really be the places
where there's the most activ going on
but in this day and age you can also go
into foodie you can go into Outdoors
travel you can go into a variety of
different boards and you're still going
to see a lot of active pinning and
engagement and interaction by men now
with all of this discovery and with
growing demographics coming into the
site it also means that Pinterest has
some pretty impressive traffic potential
looking at some of the stats that have
come out pakora has done a great job of
sort of tracking to see how to people
engage with Pinterest you know what's
going on with the
we find that the average pin drives two
visits and six page views it's also
worth an average of about 78 cents in
sales now when we look at this in terms
of sort of verality we see that the
average pin also receives 11 repins now
if you're a big Twitter user you're
familiar with the idea of retweets so to
give you a little perspective on that
that makes the average pin roughly 100
times more viral than the average tweet
which receives what about
0.1% repins or point 0 1% repins so
again when we look at the potential for
things to spread and move around at a
faster Pace Pinterest has a lot of
potential but one of the other
interesting things about Pinterest is
the latent nature of traffic and
purchases that come in from it it's not
uncommon for a PIN to go up have a
really big traffic Spike then it sort of
dies off and then someone else discovers
it you know because they're running a
search or they're looking somewhere they
pin it it gets back into the feed nice
and fresh traffic spikes again
or people pin content without having
visited the site to read it and then
they go back and review it later so
roughly half of all visits that come in
from Pinterest occur 3 months after the
original pin was released or the
original pin was made and about half of
all orders occur two months after which
again if people are researching
Christmas lists maybe putting together
you know potential purchase lists for
things they're going to buy for their
house or for themselves it make sense
that they would do their research do
their Gathering and then go back at a
later point to to dig in a little bit
more and make that final purchase
decision now Pinterest also has some
true e-commerce potential it's not just
about driving traffic we've also found
that Pinterest is very effective at
getting those actual conversions so
looking at some of the Pinterest
shopping stats 47% of online Shoppers
have made a purchase based on a
Pinterest recommendation and when we
look at e-commerce social sharing now
not social sharing in general but
sharing of products things you intend to
buy Pinterest holds 41% of e-commerce
social sharing now Facebook sits at 37
to give you a little bit of perspective
so again far more e-commerce social
sharing taking place on the Pinterest
platform and then when we look at
purchases coming in you know I mentioned
78 cents per pin is sort of the average
but when people actually do come in and
convert and buy we see an average
purchase amount of
$179 coming off of a Pinterest referral
if we compare that to Facebook we get
$80 at Facebook and $69 at Twitter so if
we want to do the math to put this in a
little more perspective that means that
Pinterest generates on average 27% more
Revenue per click than Facebook does and
that it generates roughly 400% more
Revenue per click than Twitter now this
makes a lot of sense if you think about
it because when people are on Twitter
they're usually checking to see what's
the news what's sort of the trending
topics what are people talking about
they're not necessarily in a shopping
mindset when they're on Facebook they're
catching up with friends and with the
news sources that they follow and kind
of seeing you know just what's the word
what's happening online but when people
are on pin they're in that sort of you
know small child going to McDonald's to
get the latest Happy Meal toy you know
collect the mall mode they're in that
mindset already of gathering and
acquiring and collecting and a lot of
times they're using it specifically as
part of their purchasing decisions so
they're already in a mental state or
mental mindset when they come into your
website to be prepared for purchase
they're also going to be more apt to use
something like Pinterest to research
higher ticket items so whether that's
you know your wedding dress instead of
maybe the you know the little favors
that you're going to buy from Michaels
or maybe it's you know the leather couch
that you're going to put in your living
room instead of the pillow that you're
going to pick up at Target you it's a
higher end product that they're saving
and collecting so again you're going to
have a higher dollar amount when they
actually do come through and make that
purchase now I also want to touch on the
idea of Pinterest and how it has changed
the value of images because everyone
knows image marketing over the last
several years it's become really hot
there's a lot of focus on it and
Pinterest has really played a big role
in the development of that now if we
think back several years ago to the
earlier days of social media to YouTube
and how YouTube changed video marketing
what happened with YouTube is that we
had this explosion of consumer generated
content and that content was very well
received in fact when we looked at data
in way back in 2012 we could see that
user generated content and
professionally produced content that was
paired with user generated content
performed far better across the board
than professionally produced only
content in other words when it looked
like it came from a quote real person
rather than an advertising agency people
tend to relate to it better share it
more and have a more positive response
to the trust factor is higher and that
became a really great thing for
businesses of All Size because you
didn't necessarily have to pour as much
you know money and planning and skill
set into every video you produced
there's still a place for professionally
produced video but it also meant it was
a little more acceptable to not be at
that rate so for small businesses in
particular this was like a godsend in
the marketing world now unfortunately
we've sort of seen the exact opposite
thing happen with Pinterest because with
Pinterest we see the quality of images
going up exponentially and thus we see a
need for that quality of images and
again when you think about the visual
context why we go to Pinterest what
we're looking for this makes sense very
quickly if you're going to Pinterest
because you're looking for a little
dinner inspiration what are you going to
make for dinner and you run across a
picture like this you're not really
going to be in a hurry to run home and
make that because what is it and why
would I want to eat it but when you pair
the same recipe with a good quality
image that lets you see oh well you know
that's an egg tart or it's a frittata
okay well that actually that looks a
little better that looks tastier and
this is what we're seeing happen with
Pinterest is we're seeing all of these
bloggers and all of these websites that
are producing amazing content an amazing
video you take a site like Smitt and
kitchen she's operating out of 42 square
foot Kitchen in New York City she
doesn't have staff there's no Production
Studio there she's not a trained chef
but she puts up the recipes that she
makes and she pairs it with gorgeous
photos that she takes herself and she's
pulling in millions of page views every
single week and probably a nice Chunk in
advertising Revenue as well but the same
way that we saw sort of amateurs
dramatically changed the nature of video
marketing by using more amateurish
content again we've seen the exact
opposite happen with images because in
an environment that you need things to
be so visually stimulating to stand out
on that Pinterest page the best quality
content is what's going to reign supreme
and as you have people who are willing
to put the time and effort in and who
are creating better content that's
upping the bar for everyone else so what
it has meant for a lot of Brands big and
small is that relying so heavily on
stock photography like they used to in
the past doesn't work so well anymore
not when you're competing with really
unique original relevant images that
people are taking of what they're
producing you know they're putting up
not just a blog post but a blog post
that has 20 amazing images to go with it
and so we've seen this sort of across
theboard level of expectation that no
matter what size company you are you
need to learn how to properly operate a
camera how to put some good Lighting in
there and to really great get some great
imagery again Enterprise or small
business it's irrelevant at this point
the quality of your pictures must go up
on your website if you want to reap the
benefits and the rewards that come from
the increased traffic from a service
like Pinterest so before we get into the
next couple sets of videos for this
series I really want to sort of go back
and kind of summarize this idea of why
Pinterest is worth looking at if you're
not already Marketing in it or why you
might want to put some consideration
into some of the different ways you
might be able to leverage it really at
its core Pinterest is probably the
strongest site online in the social
media world playing off the impact of
imagery photos weigh incredibly heavily
they are the currency of Pinterest but
that allows for really fast concept
digestion so unlike on a Twitter or
unlike on a Facebook where there's a lot
of reading as you're scrolling through
to figure out is this something I'm
interested in we can react to and
process images very quickly so having
the opportunity to get your content into
that environment gives you a much better
chance to really capture someone's eyes
and get them to stop and take the time
to read the description and potentially
click through to the site there's also a
really low barrier to entry it Rivals
Twitter in terms of how quickly you can
get in there and set things up for a
base level Pinterest account you know
even getting your website verified
you're looking at 5 to 10 minutes to set
up now if you're going to go a little
heavier Duty with things like Rich pens
which we'll talk about a little later in
this series there's going to be a little
bit more effort there but it basically
has a really simple interface with
minimal management there's not a lot to
it that is going to take up a ton of
time and effort management wise there's
also the ability to look at this as a
chance for curation versus creation and
we're going to talk a little more in
depth about that idea later in the
series as well but it basically gives
you the opportunity to have a channel
that you can play in without necessarily
having to create all original content
there are some very successful and
strategic ways to leverage Pinterest
with other people's content content
rather than your own and then finally
the ability to have content segmentation
which is another idea that we'll dig a
little deeper into gives you the chance
to really Target your consumers in a way
that you can't do on any other social
media channel because the idea that
people can choose which areas of your
content they want to follow that allows
you to curate much deeper into a topic
than you would normally be able to now
there's tons of potential here for big
Brands we see big companies Enterprise
level businesses really vering it very
creatively one of the examples that I've
used almost from the start with
Pinterest is Chobani because they have
nonstop done an amazing job of marketing
and one of the things that you know
they've said is it has really allowed
them to show different sides of their
personality again that idea of the
content segmentation and being able to
dig a Little Deeper it really lets
people see more about what the brand of
Chobani is and all the different ways
that people are using their products so
so whether Chobani is leveraging it to
find recipes that they might want to
send to their Test Kitchen to see about
you know leveraging on their own blogs
research to see how customers are using
their product and from their end while
they're Gathering a lot of insight and
data again there's minimal engagement
and management going on they're not
usually in there commenting they don't
have to read through a lot of comments
and respond to them they're mostly just
curating and liking and repinning
content now for small Brands we see the
same things there's been a lot of
companies that have done a really great
job of leveraging Pinterest to get
exposure and artifact Uprising is a
great example of this one of those
companies that was a small teeny tiny
startup literally working out of
someone's basement and they had a single
product pin that generated almost 50,000
visitors into their site and in 18
months they went from basement startup
to multi-million dollar sales just
because they got the right pin in front
of the right person and got some really
great exposure so they've been using it
to do a lot of AB testing of products
that they're looking to launch before
they actually get them launched just to
see what the response is and what people
seem to be interested in and that's
really given them as a small company the
ability to gather a lot of really unique
and creative data that otherwise might
have cost them a lot of money to hire a
market research firm to put together so
there's lots of different ways the
companies of all sizes are really
working to leverage Pinterest so coming
up in the next part of our series we're
going to talk a little bit about setting
up a Pinterest account you know personal
accounts versus business accounts we'll
look at the various types of pinboards
understanding what they are and how to
use them and we're going to talk a
little more in depth about this idea of
content segmentation and the value
associated with that so if you've
watched part one of this series and you
don't already have a Pinterest account
and you're finding yourself saying okay
let's give this a try let's get set up
the question becomes how do you go in
and actually do it well the first
question you have to ask yourself is
whether or not it's in your best
interest to set up a business account or
a personal account and a lot of lot of
that's going to depend on the size of
your company and what your goals are if
you're an interior designer or a
marketing consultant or someone that
really sort of is your own business
setting up is personal may make sense if
you're a company of any size or
Enterprise clearly you're going to want
to set up as a business if you're
setting up is personal when you go to
pinterest.com they're going to let you
syn it to your Facebook or set up an
email address and a password but if
you're a business or if you're an
individual who wants to set up his a
business you need to go to business.
pinterest.com and keep in mind even if
you are sort of a solopreneur or you
know a blogger someone like that you
probably want to give serious
consideration to setting up an account
as a business and not just as an
individual that's because as a business
you're going to have access to more
marketing tools to more options than you
would just going in through your
personal account now if on the other
hand you have already set up account but
you haven't really figured out how to
Leever leverage it maybe you set up a
personal account way back when and
you've never done much with it it's
important to note that on the business
account page you do have an option to
convert an existing account from a
personal account into a business account
so you're going to want to make sure you
go with that option rather than just
setting up a duplicate so when you're
creating your business account it's
going to be fairly standard same thing
you do any place else you're going to
put in an email address and a password
and the name of the business and then
they're going to take you into sort of
your starting point and that's where
you're going to have the option to go in
and do a couple different things you
might want to create your first board
and start building some of those out you
might want to install the pin it button
or the follow me button on your blog now
we're going to talk about each of those
a little bit further down the line the
one I want to focus on first because the
one that I think it is most essential
for everyone to do when they're setting
up a business account is to take a
couple moments to verify your website
with Pinterest so so that's going to be
the last option on the right there and
when you choose verify your website
they're going to give you a piece of
code that you basically take back to
your website and you're going to plug
into the header code so if you're
someone that has access to the site you
can go do this in a matter of a minute
or two if not this is just going to be a
snippet of code that you're going to
need to send over to your developer or
your website person and say this needs
to go into the header section once
you've done that you're going to be able
to go back over to the site and you'll
notice underneath your profile you'll
see a little red check that shows up
next to your url now what that basically
does is it tells Pinterest that this is
a website that you do actually own
you're not just trying to associate
yourself with it and that's going to
give you access down the road to things
like Pinterest analytics and some
promoted pins and some additional
marketing opportunities that you won't
have if you don't take the time to make
sure you put that verification in order
so you want to make sure that you do
that is part of your business setup on
Pinterest now there's a couple things to
note about getting started with your
account even Beyond you know simple
verification or setting up your first
boards one of those is the knowledge
that unlike a lot of other social media
channels you're not currently going to
have the ability to sync all of your
other social media channels up and
that's because on Pinterest the only way
to link over to Facebook and sync up
with Facebook is to sync with your
personal account so again if you're
going in as a business you're probably
not going to want to link Pinterest to
your Facebook because there's not
currently an option in place to just
enter the URL for your business account
on Facebook to let people jump straight
into that now you can sync up your
Twitter properly because you just need
to enter your Twitter username and
password but again because Facebook
tends to be associated with a personal
account that then has access to go into
business accounts it does not do the
sync very well at all you're also going
to want to plan to clean out your news
feed Pinterest will not let you set up
an account without picking a certain
number of topics that you're interested
in and then they sort of autof follow
people on your behalf so chances are
when you first log in there's going to
be a lot of content in your newsfeed
that you might not actually be
interested in so you are unfortunately
either going to have to learn to ignore
it or take the time to click into those
boards and unfollow those Pinterest
users in those boards so you can just
clean it up a little bit and then you
want to take the time to create just a
handful of boards to start you don't
need to go in and create every board for
every topic you think you're going to
use it's far better in my opin to start
with three to five boards and flush them
out with good quality content first and
then start to see where your interests
lie what seems to be getting a response
and start to add in boards from there
you've got plenty of time to go broader
and
deeper now there's four different types
of boards you need to know about some of
them can sort of be used in conjunction
with each other some of them there's a
little bit of nuances too so the primary
type of board is what's called a
category board so when you set up set up
a board on Pinterest and super simple to
do you're just clicking and add a board
button you're going to be asked to enter
a name for the board and a description
for the board and then there's going to
be a drop- down option to choose a
category and that's again a category
board so whether it's related to health
and fitness or food or party planning
you're basically saying to Pinterest the
content that I put on this board has to
do with this specific topic so it's a
generalized board that's going to be
synced up with pinterest's existing
categories that means it's viewable to
all users people can choose to follow it
or not follow it and the content that
you put into that board has the
opportunity to be selected by Pinterest
as part of their broader category
feeds now there's another type of board
that's called a secret board and a
secret board functions in much the same
way that a category board does except
for the fact that it's not visible to
anyone accept the board owner and
approved Pinterest users and by approved
Pinterest users I mean you have added
those users to the board and given them
the right to also post their content
into it so it's basically just a way to
leverage Pinterest and all the benefits
of a Pinterest board in an environment
that you have a little bit more control
over and we'll talk a little more in
depth later in the series about
different ways to leverage secret boards
both for marketing and content research
and even for things like PR and Pitch
Outreach
now the next type of board is a places
board now you can have a category board
that's a places board you can also have
a secret board that's a places board so
again there's a little bit of
opportunity for overlap there and what a
places board does is it syncs up the
board itself with a map and it allows
you to put a geographical location in
for each of the pins that you put up now
that may be because you're literally
pinning locations in places or it may be
that you're making the choice to tie a
location to an image or to a concept or
to an idea that you've put in place but
when people click in to look at these
boards they're always going to see that
map associated with it they're going to
see the pins that are in the board
showing up on the map itself so they can
take a look and see sort of how things
are laid out
geographically and then the final type
of board I want to talk about today is a
group board so I mentioned this briefly
on the secret board page but it's
basically a collabor board it allows you
to invite other Pinterest users by name
to come in and participate now you can
have a category board that is a group
board you can have a secret board that's
a group board you can have a secret
places board that's a group board again
there's a lot of opportunity for overlap
here and really all this does is allow
you to work in a collaborative manner
with people so that you're not the only
person that's putting pins in now
there's some challenges here because you
want want to make sure you don't just
add anyone because again once you add
them you're giving them the ability to
pin as well so from the business
perspective you want to be a little bit
careful on this and who you put in and
who you give some editing access to
because it's not uncommon to see these
types of boards potentially get spammed
by a new user so again you want to make
sure that these are people that you're
actually familiar with that you have a
measure of trust in before you add them
into a groupboard so now that we have a
basic idea of what the different types
of pin boards are it's good to get a
walk through what it actually looks like
to go through that process of setting
those up so when you go into your
Pinterest page sort of your Pinterest
profile you're always going to see a
create a board option that shows up
towards the top and on the left so
clicking that create board option is
going to launch a window that allows you
to do things like enter the name of the
board that you're putting together write
up a description of what it is choose a
category these are all things that we've
talked about doing you know saying there
here's the category and the topic that I
want it to be associated with but then
you also have the opportunity to turn it
into a places board by adding a map or
leaving the map option turned off which
will make it just a regular standard
board now you can at any point in the
future turn something into a places
board without a problem now you also
have the option to make it a secret
board or not so for this instance I have
turned it into a secret board because
it's planning for a future event it's
important to note you can take a board
that has been made secret and make it
public but you cannot take a public
board and make it secret once it's
public it has to stay public so if you
think this is something that you may
want to be a secret board but maybe open
up later it's a good idea by default to
start with it as secret otherwise you'll
have to go back and build a new board
from scratch and repin everything into
that board and then once you've decided
if you're going to make it a places
board if you're going to make it a
secret board you also have the option to
type in names and when you start typing
those names in they're going to pull up
a list of the fellow pinners uh people
with accounts that match that name and
you have the ability to add virtually as
many people as you want into the mix but
you can say these are the people that I
want to have access and click that
create board button and then you're
going to see that option show up now
it's important to note the people that
you invite into the mix they won't
immediately show up it's not until they
have accepted your invitation that
they'll actually show up so just in case
you set a board up and you're trying to
figure out why everyone else isn't
showing up there now from that point you
can click add a pin and you can start
uploading pins or you can go out and use
pinest as you normally would you know
either clicking the repin button or
using the pin it button on a website and
this new board is going to show up as
one of your drop- down options for
actually pinning content and getting it
online now when we look at things like
category selection it's important to
remember that category selection is an
important part of what actually gets
your content out there into the mix so
when you take that original pen that you
first put up if it isn't associated with
a category if you pin it into a board
that's not associated with a category
it's only going to go out to your
existing followers so in this instance
it was a post by Kendall Jackson wines
so they have a little less than 2,000
followers so it's going to broadcast out
to some of those 2,000 followers based
on the algorithm and you're basically
going to get limited repin you know
Limited opportunity for exposure now
when we look at putting things into the
category now we have the opportunity
that again Pinterest may take that pin
and broadcast it out into the category
area which means you're not just getting
the exposure to the people who have
opted to follow your board but to the
millions of category viewers which means
lots of increased exposure cyclical
repins and the chance for your content
to go much much further than it would
have originally now something else
that's important to understand when we
look at things like categories and you
know we mention the idea of getting our
content out into categories or even into
homepages of people who have chosen to
follow your content is that Pinterest
has put together an algorithm in much
the same way that Facebook has the
newsfeed algorithm or that Google has
you know their search engine algorithm
so Pinterest has what's known as the
smart feed and there's sort of three key
Concepts that go into the idea of the
smart feed and how Pinterest decides
what content is going to show up
originally when Pinterest was put
together it worked much like Twitter
does that content just showed up in the
order that it was pinned and if you had
good timing for logging in or for
getting your pins up there you were
going to show up in front of people but
now Pinterest is looking at mixing
different sources of pins together at
different rates so instead of having one
brand be able to come in and maybe take
over your newsfeed because they've
pinned you know 57 different versions of
putting together an outdoor patio now
Pinterest is saying well let's maybe
pick the best of that content and let's
pair it with some of the other content
that maybe showed up a couple hours ago
but you know is still new since the last
time they logged in so the idea is that
some pins should be shown now while some
are shown later so there's a mix here
that's a little different from what we
might see on Facebook or on a search
engine that Pinterest isn't necessarily
saying we're going to take the Top Value
and put those in front of you now and
toss the rest out they're actively
saying look we know that a lot of
activity around pins is latent it
doesn't always happen immediately so if
we take that pin that someone you follow
put up and we don't show it to you for a
week or two you're probably still going
to be interested in it so there's a
little bit of nuances there in terms of
understanding that just because it
doesn't show up originally doesn't
necessarily mean it won't show up at all
but there's also the idea here that pins
have different value based on the source
and the topic so Pinterest is going to
be looking at the type of cont content
that you're pinning and putting together
they're going to look at the quality of
the pins and how other people have
responded to them they're going to use
that information to figure out which one
is going to be approved and actually
show up for you versus which ones might
not be the best fit and there's just no
reason to have it show up in your news
feed so it's going to take a lot of time
for this on that note if you are looking
to learn social media marketing and
become a digital marketing expert then
look no further than the simply learns
postgraduate program into digital
marketing don't miss out on this
opportunity Find The Cost Link in the
description box for more information
really get sort of reverse engineered
and better understood before we get into
the tips and tricks let's take a
refresher and see what exactly is social
media
marketing social media marketing is one
of the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing it's a
methodology that has Brands creating and
sharing content on social media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've promptly been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video
advertising their new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
one of these are just some of the many
ways that you've been marketed to and
the objective when it comes to social
media Market marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals now
this could be increased engagement more
clicks conversions and so on so how do
they do it with text and image updates
videos or any other form of content they
can attract the users's attention and
can drive engagement from them now
alongside publishing quality content it
also involves analyzing your data and
running social media advertising ments
now some of the more popular social
media platforms right now are Facebook
Instagram Twitter LinkedIn and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media
marketing first off social media
marketing provides great brand awareness
now with the help of interactions with
people on social media brands are able
to build up their reputation as
businesses and with each interaction
each post each share the brand is
exposed to a larger network of potential
customers who might be interested in the
products or services offered next it
gives you more traffic to your website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website outside of your usual
customer
base next it improves your brands search
engine rankings now although this isn't
the direct correlation social media
marketing does have a part to play and
it comes in helping your page rank
higher up in the search engine rankings
now if you start posting high quality
content people will start liking and
sharing it and this will in turn bring
it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who would be willing
to write about your business and then
this gives you backlinks which as you
know will help you improve your search
engine
rankings next it will give you improved
conversion rates and with your brand
being much more visible and interactive
on social media every text image video
or comment could potentially Drive users
to your website social media also
humanizes your brand now this leads to
more customers trusting a brand and
being more interested in your products
and
services and then then we have improved
customer satisfaction when your
customers interact with your brand on
social media it provides you with an
opportunity to show compassion for your
customers personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand social media marketing is also
costeffective compared to other forms of
digital marketing social media marketing
offers some of the most flexible and
relatively lowcost options available now
this opens up your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures and
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on your
investment and finally it will help you
become thought Leaders with your
highquality posts communicating with
your audience sharing content and
promoting your Authority you can have
your followers look up to you and this
this will allow you to become a figure
of expertise in your
industry now let's go into the social
media marketing tips and
tricks number one set up your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make and this is exactly why
setting up goals is very important
moreover your marketing efforts have to
align with the goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a th conversions by the end
of the quarter or 5,000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options and number
three make sure your goals are smart now
smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy and alongside these goals there
also needs to be the Northstar metric
now what is the Northstar metric well
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular northstars there's increased
engagement greater conversion rates more
leads generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your
audience social media allows you to
interact engage and build relationships
with your Audience by understanding what
they need want and desire you can
deliver content in a way that makes your
product or service the answer that
they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in forums responding to their comments
and blogs and social media taking up
their feedbacks of suggest questions
into consideration and acting on them
and so
on now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learns audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates unacademy
has high school graduates and BYU app
has high school students as
users now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform now when performing social
media marketing choosing the right
platform is really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest now let's talk about the
purpose of each of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences for
Facebook well just about everyone has an
account on it
content that is related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook then we have Instagram visual
content works best on Instagram now
although it works well for static images
and short form video It Doesn't Really
drive a lot of traffic to your website
and then finally we have Pinterest
Pinterest is also limited to static
images however it's highly effective at
driving traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four setting up a
social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen post post like tag a friend
who does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media then
we have polls and surveys polls can help
you with you need a collection that also
encourages followers to take action and
interact polls and surveys also provide
opportunities through which you can
learn from customers to understand what
they like about the product or service
or what they don't and to receive their
feedback and then we have videos and
live streams although we'll be covering
this in a little more detail further on
visual storytelling along with videos
and live streams goes a long way to
drive engagement among your audience
these will help get your followers
attention increase trust and credibility
and have a high response rate and has so
much more to offer live stream with its
live nature and having a human face
alongside your business humanizes your
brand and by extension helps increase
customer loyalty and trust and then
there is infographics articles and
images so social media calendars are
successful because of their ability to
increase collaboration within the team
help understand what works and doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective
manner next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools social media marketing tools align
to the goals of your organization with
it you can create highquality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the planning process you can plan
create and schedule post posts on your
social
calendar now some of the more popular
social media tools include buffer
HootSuite Buzz Sumo if T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content creating buyer personas
providing you insights on what works and
what doesn't and giving you templates
for different kinds of
posts
now for number six visual
storytelling visual storytelling
involves passing out a lot of
information in the simplest of forms
visually using pictures and videos your
followers are able to grasp the message
quickly and remember it for a long time
afterwards visual storytelling is also
not limited by language barriers and
this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much
more but it also has some other
advantages it helps you build a bond
with your audience visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature
and finally most importantly content
like images and videos are what go viral
with visual storytelling you increase
the chance for your content to be seen
by more potential
customers so have a look at some of our
videos so here's what is machine
learning data science in five minutes
and AI in five minutes now these are
some of our most viewed videos on our
Channel and now you know why visual
storytelling if you guys are interested
in watching these videos you can check
them out on our Channel homepage and we
also have similar videos on blockchain
devops and Six Sigma but now back to the
list let's go to number seven paying for
advertising this is a method that helps
you find a Target and reach your
audience with ease it can greatly help
with achieving your organization's
marketing goal
and this can help you improve your reach
and improve your Brand's visibility it's
payperclick model and shows coste
Effectiveness by providing great results
and return on investment it also helps
improve targeting by letting you control
who sees your ad you get to choose from
a number of different factors like
interests Hobbies personality types
alongside the basic user demographics
like age location gender and so on now
since most social media platforms have
native analytics you also get to assess
and Define the performance of your ad
campaigns now as great as it sounds
there are certain pitfalls that come
along with peer advertising first of all
your audience could get exposed to your
post too many times and tune out your
content disregarding it in the
process second it could get really
expensive for small businesses or
startups to manage a campaign to its
maximum Effectiveness third people could
pass off your content as irrelevant or
unimportant and you also have to deal
with a lot of
competition smaller companies with
lesser budgets have more of an uphill
battle to deal with than better funded
organizations next we have number eight
newsjacking
newsjacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services now it's a
popular method that's used to improve
brand awareness newsjacking uses the
popularity of current events and drives
it to your brand it helps shine a
spotlight on your products and it also
helps you show off that you are up
to-date with current events in the
industry and that your product is
relevant by extension it also improves
engagement and website
traffic now for number nine AB
testing AB testing is a popular method
for comparing copies creatives and ctas
or call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content AB testing helps determine which
of the variants your audience engaged
with the
most AB testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on and next up number 10 community and
influences joining communities helps
your brand link up with like-minded
people and other companies belonging to
your Niche it'll also help you establish
your brand as an authority within the
industry actively particip ating in
these communities can help create your
own audience of potential brand
Advocates to group up
with and on the other hand partnering up
with influencers helps promote your
products or services to a brand new
audience it helps provide an additional
layer of authenticity in YouTube which
is also a social media platform if you
didn't know here are some very very
popular influencers we have Marcus
brownley unbox there
Mr who's the boss and lonus Tech tips
each of them with more than 4 million
subscribers and finally we're at number
11 measuring and analyzing
results accurately tracking and
measuring your marketing efforts are an
important part of the process it ensures
that you're making the most out of your
campaigns now it's really important that
you find key metrics that are crucial
for your brand and these metrics can be
tracked weekly monthly or on a quarterly
basis and based on these results
appropriate actions can be
taken so on Facebook you could look out
for reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for Impressions clicks
and Impressions and interactions on
LinkedIn and likes comments and mentions
on Instagram and engagements and
Impressions on
Pinterest some of the most popular tools
used for this purpose are Sprout social
buffer HootSuite Google analytics and so
on and there you go that's our list
here's your reminder to subscribe to our
Channel and click on that Bell icon to
stay updated on tutorials lab sessions
and the latest Technologies there's some
questions you might be uh asked in an
interview related to social media
marketing social media marketing is very
Interactive
a lot of people posting information
whether it be a tweet a post uh sharing
liking engaging commenting I mean
there's a lot of things going on in
social media so some of it is going to
probably be good most of it's probably
going to be good but every once in a
while you're going to get a negative
comment so you're probably going to be
asked this question how do you respond
to negative comments well very simple
you got to be quick to acknowledge okay
don't sit on it it you know don't waste
time him and ha how you're going to
respond you really have to acknowledge
the comment and start the process of
constructive engagement to turn the
negative experience into a positive one
so let me just expand on that for just a
second we know you like your brand we
know you like your product we know
you're very proud we get that I'm proud
I like to defend sometimes my beliefs
however you got to put that aside when
it it comes to social media why because
everybody is watching you and everybody
can read what you write so you the
spotlight is on you not necessarily the
consumer the customer who wrote the
negative comment so you really have to
be cognizant here and conscientious of
what you post and response so be quick
but be constructive because you want to
turn that negative into a positive
that's really what it's starting with so
how do you do that well how do you be
constructive well see it from the
customer's point of view take off your
ownership hat if you will your manager
hat and put on the customer's hat always
look at something from somebody else's
perspective try to understand why that
person wrote that negative comment and
ask yourself how you can make it right
so if you're the customer and you are
you're customer when you go to the store
and buy food you're the customer when
you go to the store and buy clothes when
you buy a car you're the customer so ask
yourself what you can do to make it
right while you're thinking in the
customer's perspective or looking
through their eyes if you will to me
it's it's not an easy thing to do but
it's something you have to do okay so
always look at it from a customer's
point of view and then take it out of
the spotlight so really because
everybody's looking at you waiting to
see how you respond and remember this
customer that wrote the negative comment
can certainly share your comments to the
world so you got to be really really
careful I mean how many times have we
seen on YouTube
you know poor customer experience going
viral on on Via video so you just got to
really be careful here so take it out of
the spotlight so offer to resolve the
customer's problems in an appropriate
form offer up your phone number an email
give them a link to a feedback form or
get their email or phone number and call
them these are the best ways to really
spin this into a more positive
experience for the customer I mean at
the end of the day it could become
something really small and silly but
don't make a mountain out of a mole hill
if it is something small and silly how
you respond could make it into more than
what it really is so be quick be
constructive look at it from the
customer's point of view and offer as
much support as you possibly can okay
that's how you want to respond if
somebody asked that question in an
interview some other comments here so
keep track although the issue might be
solved it doesn't necessarily mean the
commenter has gone away so follow up up
with them if you resolved it follow up
with them a month later hey surprise
them two months later give them a a
discount okay you'd be surprised
positivity goes a long way and it's
always nice when somebody actually
follows up with you after the fact just
to make sure they want to know that
you're taken care of and then don't feed
the social media trolls okay so ignoring
trolls across social media will make
sure they don't enjoy the notoriety it
brings so don't even allow the
negativity to feed itself so that's why
you really have to stay quick
constructive you know look at it from a
customer's point of view and just turn
this whole experience into a positive
experience it's an opportunity for you
to hone your skills let's move on to
another question so somebody may ask you
to give an example of a successful
social media campaign okay so if you're
going in to interview for social media
manager job you probably want to do your
homework in advance look at what other
people have done
so here's a good example Spotify you can
see the Spotify ad here with Ed Sharon
Spotify mind the search and playlist
data of its user based to develop a
thematic branded ad experience on
billboards in 18 markets around the
world first of all let's just take this
and break it down Edge Sharon's popular
you can see here be as loving as the
person who put 48 Edge Sharon songs on
their I love Ginger playlist so
messaging is everything okay and then
you could see what Spotify did they M
the search and playlist data of its user
base okay so they try to understand
their audience going back to email you
got to understand your audience okay
then they use that to develop a branded
experience on different markets around
the world so they took an audience and
they really marketed this around the
world okay to something that was really
hot and trendy I'd love to see how this
thing actually performed my guess is it
did perform fairly well because when
you're Spotify ify you you're going to
pick something hot and trendy to get
people to react and so to me this seems
like just on the surface a very
successful social media campaign here's
some other things uh you can see these
ads were featured on the sides of
buildings Subway platforms along long
busy streets so it wasn't just digital
per se I mean they really went full bore
on the Billboards and those Billboards
were everywhere on the sides of
buildings again in 18 different markets
so you see wasn't just necessarily Ed
Sharon per se but you know they had some
good messaging and enjoy green light at
every red light that's pretty cool I
guess if you're stuck in traffic in the
middle of a city less fake news more
fake magic so they really took and honed
in the type of music put some good
message behind it and really put it out
there so it doesn't always necessarily
have to you know necessarily be digital
per se but they what they did was they
did did post this on the sides of
buildings in Subway platforms and
throughout different city streets for
maximum visibility for their fans to
upload to their social media okay so do
your homework okay and on this next
question you certainly want to do your
homework so if you're a social media
manager you're probably going to be
involved in some Facebook advertising
okay so this is a basic straightup
question what are some of the different
types of ads you can run on Facebook you
know you can do single image ad ads most
of us have probably seen that you can do
multi-product lead ads slideshows
collection ads video ads I mean you got
all sorts of a variety of different ad
formats here okay so let's take a look
at these ad formats single image again
most of us have seen it okay it's just
simply a single image that you know has
allows you to put some text at the top a
link at the bottom or link to your
website or your Facebook page and a
strong call to action Okay so so
Facebook has that built into their ad
platform okay so the ad images need to
be 12200 by 628 pixels it's a pretty
nice size image multiproduct ads so
multiproduct ads are represented in
Carousel form so basically it allows you
the end user to view the range of
products just by scrolling and notice
each one of these products has a call to
action so here you can see simply learn
offering up all the different courses
they have to offer so if you have a a
customer that has multiple products this
is probably the way you want to go so
video ads are very popular on Facebook
so video ads usually range from a few
seconds all the way up to 120 minutes
and again video is very engaging if you
have video use the video okay because
they receive about 10 to 30% more views
than other forms of ads okay who doesn't
like engaging with video pretty simple
you have lead ads so lead ads allow you
to obtain user details like name phone
number email right in Facebook's
environment so it allows you to collect
information right then and there so lead
ads can be effective if you're trying to
get people to sign up for something
slideshow so we looked at those
multiproduct ads where you had the
carousel slideshow simply just allows
you to rotate different creative with
nice imagery so the key here is nice
imagery okay you want to put your best
foot forward choose the right imagery
just like going back to the email
marketing you know going back to
pay-per-click you want to use some
effective ads here and images in the ads
okay you also have collection ads that's
another option on Facebook so collection
ads ads combine video slideshow or
product images taken from your product
catalog so I would recommend this for
users who want to advertise several of
their products at once okay again simply
learn has a lot of different courses a
lot of different thousands of courses so
you know collection ads works for them
you could see here you got social media
certification you got PPC certification
SEO certification okay these are all
different certification courses you
could take it simply learn and they want
to go ahead and promote all those
courses together so loan behold
collection ads offers the best option
here so pay attention those different ad
formats on Facebook okay next question
how can you use the holiday season for
social media marketing well this is a
nice segue from the previous question
because you know you have on Facebook
all these different ad types so you
could change your ad placements to ones
lesser used by other advertisements you
can also set up clear simple and
compelling offers for your users it's
the holiday season you're likely going
to have some sales and again make sure
your images have under 20% of text okay
that's a standard across the board but
again you want to have nice imagery so
think about all those different ad
formats on Facebook think about the
holti season and how you can accentuate
your ads here okay I'm thinking video
here I'm thinking a promotion in the
video I'm thinking a collection ad where
you can run different products maybe
with a promotion with some nice imagry
during the holiday season so you
definitely have a plethora of options
not just on Facebook but across social
media for the holidays because normally
you're going to have promotions some
other things you can do to really
maximize the holiday season for social
media and that's make advertisements
emotionally resonate with your audience
the holiday season is a time really
where you reflect on the air you get
together with friends and family and
it's religious and you know to feel good
in some parts of the world the weather
changes so you want to resonate on that
okay you want to resonate on that
emotion okay you always holiday season
or not you want to monitor reports to
scale successful ad campaigns and
obviously the ones that aren't
performing you want to pause okay so
with the holiday season you're likely
going to have an up ticking traffic and
up ticking eyeballs so pay attention you
don't want to spend money for money's
sake so on Facebook it's a cost per
click model so you don't want to be
generating clicks without seeing any
results so go ahead and pay attention
maximize Those ads that are performing
and get rid of the ones that aren't okay
and then connect the holiday with your
products or services so again think
about which ones you're going to
accentuate which ones you're going to
make more prominent during the holiday
season again thinking back to the
Facebook ad types I'm thinking
carouseller collection ads if you can
really pump up some of your products and
have a nice promotion with them you can
run some nice collection ads on Facebook
moving on to the next question so
somebody may ask you hey how do you make
content go viral okay I always wondered
that myself how does content go viral
it's a great question so really you're
not in necessarily in control but you
can certainly do some things to make it
more appealing for the end user to go
ahead and share it I mean that's what
going viral is right A lot of people
sharing it because the more people that
share the more people are going to look
and find it just as enticing and they're
going to turn around and share it so how
do you start that process really is what
it comes down to well create short form
content short form content is more
likely to go viral in other words a
10-minute video is probably not going to
resonate with somebody something cute
funny interesting unique out of this
world in 15 30 seconds is probably going
to go viral so what does that mean make
the visual content like images and video
it works better than bodies of text so
make sure those images and video are
really compelling and then run giveaways
to draw attention and generate brand
awareness and engagement so you can
always incentivize your users with a
giveaway or some type of promotion
that's going to maybe piak somebody's
interest you know share it with 100
friends and get 10% off as an example so
these are some of the things you can do
to make it go viral of course if you're
trying to get something to go viral you
definitely want to monitor behavior and
then tweak once you figure out how it's
performing okay you may have chosen the
wrong images you may have the wrong
promotion you may find that the
content's a little longer than you
probably like and you may want cut it
down some other things you could do here
is use some trending hashtags and topics
on your post so ride that wave if you
will for any Surfers in the audience hey
two people can ride the same wave so you
got a trending hashtag use that hashtag
with that video or post you can always
ask users to interact okay so you can
always ask them to like or share
especially if they your audience because
when somebody actually shares it that
means they're sharing it with somebody
else who also has an audience so that's
a quick way to get the ball going so to
speak the ball bouncing okay so next
question which Industries perform better
with different platforms great question
there's a lot of different social media
platforms you got your most popular ones
all the way down to your least popular
ones I mean let's face it social media
platforms are also Geographic so some
social media platforms are more popular
in say the United States than say India
or Russia and vice versa we know China
has a lot of different social media
platforms that most Americans in the
United States don't even use so you got
to keep that in mind but we're not
talking about geography we're talking
about industry so you got to also think
about industry here so generally
Facebook it's it's usually food and
beverage news and media Ecommerce those
are the types of industries that you
might tend to see on Facebook when we
talk about e-commerce you know it could
be clothing it could be you know
restaurant okay selling or could be a a
food company selling you know foods and
beverages you also have Instagram so
Instagram tends to be more Beauty food
and beverage eCommerce so when we talk
about beauty we're talking about clothes
we're talking about makeup you know
maybe shoes dresses unique Styles I see
a lot of that on Instagram and then
LinkedIn for example generally works
with you know for me I look at LinkedIn
as B2B okay so anything you know
interesting in a specific industry
you're probably going to see some news
items and updates on that tips and best
practices and of course jobs a lot of
Recruiters on LinkedIn so linkedin's a
good place for you to really put
yourself out there to find that job you
seek that social media manager job okay
so here's a breakdown if you will of the
top five again in the United States you
know for those users who are watching
this from another country you know you
may find I'll be interested if you could
get some feedback here you know in the
comment section of the video go ahead
and put you know the social media
platform you use in your country and
generally what do you see on that
platform do you see food and beverage do
you see gaming or entertainment do you
see e-commerce so share your thoughts
and knowledge with the rest of us so
next question how would you measure
social media marketing success of an
organization and this is a likely
question a question you're likely going
to get okay how do you measure success
and that's across the board not just
social but PPC email marketing display
affiliate so really you're always going
to have the right answer if you talk and
think about conversion so with
conversion is about tracking content
downloads or sales or registrations or
Legion or form submissions anything
where you're going to get something in
return okay so to me that's the general
answer here you know how do we measure
success well it always depends on
strategy but if you're trying to get a
sale from Instagram based on your beauty
product or you got a promotion you're
running on Facebook and you're running a
a lead form type ad okay are you getting
people to enter in that enter in details
on the form submission so you always
want to track conversions from that
perspective okay you also have
engagement okay so your strategy may not
be conversion maybe your strategy is
simply brand awareness and engagement
you want to know how many people
participate in the conversation for
example you may post something that's
really you know hot Trend it's trending
it's it's political it could be business
it could be a world Affair you want to
be able to measure how many people react
how many people comment reply repost
retweet share like Etc so engagement
metrics vary across different social
media platforms but basically when it
comes to engagement you can measure it
it just has to align with the right
strategy you also have awareness again
if you're just simply in it for brand
awareness okay it's all about how many
people are actually looking at it the
total volume of people okay and how
widely your message is spreading okay
what's the reach it could also be just
simply traffic to your website so you
can certainly track traffic to your
websites by clicks or shares so it
doesn't always have to be about
conversion or engagement it can simply
hey we want to drive traffic to the
website at 37 what are some things to
focus on when advertising on Twitter
okay you can advertise on Twitter
whether you knew that or not now you
know Twitter is a platform where you can
pay for advertising so what do you want
to focus on when you do advertise on
Twitter well you want to emphasize
urgency to make sure users take
immediate action you want to express
discounts and percentages why well
because you're limited in what you can
say on Twitter you want to avoid using
hashtags that don't pertain to your
brand and product I I know that may
sound like common sense but remember
your advertising in in here so you got
to be really really really careful
because you're paying you're paying for
somebody to either look at that ad or
click on that ad so some other things
you want to keep focus on is your ad
copy it's got to be short into the point
and then make sure your ads are mobile
friendly again just like most social
media platforms Twitter is no different
people are looking at Twitter on their
mobile phones so video ads should have
subtitles images in the proper ratio so
you always want to think mobile mobile
mobile mobile cuz most people are using
mobile on their mobile phones whether
that be in the browser or via an app
okay next question how can you use
social media to promote your event okay
so you got an event coming up I want to
promote it so you're going to turn to
social media and the first thing you do
is have Affiliates fans and attendees
share resources about the event okay use
leverage your community in other words
words okay you can remarket the event to
potential attendees using Facebook ads
so you can do remarketing and
remarketing is basically hey somebody
who's seen it or been there or done that
you're retargeting those people you can
use photos of attendees and social
updates so depending on the event you
can have some really high-profile
attendees speaking at the event or just
attending the event so use photos to
drive excitement about the event okay
you can create a uniform #that can be
shared across multiple channels you can
mention the event all social media bios
so don't just limit it to one you know
cross promote it on Twitter LinkedIn Etc
and what you could do is if you've run
other events in the past create a
highlight rail from prior events you
know show people hey your events are the
events you must attend they're the go-to
events because they popular they're
successful good attendees usually good
attendants and then some other things
you could do here share behind the
screens visual content and again you
could share pictures of guest speakers
along with your quotes Okay so you want
to do everything possible at your at
your disposal especially on social media
to really pump up the event next
question how can you perform AB testing
on your ads so for those of you that
listen intently on the email marketing
part remember e AB testing is key with
email marketing what are we test in an
email we're testing subject lines we're
testing layout we're testing call to
action so the same thing here on social
media you want to do continuous AB
testing to figure out what works and
doesn't work it's very simple the great
thing about Facebook is they got an AB
test feature built in so you can
certainly test different ads great thing
about Facebook I like is that you can
simply start out with an ad by running
an a test you could simply test the
imagery it could be a male versus a
female you could test test the call to
action a lot of things you can test so
things you can change are again color of
the elements you can change the
positioning you could change the
audience your targeting the call to
action I mean everything everything
because the whole point is you want to
see which one works which one doesn't
work so testing can be done initially on
broader elements and then smaller finer
details like statements in your eye copy
so you could start out big just by
testing the imagery and so the Fe em
tends to work better than mail then you
know what works in terms of imagery well
take the next step and start honing it
on say the message and then once you
figure out what message works then you
can move to the next element like CTA
some interesting questions you may get
include what are some things to focus on
when setting up your ad creative this
goes back almost to the AB testing you
want to use ad creative that's attention
grabbing and relevant for your business
so use a primary but bold color scheme
so you also want to you stay away from
clip art okay so again align your IM
imagery really is important on social
media don't use some basic cheap clip
art you don't necessarily always have to
use stock imagery either I mean it could
be imagery you took that's very relevant
and unique to your product but if you do
that don't use low resolution pixelated
images use images that are well lit so
decide on the aesthetic you want for
your creative clean minimal or colorful
and bright vibrant it really depends on
you know the advertisement what it is
you're trying to promote so some other
things to focus on here to create
attention grabbing ads show images of
people benefiting from your product and
Coca-Cola has done this forever when
have you never seen a Coca-Cola
commercial with somebody with a smile on
your face drinking a bottle of coke I
don't think I've ever seen an
advertisement so when it comes to food
you should always have somebody in there
enjoying the food if it comes to clothes
should have somebody looking like they
really enjoy wearing these clothes and
they look great in them you want to
accentuate that with you know some nice
coloring sticking with your brand
guidelines okay so imagery really is
important here so you do need to make
sure the ad works for your brand without
requiring explanatory copy the image
should basically speak for itself so
here we wrap up social media marketing
crash course if you are looking to
master digital marketing then have a
look at digital marketing Masters
program by simply apply discount code
ytb5 to get easy discounts on your
purchase find the cost Link in the
description box if you like this video
hit the like button and consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us till then keep watching keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here